the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess
club it's no secret that you'll spy the
nation's top chess Talent at the US
Women's and US Open championships in St
Louis after days of intense competition
players were shaken but not stirred
Fabiano Carana was the May with a golden
gun using the gadgets in his Arsenal to
take out his opponent and jump into
clear first beg him to joer Jova brought
her Killer Instinct to the board but was
unable to silence Carissa Yip settling
for a draw to remain tied at the top the
sky is falling for some but with tons of
games left you can never say never day
five of action-packed Chess coming up
[Music]
next
welcome back chess fans to day five of
the US Chess Championship and US Women's
chess Championships held here at the St
Louis chess club it's the day after the
rest day and the players are
re-energized and ready to battle over
the chess boort let's go to the studio
and start the
action welcome to St Louis the home of
Chess in America as the St Louis chess
club proudly presents the US and US
Women's chess championships the race to
the top keeps changing what will happen
in round five
today hello and welcome everyone thank
you for joining us I'm Katherina yova
and I am here with yaser Sahan Kate how
was good to see you how was your rest
day my rest day was wonderful I actually
got to hang out with some of the players
and play games so it was a little fun
outstanding I tell you everybody enjoys
the rest day and boy coming back after
four intense rounds of play that was so
so welld deserved we have Juan Fabiano
who is doing tremendously well he
started with two draws but back-to-back
victories have catapulted him to first
place does doesn't mean you can't have
some fun with the leader have a look it
was just one brief moment at the very
very very end King F5 and it was this
moment that caused us a little bit of
Mirth but did you see the move Knight
D2 at the very
end just had to ask oh my
God is this still winning it's still win
yes it's still winning it's still
winning I I assure you but it was a it
was was a nice moment it was a very
funny Mo moment right no at the at the
moment I'm I'm I'm kind of uh
hallucinating things so so let's not
talk about Chess
anymore our tournament leader and
defending Champion by the way just
having a little fun that's what you got
to do you got to enjoy yourself really
wishing for that rest
day lovely and Kate do the honors tell
our viewers the current standings after
again four very intense rounds and
ladies let's start with a woman so here
we have two leaders they made a draw in
the previous round Karis and be to janov
with three points out of four and then
we have a four-way tie for the third
place inen crash Anna zatonski nazzi p
and TF abrahamian an impressive list of
leaders there and in the open section
standings after four rounds in the open
section after a previous round
impressive win Fabiano Carona is the
sole leader with three points and then
we have a three-way tie for the second
place Sam shankland Hans nean and abanu
Mishra with two and a half points and
tell us about the format for the two
national championships please we have
two 12 player R Robins which means each
player plays everybody else in their
respective section the time control is
90 minutes for first 40 moves followed
by 30 minutes for rest of the game and
there is a 30 second increment from move
one players cannot agree on a draw there
are no draw offers allowed and the
traditional scoring system 1.4 win half
a point for a draw and zero points for
loss tell us about the schedule and our
next free day when is it upcoming I
enjoyed it so much today we have round
five we always start coverage at 1:20
p.m. Center time we have four more
rounds to go and then we have another
rest day and if necessary on October
18th there will be
payoffs wonderful and Christian
wonderful to have you in studio as
always you had a nice rest day I know
but you want to drill down on our turn
leaders and tell us how they all got
here absolutely it's all about the
leaders as we entering I might say
almost the second half of the event
we're getting close for sure I'm already
looking to the next FR day but let's
take a look at where our leaders stand
as we enter day five of the USS
championships and we're going to start
with the ladies section and one of the
co-leaders going into the fifth round
that is Karissa Yip International Master
Karissa Yip standing at the beautiful
three out of four points and she's
coming off a very successful event in
Mexico as you can see her line score
unblemished so far no losses drawing
round number one against Arena Crush two
important victories crucial victories in
rounds two and three and then a draw
against her co-leader beim toonova in
round four she's already played so many
of the top competitors of this event and
guess who she's playing today another
tough competitor who's coming up off a
victory that is woman Grandmaster tatev
abrahamian and as you can see it's very
tight between these two ladies one win
one loss and one draw nothing to
separate them up to this point what's
going to happen only time will tell now
let's take a look at our next co-leader
as we entering the fifth round that is
international Master begim tokir jonova
also at three points out of four and a
very similar line score started with a
draw important victory is in round two
and three against ashar and tatv
abrahamian that game against tatv it
wasn't easy back and fourth thir that
was and a draw in the fourth round
against Kissa a I have to say she was on
the defensive in that game but she
escaped with a draw and today she has a
very difficult matchup as well she's
playing against Talia serantes and also
extremely close this matchup is one win
one loss and one draw and all of these
are in classical chess they've met in
Rapid and Blitz many many times but in
classical chess it's all tight and
what's happening in the open section
well in the open section we have only
one leader going into the fifth round
that is grandmas Fabiano kwana he is
also the defending Champion entering the
2023 Edition as you can see also three
points out of four and a very similar
line score but those rounds three and
four against Jeffrey Jean and Darius Z
he mentioned it during the interview he
said I should not have gotten two points
out of those two rounds but he maximized
the potential of those games and right
now he's in sole leadership position and
I have to say he has a good opportunity
today to potentially even extend his
lead going into the sixth round he's
playing the lowest rated player in the
event Andrew Tang a player that has been
struggling up to this point and he will
for sure try to get a victory this one a
lot of exciting games coming up in round
Five Guys absolutely thank you for that
Christian the determination the stamina
of a faabi uh unquestioned uh very
impressive those last two rounds but
Kate do the honors tell our audience
what they can expect for round five the
pairings starting with the
ladies so in the round five in the
women's section we have Yan playing
asaran who is trying to get that half a
point or one point to start her
tournament then we have Crush playing
zatonski the two veterans Olympic
players US Women's Champions uh that's
going to be definitely one of the two
matchups absolutely great match up at
Marquee match up if you will please then
we have you playing p Lee playing por
kashian toir janova one of the leaders
playing cantes and abrahamian playing
another leader Yip that will be a great
match as well and in the pairings for
the
open board one we have Tang playing
Karana who is the leader who will try to
keep his leadership or incre creas it
even against others than Robson playing
Jean uh Neiman playing aronian who's
been very solid in this tournament yeah
but four draws kti he needs he needs a
victory please continue so playing
Mishra Dominguez playing shankland and
Sh playing savan as we go to the World
Chess Hall of Fame get ready for round
five I tell you I'm seeing these 2800
players Wesley so lanir Dominguez Leon
ronian all making four draws a piece
nobody seems to be able to get a victory
they need some victories they need some
victories guys for this young man Mishra
I mean 14 years young uh making his
debut and a very impressive debut uh two
wins one loss one draw absolutely that's
a plus one scored definitely an
important a couple of important
victories for young Mishra and he's been
showing great chess also up to this
point he didn't get lucky in the games
he actually played very precise chess
with the exception of um the game from
two days ago against H nean that was a
difficult Affair but out of the opening
he had a great position in that one as
well showing great preparation in coming
into this event quite impressive and
Kate we're looking at Jennifer Yu as she
gets wanded uh coming into the playing
Hall Jennifer our defending
Champion well very unpleasant start
she's not happy with her results what's
going wrong she has one point so far she
had definitely higher expectations but
you know the tournament is long still
seven rounds to go I know Jennifer she's
a fighter and she really wants to
continue and do her best and we see the
games are starting some players were
still want it uh but here we see Fabiano
Carana it looks like a London another
London I was about to say but this time
Fab night A6 repetition yeah right uh I
wanted to say this time I'm thinking
Fabby is going for a fan shedow like he
had the groom Feld at his repertoire in
uh I want to say his young ago long long
time ago a long long long time ago uh G7
G6 um I don't think he's looking for the
grel necessary because any Grom felds
with an early Bishop to F4 they don't
make that much sense now one of the
problems uh of this move G6 after this
move Bishop to F4 is that white has this
move exactly the move that he just
played Knight D3 and now this is posing
a very serious question you already
committed to the move G6 are you going
to allow me to take the center with the
move E4 you shouldn't because yes and
that's exactly what he did he played the
move D5 this is the best move in the
position the problem is once you already
committed to the move G6 you have ideas
of H4 H5 very quickly this is the way to
try to punish uh this G6 move so that's
why we're seeing E3 we're not seeing the
development of the Knight on F three you
want to keep the Knight on G1 why
because after E3 Bishop G7 Bishop to E2
once again is going to support this idea
of H4 H5 an early H4 H5 these are the
type of uh situations that we're going
to see in this game and it's going to be
a braw because black is going to try to
open things up on the queen side most
likely after the move H4 H5 white is
going to try to Castle long side so
we're going to see a back and forth
black going to attack on the queen side
white on the king side who's going to
get to their opponent's kings first
that's the question that these players
are going to have to
answer and thank you for that Christian
I've got a question for you on that one
is uh I do note that Knight H5 was
played by Bobby uh I can't believe
that's a novelty there novelty no no no
it's not a novelty it has been played
before yes it has been played
before okay uh you're obviously
attacking the bishop you're provoking
the bishop to move to my uh estimation
okay Bishop to G5 makes some sense right
Bish then you can play Bishop E2 with
the tempo later right and H6 Bishop H4
you cannot continue chasing the bishop
with G5 because KN your knight is
hanging on H5 so the question is after
Bishop to G5 and by the way this is not
the only move in the position of course
you should hide this bishop somehow you
have Bishop to E5 which is going to
provoke some more weaknesses in the
position after the move F6 don't do
anything else black Rook to G8 doesn't
make any sense you're going to lose the
right to Castle you want to go F6 Bishop
to G3 and you're not forced to take on
G3 yet you can wait for your opponent to
maybe press you with a move Bishop to E2
because uh a much more act active Square
for the bishop is on D3 right especially
if you take take Bishop to D3 is going
to come and that comes with Tempo that's
the problem because the G6 Pawn is
unprotected also I'm looking at ideas
just to give you some uh some some ideas
of how things can go wrong whoops Rook
takes H7 there you go that's a tactic in
the position let's say I don't see that
I'm just simply going to play something
like 84 and you're going to go Castle
Rook takes H7 again there you go that's
another opportunity for white because
you cannot take you're getting
checkmated check I take on G6 you get
checkmated on H7 and there's no way to
stop it so a lot of uh dangerous zones
for the black king in in this particular
game but I'm sure Fabiano has most
likely prepared this at home quite
thoroughly because it was expected he
played it already he played the London
already Andrew Tang that is Fabiano was
definitely ready for it thank you for
that uh Christian I'm I'm going to the
game of Wesley so and it's shocking to
see this particular position on the
board uh first of all Wesley playing E4
playing an open Sicilian against m who
comes again very very ambitiously into
the event and uh with the knor well
Bishop G5 at one time was considered the
sole go-to uh way of playing uh then
white started experimenting with Bishop
E3 and everything everything everything
just about everything has been played
but this was a Bobby fiser favorite uh
Bobby fiser just breathed new life into
this very sharp and very dangerous line
but today's modern engines I almost want
to say have cured the line I mean they
they I'm thinking of some games of mvl
which seem to have gone to the 20th move
and Beyond but you know now with
computers you can prepare like a small
sideline we can expect some H3 or
something that we don't know how how
that really fits into that position
exactly because Wesley is definitely
prepared yeah E7 E6 ideas of for black
involved B5 B4 the pawn on e4 a target
for uh will be a target for the Knight
as well as the bishop and I just wanted
to ask you Christian in terms of Bishop
C4 since it's such a rare guest at the
elite level has it been played out oh it
has been played out quite extensively
yes if I remember correctly this was
called the soing right with yeah don't
get me on my hobby horse there the
Soviets there was one guy from the
Soviet Union soan he played it three
times as white he lost two games and
they named the open got they Nam one
draw Bobby Fisher revolutionized the
variation and the Soviets called it the
soan variation I called it thean get out
of here that's how I remember Fisher
variation go on uh yes E6 was the move
and of course it makes a lot of sense
right don't respond with E5 because the
bishop is already on a beautiful
diagonal close that diagonal right make
things is a bit more uncomfortable for
the bishop on C4 that's why E6 is the
preferred option and now we have Bishop
to E3 B5 is a way Bishop to E7 to take
things a bit more slowly is another way
Queen to C7 and Knight to C6 is also
possible the big question is going to
come um for this bishop on C4 and most
likely it's going to go down to B3 and
then black is going to have at his
disposal ideas such as Knight D7 Knight
C5 to try to Target that bishop or maybe
even at the right moment ideas of A5
sacrific the pawn on B5 and try to close
that Bishop with A4 so at the same time
the question is is it an asset or a
liability for what we probably will see
the King on the queen side right is it
going to be a Target or is it going to
be a piece an extra piece that's going
to defend my king on that side that is
the question I know theoretically black
is supposed to be okay in this line
that's why a lot of uh players
especially with the emergence of the new
engines have understood that this bishop
to C4 is not as precise at the same time
it's a strategy because not a lot of
people play it we know ABI Manu is very
well prepared but this one is more of a
sideline so this is perhaps what Wesley
is trying to achieve with this idea of
Bishop to C4 just take him out of theory
as early as possible because he got a I
mean Ray got a taste of his opening uh
preparation Mish that is he got a worse
position out of the opening Andrew Tang
got a taste of that as well so that's
Wesley strategy but you guys mentioned
at the beginning these guys need to win
the 2800s going into this event they
need to win they're on 50% they need to
catch up with the leader who's already
on plus two they need to score some
victories and that's exactly what we're
seeing from all of them take a look at
what aronian is playing with the black
pieces a sicilian against Hans he's
showing early on that hey I want to win
as well with the white pieces with the
black pieces it doesn't matter I'm
trying to get an imbalanced position I'm
trying to win uh in this round five to
try to catch up with the leaders and
Wesley is playing a sicilian aronian is
playing a sicilian what do you guys
think Dominguez is playing no way a
sicilian as well yes against Sam
Shanklin another very well prepared guys
so this one is a theoretical battle 1
hour and 30 minutes for Dominguez 1 hour
and 34
for Sam shanglin perhaps Sam has out
foxed his opponent out of the opening we
shall wait and
see I'm kind of stunned I mean I'm
looking at Leana leavon ronian has
played three lifetimes of Chess and
they've always been E4 E5 whenever he's
been black E5 I mean he what he did in
the Marshall uh Gambit is just
absolutely astonishing he's got the
shark thing going the Shark look and uh
well uh seeing him play a sicilian is uh
simply remarkable let's take a look at
the Ladies by the way how his think he
got moved yeah right I me move three he
he got stunned uh like every one of us
here on the panel he got stunned as well
so uh there you have it I wanted to
start with U our tournament co-leaders
in the lady section just uh bringing up
uh the game of Carissa Y and we have
another king Sy in defense Karissa is
just you know it's working why to change
her opening and we have uh for the third
time I believe in this tournament yes
she starts the tournament uh uh with an
extra black and uh okay she she's look
I'm tied for first I'm tied for first I
don't know about you guys but the Kings
Indian has been working for me and uh
let's go but it's very interesting you
know T she's not a D4 player she's an E4
player almost exclusively uh but here
you know remember when Karissa was
saying she didn't want to allow Alice to
play Bishop E3 line so she play H6 so T
kind of Switched the moves she did not
start with Knight F3 she played Bishop
E2 okay and now she played that Bishop
E3 move so she got one psych
psychological uh play going on now
I've I have long had the ax system uh in
my repertoire and as white I habit
played the move Bishop G5 and the whole
idea behind the move Bishop G5 was to
try to coax the move H6 out of black so
that in the future I would play Queen D2
and hit the pawn uh that was not tatf
strategy she came in fighting okay
Bishop E3 E7 E5 all of these moves very
traditional and earlier in the
tournament uh you could have seen
Carissa do this against Alice uh lee
Knight A6 her idea is straightforward
she wants to go Knight to C 5 put
pressure against the pawn on e4 tatf
says I don't care about your pressure to
I am going for your king H2 H4 Knight C5
uh attacking the pawn on e4 Queen to C2
defends the pawn and again from White's
perspective if you let white simply go
H5 H takes G she'll rip open the king
side and your the black king will come
under a heavy assault so H7 H5 after the
move H7 H5 you're giving up the G5
square and usually it's White's strategy
to play Knight H3 followed by Knight G5
also because the pawn is on H5 it does
mean that the future F3 and G4 will open
up some line over there so as the play
gets underway in this round five this
game seems a certainty of becoming a
very sharp complicated that's why
skipping the Knight on G1 right she
wants to keep that option F3 move in her
Arsenal exactly so it's uh traditionally
uh in these uh systems you do Castle as
white you try to tuck your king into the
B1 square and again as just point
indicated F3 and G4 on uh White's
agenda right and just to give you kind
of like a back story to this one as well
because you might be uh wondering why
not H4 directly H4 is perfectly possible
and if I'm not mistaken and maybe you
remember this as well didn't we see a
Wonder leang win against Karissa with
this idea H4 when Karissa played in the
junior section A couple of years ago I
think it was this move H4 and her
Tendencies are always to stop it with
the move H5 she played H5 in that
particular case as well she got
obliterated I mean that that was a very
very bad game for Karissa so definitely
tatev shows that she has analyzed her
tendencies in the opening and she
decided to completely switch from E4 to
D4 MH I remember TF playing D4 for the
first time in her life I think last year
wow because she was doing really poorly
with E4 and she was like okay I'm going
to switch things up I'm going to play D4
for the first time in career in my
career last year and she she's been
having a very long career uh many many
decades so take a look at this age 4 is
one of the ideas but without the bishop
Pawn E3 Black's main move in this
position is C5 now you're not losing a
pawn right because the bishop is not on
E3 D5 and now E6 and we get completely
different Pawn structures especially
because the Knight is still on B8 and I
have ideas of let's say H5 take take at
some point I can even sacrifice some
pawns with a move B5 bko style and uh
get some play and some compensation like
that Rook to E8 is the main line the
game continues the theory continues in
this one as well Bishop to E3 is a bit
different E5 D5 and now Knight to A6
you've committed to a different Pawn
structure and after the move H4 Knight
C5 Queen C2 H5 and now F3 I have to say
I'm looking at the position I see long
Castle I see the weakness of the square
G5 maybe a knight Landing there Knight
H3 Knight to G5 and then at at the right
moment I will play the move G4 I have to
blast open the position try to open uh
my way towards your king the H file
sacrifice some pawns maybe an exchange
along the way and try to Checkmate you
that's the key strategy in the position
and black is going to try to do
something very similar but on the queen
side after the move C6 I'm not sure
about this move A5 I sort of liked
having that square for my queen so
that's why instead of H5 I would have
started with C6 and try to put early
pressure in the center she did not do
that she's choosing a different avenue
for uh her attack but I have to say
right now I like what white is doing I
like TF choice you mentioned the Wonder
leang and I see in your list of top
games that his name came up he also
lost well okay he also lost it with the
black pieces against prananda in 2021 so
yes a wonderand plays this with white
with uh black as well and I'm not really
sure if they're good friends maybe
they've analyzed this position together
who knows exactly uh going to our
tournament co-leader in the l section as
well let's jump over to beum and Talia
as we have an accelerated Dragon but it
was a transposition by transposition
very interesting because we did not
start a sicilian not at all night F3 and
in fact it's kind of starts as an
English and then it uh transposes into a
Mainline um or getting some sort of a
morazzi yeah yeah moroi bind but it's
it's the accelerated dragon and uh you
might
recall melik uh playing here in the
senior championship play very nice game
he had and very I mean kind of easily he
just won with black pieces devastating
attack for White's position exactly uh
we'll see uh what beam has prepared or
if Talia is catching beum uh unawares
our pick Alice Lee let's see what's
going on here again we're seeing Kings
Indian also with Bishop E3 by the way
sorry that was not what I wanted to do
Knight C6 so D4 D5 is the main line and
when I say books have been written about
that position I mean really really
really thick book so much time looking
at that Knight D7 Bishop B3 B4 oh my
gosh the did did you study the bayonet
attack CU it was John Donaldson tortured
me with uh looking at uh variations of
the bayonet attack where you go for the
very quick B4 and C5 and he worked it
out for 20 moves it was just amazing uh
one of just one of uh multiple main
lines move rookie eight that's a little
bit unusual but I mean I think uh for me
Knight G4 has been mainly line and only
line Rook E8 feels like a potential loss
of a Tempo takes takes we've caught up
with the players H2 H3 by white uh Alice
is looking to use her control slightly
Superior space slightly Superior
development oftentimes in these
positions white plays for C5 and Bishop
uh pardon me white plays for C5 and
Bishop C4 we'll keep an eye on this one
one thing I I was wondering after Rook
E8 yes uh since we know that black kind
of wishes to open up the center is it
possible to close it now with D5
absolutely uh that you want to jump now
on D4 right because if you go back then
I'm very happy to Rook is removed from
the f file exactly and Knight D4 would
be the main move right and then we're
going to take take take and black is
hoping that after all of these trades
that she'll be well
equal is that fair yeah I think since
the bishop can later be developed to
Bishop B5 Bishop F5 pardon me yeah then
it's I mean again you kind of think that
white might have a smidge of something
just because you do have still the space
and you're going white is going to have
an easier time uh challenging the file I
don't know where I want to go that's I
just go all the way back I was thinking
D4 is that too risky
D4
uh maybe it's too RIS you're kind of
like suspense I wish to go Queen F6 and
I get you uh it's kind of I don't know
the look R looks a little funky it's not
that easy to exploit it's a unusual
position and of course I you know
whenever I see uh US Women's
championships and we have Anna zatonski
matching up against Arena Crush these
two ladies have shared 12 us
Championship how many games they play
each other uh you know you got to check
in and what what are you up to well this
is a bit surprising Anna is playing a
Mainline
tarash and I remember ages and ages ago
there was one Sammy RFI that liked to
play the system as white
and as far as I'm aware black plays this
particular line not with the idea of
necessarily winning back the pawn but
just playing for fast development with
Knight F6 Bishop G5 and says you know
what your knight on A4 is terrible go
ahead and play the play the position
with your with your knight on A4 catch
us up on this one chrisan because I'm a
more than a little curious what the E
what the I was not looking at
that one I I just wanted to tell you
guys about there's this new infused
energy into these players everybody's
looking to fight after the rest day you
know that and they've had a lot of time
to also prepare new weapons as well and
we're seeing a lot of that transpiring
in today's round as well take a look at
this game between Darius VCH and Sam
Sean what a strange game C4 E5 G3 Bishop
to E7 okay I understand this is more or
less fine Knight to C3 and now a D6 now
this already signals a very clear fact
and that is I'm going to go F5 that's
why I didn't play Knight to F6 very
natural move Knight to F6 I'm leing the
Knight to G8 I'm going to launch an
attack on the king side as fast as
possible as early as move four with the
move F5 Bishop to H3 was played which is
the main line and Knight to A6 perhaps
this is something that surprised him e
takes D4 followed by Knight to C6 is the
main line or Knight to F6 and then
Knight to C6 but he chose this move
Knight to A6 Sam Sean that is and right
now Darius is thinking he's probably out
of his theory he has a couple of options
you can play the move Knight to F3 but
my eyes allowing the move E4 just
doesn't feel right it feels like black
is getting somewhere right you would
love to be able to put some pressure on
F5 with Knight H4 that's not happening
because the bishop is nicely placed on
E7 you have to go past Knight to D2 and
it just feels like black achieved what
they wanted out of the this opening so
the other option is take take and take
on d8 and go into this end game Knight
to F3 try to take advantage of the fact
that the Knight cannot go to B7 to D7
excuse me or to C6 to defend the pawn on
E5 you play Bishop to F6 I understand
this doesn't look right for black but at
the same time sure you go Knight to D5 I
go Knight to E7 I'm developing my pieces
I am fighting against the two Bishops MH
but I do like this complex of Pawns in
the center for black at some point maybe
I can even go F4 or E4 I have ideas
right for example if you go something
like Bishop to E3 maybe at the right
moment I would even have some tactical
ideas with a move F4 not immediately
because the B7 point is sanging so this
is the position Darius is thinking as of
right now another player that was
thinking for a very long time was in
fact Andrew Tang at this point after the
move Knight to H5 it does seem like
Fabiano has surprised his opponent out
of this opening because he spent around
18 minutes 18 19 minutes to play this
move Bishop to E5 that's a good sign for
Fabiano F6 a bishop to G3 and C6 this is
his plan I'm not going to once again
take on G3 immediately you have to
attack me first with a move Bishop to E2
in the meantime fine I'm getting ready
to blast open the center with a move E5
that's why I'm defending the pawn on D5
for example you take their take and now
I go E5 the D5 Pawn is defended I have
the two Bishops I'm opening up the
center I'm playing to the requirements
of the position as black and by the way
Fabiano is still in his theory not good
news for young Andrew TCH all right
thank you for uh that indeed as I just
wanted to check in in on the um sorry I
wanted to check in on the game of leavon
aronian because it's such a rare
sighting that I see him playing the uh
Sicilian and I was more than curious
what type of open Sicilian he was going
to play not at all not at all we didn't
get an open Sicilian after the move E7
E6 Hans decided Well I'm a lap in this
uh C2 C3 idea is very simple you want to
set up the classical uh Central Pawn duo
with a move D2 D4 traditionally Knight
F6 D5 or the two uh weapons that black
has to prevent white and now how would
you like to play a French defense but
isn't it somewhat unexpected uh from
Hans not to open up
position yeah I would have said so too
but it's kind of funny if your opponent
comes uh at you with a sicilian and you
could play uh an advance French with the
move E5 now of course if black plays
Knight C6 white app plays D2 D4 is in an
advanced Fringe and I don't know if this
is Bluff or Bluster but a D5 D4
preventing white from getting the
advanced French now I I do believe that
this is associated with a pawn sacrifice
this move D5 D4 and it has has um what
is it I think it's takes and queen A4
check there's some lines that I I
remember but it's not necessary for
white to go after the Pro Pawn the
normal solution for white is to play
Bishop D3 Bishop E4 let's see what Hans
did no can't guess the moves but Hans
gonna F that Bishop D2 D3 surprise move
Knight E7 G3 you called it but uh what
are you going to do if if I just go all
out on your Pawn on E5 say Knight C6
Bishop G2 Knight E7 Knight E7 G6 Pardon
Me In The Immortal words
of Nikolai manev gift me your pawn queen
E2 maybe but Queen E2 Queen C7 yeah
that's what I was going to do I was I
was really going after this Pawn at some
point I have to give it to you right
Knight A3 I mean I can go Bishop F4 but
that just
that's not exactly what you had in mind
when you were going in this whole uh
Advanced Pawn uh line I can be very
quick with development on the other hand
sure right so Queen E2 let's say queen
C7 Castle exactly and if you're going to
waste time capturing that pawn I may
have some some time for my piec to get
out quickly agreed I'm going to take on
D4 uh you going to take on D4 and pause
here just for a second so I will take
with the queen or the the
bishop let's do what's the bishop I was
waiting for the music from Jeopardy
de I'll take the the pawn and now I
agree with you Kate you are gonna you
know you're going to go Knight A3 you're
G to get your Rook on C1 you're you're
going to get develop you're going to get
compensation but it's not an open so
pardon me it's not an advanced uh French
that white is getting with this move D2D
3 now I don't actually think that this
line is that good for black I do think
that after the move Bishop D3 castles
followed by Rook E1 you do get to keep
the wedge on E5 and you will play Knight
A3 knight uh C4 and Bishop E4 and how do
you plan to develop the bishop on C1 do
you want to play Still D3 after the
bishop moves to E4 or B3 that or B4 yes
correct it's not I mean I'll I'll adjust
to whatever way that you play right I
mean if you if you play the position
with B7 B6 I'll put the bishop out the
other way if you don't I will go with B4
I'll I'll try to bring the bishop to the
B2 Square anyway uh interesting to keep
an eye on this one I want to just check
in on darush uh that was the Knight A6 a
very very
unusual uh line of play I've played
English my whole life the only guy who
ever played this against me was bent
lson and uh that was a that was a a
really fun and crazy game this
particular case with um with the bishop
on H3 I think I want to take trade
queens and play for that line that you
were talking about Knight F3 and in E4
um very uh off the Beaten Track two
players who definitely need a win is the
game between Ray Robson uh Jeffrey Jang
Ray just had a disastrous start as the
Jennifer you this is a uh well when
Jeffrey you can expect that Jeffrey
would play the pet and we quickly catch
up with the players Ray paus Ray is
ready to push F5 like in his first game
against uh saman well he didn't
recapture on D3 immediately which I find
intriguing so do you think he's
contemplating CX D3 because every you I
I follow you completely right everybody
normally would play Queen takes D3 with
the idea of getting in F5 as quickly as
possible but so why would he be sipping
his water what's that signal in the open
I don't know uh but C takes D3 looks but
you know it could be possible that maybe
that move is not very good so he did not
prepare for it so now he's wondering how
to recapture but I agree with you Queen
wi AG D3 looks very natural very natural
and again uh you
know we we do this all the time we
compare openings one opening one defense
I mean we've seen the transp
transpositions especially in the Hans
nean leavon you know you want to go you
want to try a sicilian no I'll play in
elpin oh you want to play in Lapin I'll
play a French oh you want to play the
advanced French no no no I'm going to
play this so you have all so you make
these careful considerations right so my
whole life I have been playing perk
defense G7 G6 E2 E4 D7 D6 I am black in
these positions Knight C3 Knight F6 and
the one move I have never ever ever in
my life feared is the move Bishop
F4 that looks completely stupid actually
what is the bishop doing on F4 you would
play your knight to to F3 you would play
your Pawn to F4 in fact even H4 nowaday
even H4 the Austrian attack is
considered the most dangerous uh line of
play against the perk so what do we have
we have Andrew uh and Fabby at play we
have a London with Bishop F4 Knight C3
and then uh Christian would say after
the move Knight C3 don't allow white to
play the move E2 E4 and I would say well
why not because after Bishop G7 E4 D7 D6
we've
transposed right back into the perk with
the bishop on F4 yes yes but there's a
slight difference sometimes you want to
actually have the Knight on G8 true so
you start with G6 and then D6 and then
Bishop to G7 that's much more different
especially against the bishop on F4
because with the Knight on G4 you have
ideas of E5 at the right moment right I
looked at this in recent years and the
engines are saying that with good moves
white is close to winning with the with
the move Bishop F4 yes this SPS with the
Knight already on F6 you don't have the
option of playing E5 that easily uh this
is not a good position is really really
bad I will go F3 Queen D2 at the right
moment I'm going to go for Bishop to H6
long castle and this is the type of
position that the engine thinks that
white is completely winning
very very close to it at with the best
moves and you know that these players
have analyzed um more the natural moves
in this type of structure right yeah not
good news for black that's why you see
this move D5 almost exclusively being
played against Knight to C3 to stop the
expansion in the center with E4 so which
in fact was uh Fab's uh choice but Fabby
got I this is a dream position if you're
playing with the black pieces against
the lowest rated player in the event and
you want to wa exactly you've got a
great
position likely to have the two Bishops
and uh if you do get in the move E7 E5
you're going to have more than your fair
of the uh fair share of the center oh
and guess what your opponent also has
thought for like 30 minutes up this
that's helpful too yeah that's helpful
for sure exactly Kate where would you
like to take us I would like to take a
look at the women's section and some of
the games we did not see yet maybe y uh
yen yank against eson ashita okay just a
second uh that's at the bottom here oh
okay B venic triangle system this comes
out of a Rosal Lio Sicilian uh I think
of again I use guides if I'm going to
play an opening and if I look at this
position I think of teamour Raja I have
seen him
play this specific line is black
incredibly well and very very
successfully but G7 and H H6 and E5 and
C5 so many pawn moves those intriguing
moves D6 Bishop G7 but uh first blush
black is okay because uh well it's a
closed position so the extra development
that white has when the position's
completely closed is not that meaningful
you you take some pawns off the board
and open lines then the better developed
player has a big advantage in this
position white is going to maneuver her
Knight to D5 most D without doubt black
is going to play Knight E7 many many
cases black is playing for the break F5
where's White's break well I'm curious
if I go Queen
D2 are you really going to play F5
before Castle because I'm not going to
allow you to Castle exactly I I'll hang
out I'll put pressure on that 86 Pawn
Yeah and you have right away uh but the
question is where are you going to
Castle I'm kind of waiting for you to
make that decision as well so let's say
I Castle shorts side oh you're not being
very I know you want to play G5 Knight
G6 well I thought I thought you were
going to be you know uh uh playing for a
kingside attack okay so you castle and I
put a question to you what are you GNA
do I'll put my knight in the middle of
the board good good outposts right coach
yes yes yes okay I will move that night
away AG to oh I don't like that move too
much but I don't want to trade I don't
know this looks black is getting
something will go immediately I'm ready
uh we've been seeing the Kings I'm it's
so surprising to see the Kings Indian
defense being used so often in this
tournament successfully successfully
Karissa is just taking no prisoners so
F5 well we'll keep an eye on this again
this is a game uh that asria bless her
heart she really needs to get on the
scoreboard uh because she started so uh
very poorly okay this game absolutely
but let's speaking of Kings Indian guys
let's talk about this game the Kissa
game because this one is developing very
interestingly uh against T of course t
with the white pieces Kissa with the
black pieces and after F3 A5 Knight to
H3 was played it seems like T was still
within her theoretical knowledge because
she hasn't spent a single minute up this
point C6 we're following the game
prananda versus wand leang so once again
maybe that connection between Karissa
and PR and Wonder Maybe they've analyzed
this position together who knows we will
ask her maybe at some point during this
tournament C6 and now this is a big
moment okay because you have a couple of
options as why you can go castle and to
my eyes this feels very natural right at
the same time you have to contend with
the fact that I'm I'm going to open up
the position right on the queen side I
will take on D5 if you take back and try
to uh keep the Symmetry in the position
in the structure I'm going to go A4
Queen to A5 Bishop to D7 Rook to C8 and
B5 my attack is actually coming quite
quickly that's right on the queen side
and this Knight on C5 is an asset in the
position so going backwards rewinding a
couple of moves understanding that this
Knight on C5 is already very nicely
placed okay
we have to exchange it we have to put
some pressure on that Knight because
that Knight not only that it attacks and
it's getting very close to my king but
it also supports this move A4 very
critical to the whole expansion of the
attack for black so what she has to do
she has to go Knight to F2 this feels
like the right move Knight to F2
followed by let's say Bishop to D7
Knight to D3 I'm going to address the
problem of the problem of the Knight on
C5 first this is my first task as white
and after that I even have the option
maybe I want to Castle short if you open
up prematurely on this side maybe I will
actually use uh the open the opening of
the queen side for my purpose as white
get the Rook on C1 get the Knight to B5
now that the pawn is on A5 and play on
the queen side shift my focus right
that's uh the asset that the king is
Center gives me as white so Knight to D3
I think this would be a good position
but this idea Knight F2 Knight D3 it's
not an easy one to understand right it's
not a very natural one because whenever
you go Knight F2 you're thinking okay
I'm going to keep the Knight on F2 to
support my expansion with the move G4
but that's not the correct attitude in
the position you have to address the
problem of the Knight on C5 and once you
do that you have a lot of options Your
Horizon definitely expands as why
definitely a good position for T but
once again she needs to keep Precision
for the next few moves if I can uh be a
advocate for Carissa's position for
after your move Knight F2 Christian if
we go back yes and if I take the pawn on
D5 yes let's take the pawn on D5 and
let's say now I continue with your move
Bishop D7 just for a moment I will do
the same thing yeah and the question
that I'm going to ask you after a move
like B6 I'll just I'll just wait uh are
you castling Queen side or are you
castling King side
maybe I wait maybe I go A4 which kind of
is not a waiting move like I'm not going
to Castle long side anymore after that
once I play the move A4 yeah well okay
so Knight H7 and I'm going to play for
the F5 what we've seen Kate so often and
I'm going to play for this complex of
Pawns takes takes and you take with the
B Pawn I get the Knight to
B5 and in fact now that my knight is on
B5 it's kind of awkward there it's
working like a plug for your maybe I'm
actually going to go Castle long isn't
completely out of the question first of
all how do you defend queen7 Castle long
queen7 but now I go oh you don't even
play uh Castle long not yet but once I
go Castle long you don't really have a
good way to open me up on uh on the
queen side my king is safe your king
notbe not so much from practical
perspective it's kind of difficult to
play on the queen side then on the king
side keep the king in the center just
I'm deciding which way it's all I feel
as a player I always like to decide all
right what am I doing am I attacking
inside do I castle and I keep all the
options open exactly it requires a lot
of experience which tatv doesn't have
against the king Indian because she's
not the D4 player she's an E4 player
right so due to the lack of experience
maybe this will play into kissa's favor
and we know that in the Kings Indian
against Arena against Alice she's had
bad positions actually but she managed
to turn them around because of this
experience that she has and the way she
feels this Kings Indian positions okay
uh turning our attention to our
co-leader in the lady section Knight F2
by the way was played by TV so tatv is
on the right track all right uh beum and
Talia the this is the moroy bind open
Sicilian uh
Advanced um Dragon variation and uh
Bishop e 6 uh John
Donaldson loved to play A5 A4 put his
Bishop on C6 and only thereafter play
Knight D7 and uh away you go Bishop E3
completely legit everybody knows this is
uh this approach uh I would say
thousands of games uh in the database as
black readies her counterplay against
the queen side with the moves Rook C8 A7
A6 often times coupled with the move
Knight D7 fin only in a number of these
variations Bishop takes C3 giving up
this beautiful dark squared Bishop is
often on uh Black's agenda because then
we can destroy kind of the pawn
structure and put even more pressure the
C on the C4 Pond indeed so uh they're
still early days they're still deep in
theory apologies I do want to go back to
the game of Hans Neeman and leavon and
just to see how that game developed we
have it after G3 takes on that is a
little bit
unexpected little bit I thought I
as Pawn and4 I thought we put a lot of
energy into kind of uh making that pawn
advance but leavon if there's one player
in the world that would play for a world
championship match and I had to be a
commentator please not Leon I can't
guess his moves uh this move Bishop B5
takes on C3 is a surprise Bishop D7 to
B5 uh that's also a very different uh uh
variation and he's he's doing get it
against Hans which by the way reminds me
of this beautiful uh um Sabina our
social media director has caught up with
Hans she was all happy at the dinner I
had 11 minute discussion with Hans and
I'm sitting there say well what did he
say no friends at the chess board have a
look this was pretty funny okay but when
you play a game of chess hun of course
when you're playing the opponent is you
and the opponent but you know in real
life you still like sometimes you CH is
life that's that's what you don't
understand but the chess game is the is
the only thing that matters so but you
have some friends don't you Huns yes but
they're but I I take pleasure in their
pain what like when I see many many
people here when I see them lose I I but
this is this is not like a controversial
thing everyone takes pleasure in their
enemies losing this is not like people
just lie and say oh you know well I'm so
respectful oh I love oh we're just
everyone such no no no you and like I'm
sure this entire playing hole when I
lose they take Serious pleasure in that
okay I'm I'm just telling you I'm just
telling you but but you know we all uh
we all what about friendships H like
there's no friendships on the chess
board uh there's on the chessboard but
what about outside of the CH chess is
life life is chess like
the the game of chess continues on and
off the board okay it is a continuous In
Perpetual game of chess until
death a Perpetual gain of Chess until
death okay I mean there are no friends
on the chess board or the philosopher
what chess is life life exactly and and
we are out to kill one another sort of
sort of like what he's saying obviously
I as a chess coach is this how how you
rally the troops and say come on guys
chess everybody's different right
everybody's different everybody reacts
differently to a different steaming
light uh so this is exactly what's
happening with Hans he loves to be it
seems like he's getting some inspiration
from being hated supposedly at least in
his mind he thinks that he's being hated
it's him versus the world and uh you
know when in his mind it's him versus
the world that's his attitude I have no
friends over the chessboard or outside
the chessboard chess is life and we're
playing until death so that's kind of
what he brings to the table I love it I
like it how about you guys I like the
line of Mogadishu he was saying that uh
you know I need more haters all all the
haters I have have become my friends
right I need more haters that's right
maybe not a bad thing I thought it was a
pretty funny line I mean need more
haters Kate jump in on this I don't know
like liking when your friends lose I I
don't agree with that or your teammates
or yeah like teammates your schoolmates
you know you're no but he doesn't have
any friends that's the thing he doesn't
have any friends he said I don't have
any
friends but you know that was always
very difficult for me like I I had a lot
of very close friends growing up and we
would go to these tournaments all the
time and we had what we call Brotherhood
pairings like we get paired you know we
go from Seattle to Portland and then we
get paired against one another in the
rounds and it's like no I could always
play you in Seattle so I had trouble
playing against my friends uh over the
board because I didn't want to lose I
didn't want to beat them I you know so
this was always tough but Hans no
problem I'm curious how he would do at
like Olympic team event or world team
event because there he has to cheer for
his friends or enemies and Away you go
uh I dare D not ask you in the game
between Hans and Devon if we are in some
crazy no no no there's no Theory the
there's no Theory I've never seen these
moves before take us away no no no we
left uh the Green Pastures of theory
long time ago I think somewhere around
D3 was still a move Knight to E7 but G3
was only played once and by the way by
hakobian who might have have trained
with leavon as well in the past they're
both of Armenian Origins dtc3 btc3 Dake
C3 was by the way the first novelty in
the position and in fact it was the best
move according to the engine is not very
natural because do you want to help
white to strengthen the center doesn't
feel like the right way to do things
right but he has something very specific
in mind and that was uh illustrated by
the next few moves Bishop D7 Bishop B5
you're losing some tempies but you're
forcing the change of the structure of
course white is not going to go D4
that's not going to allow me to Castle
anymore not a good sign right don't play
like this I will keep the bishop on E6
you will attack it but it doesn't really
matter H you're very far away from doing
castle and that's bad news for white so
you have to stop this threat of Bishop
takes D3 with a move C4 Bishop C6 castle
that's what we have Knight to F5 Bishop
to B2 and Bishop to E7 right this is the
position now we understand why did you
want to provoke this move C4 because now
you have some sort of a control over the
D4 square and once you play D4 as white
which most likely will arise in the
position well then I'm going to exchange
the light Square Bishops if you do take
on D4 back with the Knight I'm also
going to have a better Pawn structure
long term right white has some Dynamic
play because of the structure I have
nice control over the B file I have the
night and I have a couple of uh extra
tempies in terms of development I almost
finished my development I also castled
you still a couple of moves away from
doing that so white has its trumps in
the position black has his own trumps as
well very balanced I have to say and
this is going to favor just simply the
better player the player that is more
comfortable with the imbalances that we
see right now in the position perhaps
the player with no
friends and we know leevon has a lot of
friends
I I I've seen uh leavon being
cheered by uh fans here at the US
championships as well as at the
singfield cup um it seems like uh he
brings out the best in the locals I
wanted to turn our attention to the game
of Wesley so for just a moment uh Wesley
versus Mishra again Wesley kind of
complaining that uh he's playing this
Berlin defense making easy draws with
the black pieces but not getting any
wins he's going to have to sharpen up
his openings well guess what uh in this
line of the fiser variation of the
nidorf he got a very double-edged
position H2 H4 and Mishra said well
that's an invitation for me to make the
classical sicil open Sicilian exchange
sacrifice Rook takes E3 we have seen
this in thousands of games is this one
of those positions Kate before I go any
further
where you uh would make the exchange
sacrifice yourself as black yes I like
the sacrifices on C3 I think it allows
black a very easy play right because you
do have two Targets you have C3 targets
you have A3 a Target and you just want
to improve your night you want to put
something on the C file uh I remember a
lot of games that I played like this and
I think I have quite good results but I
also remember one horrible game that I
lost to Grand Master Carlson pontus as
white within like 20 mov because I
completely forgot I just blanked about
Rook C3 he he I mean exchanged I mean he
captured there and game was over in like
eight moves wow uh yeah I've always
thought that these are great sacrifices
and practically speaking it's so hard
for the second player uh to keep up uh
Knight B6 as you just described it very
very well plan a knight on C4 the pardon
me the uh A3 Pawn very often becomes a
Target after moves like D5 and well that
King you know it starts to feel a little
bit uncomfortable but Wesley it I mean
look at Wesley's time 1 hour 30 30
minutes or 29 now
like I mean it's amazing and Wesley is
just one of those players by the way who
is so I want to say practical he says
okay go ahead do your worst you messed
up my structure on the the uh uh Queen
side but if I play King A2 if I get my
Rook to D3 I'll cover my weaknesses I
don't know uh it it sure feels like
black is having the fun here's a
close-up graphic of uh Wesley so former
three-time US chest Champion age 29 USC
of rating
2822 wow what a great number and yes
three-time us chess champion 29 years
young I I've been calling his I've been
calling his game for two decades it
feels like
he's today is his birthday no way it's
either today or yesterday it it was
perhaps yesterday but right now this is
some misinformation were spreading right
there it's he's not 29 years of age he's
30 um yesterday was his birthday happy
birthday was oh congratulations indeed
30 but I got to tell you he he's been
around around for a long long time and
his games have been absolutely fantastic
to call uh he's played this very very
quickly are we in are we in theory no I
mean we're very far away from Theory
because he's like more than 90 minutes I
think it has to be his theory you can
just I mean walk into that sacrifice
without knowing what you next it's his
theory definitely but it hasn't been
played before now the question is no no
no it hasn't question is what is his
preparation because and I believe that
is's game exactly is we're focusing
Mishra they're sporting that white uh
shirt so perhaps that's why um we got
confused but yeah this is the position
and I'm trying to understand what is
your preparation after Bishop to C1
Queen to you have to continue the attack
of you have to continue the attack over
the pawn on A3 and the most que the most
natural why not right let's go yeah what
do you do no you cannot defend with King
A2 that would be a very bad move because
after D5 I'm coming I'm coming in the
position and and you're in big big
trouble Bishop takes A3 is coming and
that's going to come with direct
consequences you're losing you're
getting checkmated so that's not a good
idea but how do you defend Knight to B3
I understand you can do this but now I
can even take on A3 but that was my
question could but
I'm can I that position go King A2 or
maybe Queen A4 Bishop takes
D5 but I had this crazy IDE no your
Queen's KN trap sorry Rook A1 Queen
takes A3 if my Pawn were on
E5 okay yeah that's not happening and
right now your Rook is kind of stranded
on a one yeah I'm not I'm not proud of
my a pawn uh for the exchange the two
Bishops with the center potentially
opening up at some some point and I have
a lot of pressure still on the C
file the center is going to be open two
Bishops this would be good for black I'm
not proud of my uh play here as white so
that's what I'm wondering I know it's
his preparation but what is his
preparation once more Queen A5
yeah maybe you want to go for the attack
right maybe you go look let's let's try
to kill black on this side right G5 why
not right okay if I take take take maybe
G6 am I getting checkmated as black it
doesn't seem like I am no no your Bishop
will go to F6 and you will be proud
that's the thing that's the thing I
always have the dark for Bishop next to
my king and you don't have your dark
Square Bishop to challenge it no because
you have to exchange it on A3 no this
this this can't be this is so imprac
once again Queen A5 could I just see
another uh potential defense Rook D3
this is a little bit of a stupid the
idea is if you take on A3 then I let's
go D5 I'm not I don't want to play H6
this looks like an interesting move I
guess the idea is to go Bishop to G5 uh
but I don't want to play like this I
want to play D5 this is the most natural
way I hate this position actually I just
don't intuitively it just feels like
black is it's so easy to play for black
right as white I have to just keep
defending and that's not what you want
to do when you have white pieces that's
right you want to have fun with white
not defending your king and that's what
this is all going on here black is
having all theun no no no no I I
definitely would not suggest this
whatsoever for Wesley but again he's
played it so quickly so fast he's
analyzed something no for sure he's
curious what's going to unfold because
there has to be something absolutely
just before we do take a quick break I
did want to check in what I think is
just an absolutely huge game between two
great competitors and Olympian and that
is between lanir and uh Sam Shanklin
keeping in mind that Sam is just half a
point behind
Fabby feeling a little ambitious as he's
knows that lanir is having a solid
tournament castles Queen B7 Rook G1 Rook
d8 wow what can I say this is one of
those open Sicilians with a very unusual
Pond structure but I like the G file for
white this is a different position than
in Wesley's game very much so right I
mean you do have an an an instant and
direct Highway towards black king the
last move Rook d8 kind of intimating
that I can cover the G7 square like you
could take on on E5 and try to plan a
bishop on H6 but I do have Bishop f8 I
do have Knight E8 defenses and well you
have to put a lot of energy in the
meanwhile by the way just just a
reminder
you know the pawn on e4 is hanging there
are ideas of takes on F4 Knight E5 I I
like this imbalance I would say uh
whoever has prepared this position best
uh will I get an advantage as we go on
break as we know at the end of our first
break we always like to check in with
our friends at QB our our friends who
are offering 5% for friends and family
discount let's see what's the special
today well check this out we have an
oversized button-down 2023 us Chess
Championship jacket look at that that is
so well that is just so nice uh a brand
new look these oversized button- down
long sleeve shirts proba me not jacket
shirts of the 2023 us Chess Championship
the thick collared shirt comes in both
men's and women's Styles sporting uh on
the Hem either the logo of the 2023 us
Chess Championship open field or or the
women's field respectively the official
logo of the St Louis chess club can also
be found on the nape of the neck these
shirts are made of whoa this takes some
while 69% polyester 29% rayon and 2%
spandex uh I want that tested 69 and 29
available at Q Boutique St louis.com for
all your chess shopping needs and we're
going to see you at the end of this
break where we bring you a special
message from the board of directors of
St Louis chess club
[Music]
join
yeah um it's amazing what the club has
done for chess in general because I mean
it's already been 15 years and they've
done countless uh national championships
tournaments for juniors helping around
schools and they've just grown the game
so much across the UN un States I think
if I look at my own career and I look at
American chest in general we're in a
much better place than we were 15 years
ago and so the contributions have been
immense and of course it's all thanks to
Dr Jun singfield and Rex
singfield I would say that St lucious
Club is like a rock in the ocean of
Chess and we know that it's it's there
it is there it will be there I think it
sense a hope that the game of chess will
always stay Alat by the M fact of its
existence I think it it it sends
positive waves across the
globe the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States we bring the educational benefits
of Chess to thousands of students across
the St Louis area we also promote Chess
at the highest levels hosting all levels
of the US championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best play ERS become a
member and enjoy perks such as free
classes and lectures weekly tournaments
and so much more visit St Louis chess
club.org to claim your membership
today the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Louis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess has intrigued people around
the world for nearly 1,500 years stop by
and learn about the impact of Chess from
our three floors showcasing the artart
culture and history of the game the
World Chess Hall of Fame has something
for everyone to enjoy for more
information on current exhibits please
visit World Chess h.org
[Music]
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85,000 students in both in
school and after school programs we
created the select chess training
program and the junior select chess
training program in order to elevate the
skill level in students across the St
Louis area these students receive
professional training from Grandmaster
veran niobian other programs include
chess cops a partnership with the St
Louis Police Department looking to
improve relationships between atrisk
kids and police officers in the St Louis
area with over 600 students playing
chess over the board since
2019 the St Louis chess club has also
created a chess merit badge for the
scouts BSA quickly becoming one of the
most popular badges with more than
250,000 Scouts earning the badge since
2011 students of chess can also pick up
a copy of read and write chess thanks to
Club co-founder Dr jeie Ken sinkfield
anyone can learn how to understand chess
notation in no time we view chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting St Louis chess club.org
education St Louis the chess capital of
the United States boasts the worldclass
St Louis chess club and the World Chess
Hall of Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at CU Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chest
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q Boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to
enjoy the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States and is among the best in the
world thanks to co-founders Dr jeie
Karen sinkfield and Rex sinkfield the St
Louis chess club is a nonprofit
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess locally and
internationally we bring the educational
benefits of Chess to thousands of
students across the St Louis area
promoting cognitive development critical
thinking concentration and analytical
skills the St Louis chess club welcomes
chess lovers of any age and skill level
to come and enjoy the game of chess we
also promote Chess at the highest levels
hosting all levels of the US
championships and the American Cup as as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sinkfield cup
Ken cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also include over
2,000 chess lectures for anyone to enjoy
become a member and enjoy perks such as
free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit St Louis chess club.org
to claim your m membership
[Music]
today the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Louis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess has intrigued people around
the world for nearly 1,500 years stop by
and learn about the impact of Chess from
our three floors showcasing the art
culture and history of the game
landmarked by the world's largest chess
piece sitting outside our front door the
World Chess Hall of Fame has something
for everyone to enjoy including various
exhibitions monthly concerts and much
more whether you are a beginner or a
professional there is something for
everyone to learn here at the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy free admission
to our rotating exhibitions in our
Galleries and sign up for chess events
familyfriendly programming and art
classes and don't forget to stop by our
award-winning gift shop Q Boutique and
Shop a wide selection of Chess related
merchandise for more information on
current exhibits please please visit
worldes h.org
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
broadcast of these 2023 US championships
we have a very very special guest in
studio Dr Pella welcome aboard thank you
so much not at all and uh for Kate and I
this is a great honor you're the
president of St Louis University please
introduce yourself uh to our audience
yeah it's great to be here um Fred
pastello president of St Louis
University uh very proud of our
University and our chess team uh we have
one of our students on the chess team in
fact competing in the tournament here
absolutely well I mean uh andalia she
the first four games she had wins in a
couple and she let them slip away it's
really oh very very tough but the St
Louis University I was seeing in uh the
uh uh papers they give to me you're the
34th president of the St Louis
University you have a very big history
the St Louis University history here yes
thank you so um we've been here since
1818 we're the oldest university west of
the Mississippi River uh was St Louis
University High the longest continuing
organizations in St Louis and were
located in Midtown which is burgeoning
right now and very close to the uh
Central West End andou chess club and
the Hall of Fame andly we're very
pleased with that proximity and to be
supporters of it we love the Rex and
Genie sinkfield they've done so much for
this region so much for the Central West
End St Louis that club that Hall of Fame
and St Louis University so absolutely
I'm delighted to be here with you too
and love how you call the game well
thank you for that uh you of course
course you and your wife are hosting the
strategy across the board that's our big
fundraiser that happens each and every
year in December tell our audience about
that and how people can be involved in
the strategy across the board please so
uh on December 2nd the seventh annual
strategy across the board at the Chase
Park Plaza everybody knows and loves the
chase It's a Wonderful celebratory event
grows every year supports This
Magnificent cause to further chess
education and all the culture and arts
that are around it I don't know if
everyone realizes here in St Louis not
only is there the club and we push out
the education of Chess and people come
and play but it's really an artistic
venue a cultural venue with the concerts
and the things that are sponsored by the
uh Hall of Fame and uh the chess club it
is impressive and the transformation
that's taking place that's actually some
of it centered right on that club so uh
my spouse Francis and I are Delight Ed
to be a part of this we hope you'll be
able to join us December 2nd at the
Chase Park Plaza for the 7th annual Gala
and I know you both are uh musical
lovers you're you're the musical series
and there it's held at the World Chess
of Hall of Fame and at the St Louis
chess club we've got some
uh a rooll I want to say photographs of
uh the World Chess Hall of Fame as well
as the St Louis chess club sorry we
don't those Fred I I messed up it's the
slooh pictures because we talk about the
chess I know we are suppor I want to
show you where verian trains his team at
the slooh University where are we here
so uh this is the St Louis University
campus we are an international Jesuit
university we in addition to the
campuses here in St Louis we have a
campus uh in Madrid a full degree
graning campus and we're very proud of
our team which started in uh 2016 very
much supported by Rex and Genie
sinkfield and we're delighted uh to have
their support and to be affiliated with
the uh chess club here in St Louis and
thank you for showing those pictures of
our beautiful campus here midtown St
Louis so thank you very much and I'm
curious do you play yourself chess
because I know you're are a big
supporter of Chess of Chess Hall of Fame
uh what about you and the game I I play
occasionally and I play uh Mr sinkfield
occasionally and Mr sinkfield uh has one
more than have and delights uh in that I
think enjoys reminding it yeah I got
news for you you got a really good
trainer it's Lou his name is Grandmaster
aruan acopian take a couple of lessons
with him that is a wonderful idea that a
great next time you'll be ambushing Rex
with I would Delight in that yes it's
wonderful Fred thank you so much for
joining us thank you for having me it's
pleas it's been a pleasure and thank you
for supporting chess and having just
incredible team at absolutely I look
forward to watching more of the games
absolutely and indeed we do have games
uh as uh we go to our standings here in
round five Kate take it away yeah so
let's take a look at the women's section
we have two leaders who made a draw in
the previous round Karis and beim toir
janova with three points out of four and
then we have a four-way tie for the
third place arena Crush Anna zatonski
naszi pza and stf Abraham with two and a
half points out of four Arena and Anna
playing that is a huge match and tell us
about the standings for the open section
after four in the open section we have
one person who is the leader Fabiano
Carana with a very important win in the
previous round got into the first place
with three points out of four and then
there is a three-way tie Sam Shanklin
hanyan and abanu Mishra with two and a
half points out of four absolutely with
Wesley lenir Sam Sam Sam Sean and leavon
uh they're at 50% % and uh so many of
our 2800 group uh need to make some wins
Christian I tell you what's happening in
Wesley's game when take a look at what
happened while we were on a break while
you guys were doing that amazing
interview as well Wesley is winning
spoilers alert what has happened we were
saying I mean Abby is going to
have in this position he's going to be
enjoying the next few moves what he
played the move D5 prematurely and I
look this is what I think happened okay
he saw it takes D5 and he was like okay
I'm just simply going to take with the
bishop get my Bishop in Queen A5 next
I'm going to Checkmate you're losing a
piece after Knight to C6 uhoh perhaps
this is what he missed and now Rook
takes D5 comes on the board you cannot
take back because of Queen C7 it's not
such a difficult trick though at the
same time right and I'm pretty sure he
realized immediately has he that's why
you wanted the Queen A5 exactly get the
Queen off the dile no more Knight to C6
then you can play D5 whenever you want
right and open up the position like that
don't play the5 first and right now he's
in the tank he only has 30 minutes on by
the way Wesley is still at 1 hour and 30
minutes so he probably knew about this
trick as well was like okay if he goes
D5 I'm going to take on D5 I'm winning I
mean he has to recapture with the pawn
but that looks very ugly he did
recapture with the pawn the best move
was E5 yeah taking with uh the pawn the
problem is is that right now you're
giving me the very important crucial F5
Square so I can just simply also I have
ideas of playing H6 first and then with
the open E file this exchange hasn't uh
helped you at all as black it locked
your Bishop on B7 it opened another
Avenue for my attack via the E5 finally
I'm going exchange up I have an extra
Rook so I might as well uh use it right
right so I'm going to go Rook to E1 e
takes D5 was played we expect something
like this Rook E1 Bishop F6 and now you
even have ideas of G5 yeah if you take
on G5 unfortunately Bishop takes G5
comes Queen takes G5 Queen to E7 once
again we understand how bad that Bishop
is on B7 right now there's absolutely no
prospects for that Bishop anymore no
positive prospects so this is the
position out really well for for white
wait a minute Rook a H1 to E1 with or
without H6 G6 you're welcome I'm going
to weaken you a little Bishop Bishop H4
is that a nasty Tempo yes yes you can do
this but in fact once again we look at
the quality of the pieces if you do take
on E1 okay which I would assume you will
that was the idea Bishop H4 you have
huge problems with your King right now
the bishop C1 is in fact very good and
it's all about how bad the bishop on B7
is can you go Rook to e uh E1 E8 excuse
me no you cannot Queen back check that's
a nice little move right here you cannot
take on E1 because um that's not a check
and you get checkmated yourself on d8
obviously you cannot take the queen and
once again it's all tied to the weakness
of the bishop on B7 that you just
created with this move D5 D5 huge
blunder Wesley so winning in the
position winning on time as well because
he has an extra hour Wesley is enjoying
himself and maybe he will get that
elusive first victory at the US CH
Championship guess what there's another
2800 who's doing quite well that is Fabi
Fabiano right now has a winning position
as well with the black pieces at move 10
are you kidding me this is an absolute
Masterpiece from a theoretical
perspective the way he chose uh this
line with Knight wage five
offbeat line and the position that he
got this is what he did Andrew Tang
after a very long think Bishop to E2
Knight to G7 and E4 the problem is
you're just simply not ready for this
I'm going to go Queen to B6 what are you
attacking B2 attacking D4 that's right
so you probably have to take right try
then I can just even continue with
Knight F5 oh my that's another way to
hit your pieces in the position at some
point I'm going to recapture and I have
the best pieces in the position first of
all why not no no I hate this I ha let's
take on B2 as well Bishop to B4 is
coming also this is h no no no I hate
this for for white so if he sees Queen
to B6 which is a very
natural I think one line we can look at
is in If instead of Queen B6 black
captures on e4 because that is something
that maybe Andrew would really like
Knight takes back not so much even this
is not that good because of Knight to F5
again this complex of pawns are very
well protected right now G6 F6 so so
what's the idea of E4 if everything is
bad thank you good question good
question my guess is that he wants to
take on E5 right now the problem is that
okay I'm not going to take with the
Knight because Queen takes d8 followed
by takes F6 finally you're winning right
I cannot take with uh the pawn either
because my queen is uh not protected but
I can go Queen B6 it's all about this
move Queen to B6 and this is again a
very Ty move in this position because
once you get the bishop out to F4 early
on then I'm going to be able to create
some attack over at the B2 against the
B2 Pawn right so this is what he needs
to be looking for I'm sure he is right
now he's testing his it looks like
computer is starting to be happy but I
think the move sort of sort of yeah
maybe you can survive this but again
don't don't take on e4 it makes no take
e it makes a bad move just Queen B6
you're hitting B2 and D4 by the way
takes on D5 I'm not worried about his
black because of that move Knight F5 it
loses control of that square of the F5
Square by the way Queen takes D2 works
as well it's just not as precise because
of this move Knight to E4 you're still
having a very good position but at least
Knight E4 comes with Tempo on the pawn
on F6 right and the Knight on G7 is for
no reason to do that but Knight F5 is a
beautiful Tempo against the bishop
because the Knight on G7 wants to go to
that square obviously that's right no
Bishop to E2 I mean look if you look at
the last few moves after this move
Knight to H5 you kind of understand why
black is so much better in the position
Bishop to E5 Bishop to G3 Bishop to D3
Bishop to H4 Bishop to E2 how many
Bishop moves did white make in that 1
two three four five six in a row six
Bishop e E2 is set no no five five of
them Bishop E5 Bishop
and2 five moves in a row with a bishop
and by the way you actually haven't
improved your Bishop you went Bishop D3
Bishop E2 you want Bishop E5 Bishop G3
Bishop H4 that's going to get hit by my
knight on F5 it's not looking good even
if you look at the last few moves you
understand why the assessment is the one
that we're seeing right now on the
screen chess coaches have cherished
principles and they include don't move
the same piece twice in the opening Hall
in this move
don't move them five times uh wow okay
big big developments and especially for
our tournament leader Fabby who comes
into today's action with back-to-back
victories well uh
Trifecta coming up we we'll see as as we
go along I'm still kind of Reeling I
don't know about UK but sometimes the
engines really throw me off so in that
game of Wesley so Wesley's an exchange
up so he plays the move Rook a H1 to E1
the bishop attacks the rook and then
Christian s Christian pardon me says
take the Rook it's good I'm like what I
mean was that intuitively obvious for
you did you grasp it right away that The
Bishop's of opposite color I feel like
so favorable for white yeah the dark
Square seems really weak and the bishop
on B7 like so sad just no potential
there whatsoever but it's obvious when
he says it to you like okay look at your
dark squares look at that stupid Bishop
on B7 you're about to object and you go
I'm making a good point Bishop on B7 is
terrible so those Bishops of opposite
color positions really really good
winning in fact for Wesley in his game
with Mishra we're just going to go check
in on the game of Hans uh Neeman and
leavon for a moment because this game
has just been a very very hard game to
call Queen E2 and it gets even worse you
know H7 H5 when you see a move like H5
you understand that leavon is actually
thinking he has the better position
because you only attack from a position
of Advantage if you try to make an
attack when you don't have a position of
Advantage usually it's just going to
rebound and it's going to work against
you H7 H5 is a call it says this is
completely different level that we saw
in the first four games right very
patient even repeating very early on now
he's ready to attack well yeah and he's
done it H4 HG and look at him go F2
takes G3 okay so this is an indication
to me that says okay Hans is a little
bit worried that the H2 takes G3 that
the attack down the H file can be severe
so he recaptures he compromises a little
bit of structure on the other hand he
says please uh I want the dynamic
compensation of a of a potential attack
myself down the file if I can play G4
maybe on a good day uh Knight to D6 I
can turn things around uh Bishop takes
E4 Queen takes E4 Knight C6 we've caught
up with the players and it's just a very
difficult position to try to assess what
do the computer say uh Christian the
compu is saying and this is good news
for all the H Hans fans out there he
doesn't have a lot of friends he doesn't
have a lot of friends but he has a lot
of fans I can guarantee you that right
and he's doing really well in this
position in fact his border line winning
whoa if he plays this move
G4 right now you were mentioning you
guys understood uh the dynamic position
you have you have to go on the attack
okay Knight H4 let's go Knight H4 and
now I'm going to start uh looking at
your F7 Pawn so I'm going to take take
Rook to E3 again it's all about I have
the two Bishops I have this light Square
Bishop controlling all the light squares
around my king I'm going to be able to
defend against any sort of attack that
that black is going to throw in my
direction so I can even start with Rook
to F3 to First focus on the Square F7 do
you want to Castle I don't think you do
no I not not
sure I really wanted Rook H3 is coming
Rook F1 followed by Rook H3 you cannot
move the bishop because you get
checkmated this is not looking good no
this I really I come but I did want to
go like Queen D7 and I did want to kind
of Castle along okay so what if if I go
Rook F1 how do you defend that pawn I
know my if I go Rook f8 my Bishop is out
of play and if if I go Knight d8 the
problem is Rook f8 Queen H7 I have Queen
to H7 I also have ideas of Bishop to A3
at the right moment and pressuring your
C5 Pawn but Queen H7 is a big big I'm
messed up here no I I I don't like what
my pieces have done but again if you
continue that line Sorry G4 yes what you
said Knight H4 Bishop H4 Queen D7 Rook
d8 I'm not happy I'm not happy Knight to
d8 just I'm not happy can yeah you
shouldn't be you shouldn't be Rook to H3
D4 even K G5 is a big big threat right
now yeah my Bishop is you have to go G5
yourself and now I go
D4 I mean pair of Bishops safe King open
files I don't know what this Rook is
going back to well it's going to e three
or B3 I've completely messed this up so
G4 Knight H4 Rook takes H4
yeah you can do that but I'm not now
Queen to F4 how do you defend once again
if you have to play moves such as king
to D7 as best
moves no and Christian can I go to D4
instead of H4 with my
knight what Knight to D4 but then I take
and pawn
takes right but now your knight is come
not coming to D4 anymore um worse Rook
is coming to B1 and Rook that's right
Bishop to C1 Bishop C Rook B7 is it's
all queen7 and kind of attacking the E5
square and you cannot easily recapture
on D4 that pawn because I'll be happy to
trade that Bishop for the Knight and all
the dark squares there well let's have a
look Rook B1 Queen C7 we're going to
play Bishop C I can take so you have to
go Queen D7 no you've got Bishop C5 but
I have uh Rook takes B7 after Knight
takes D4 I think you're losing this
right takes Rook takes E7 as well wow
that's a strong counter punch yeah that
hurts no it's just you're not you're not
getting better in this position that's
by the way we're just being told that fa
that Fabiano has in fact found the right
move Queen to B6 yeah that is just
begging to be played because this this
is good for Fabiano um and he might be
extending his lead right if Hans doesn't
take down uh Leon I mean he has some
decent chances in this one I have to say
Leon is looking for a fight and he got
it G4 is on the board by the way wow but
maybe not the position he hoped for G4
and he's stretching all right yes we
need a sip of water to just cement the
F or of having a good position and here
we
go you called it there's a sip of water
yes you do cometry your whole life you
know the players you you know their
tails
uh you know one game I think we can take
a look at is Arena crash and Anna
zatonski we talked about them they're
both uh US Women's Champions they're
extremely strong Olympic players uh I
mean they're so long in the game of
chess but now look what is happening in
their game when we left it uh Anna who
had just essayed the tares defense had
one backer Pawn rookie won and Arena
went for E2 E3 so what arena is counting
on she has the two Bishops but in an
open position the loss of the pawn will
mean you know whoever has the better
development and in this case it's very
clear that Hest King uh is still un
castled and this is happening very fast
let's see what happens look at the time
difference so Anna has 23 minutes only
left so she spent over one hour for the
first 12 moves and that's another good
sign especially if you will if you know
that you will have to defend in this
position because you keep that extra
Pawn but your pieces are not develop at
all yeah no this I look I love grabbing
pawns but this is not one of those uh
positions I enjoy defending as black the
problem is I say if white goes castles
and Rook E1 I can almost resign it's
like like it's that bad I mean my
Queen's going to get uh picked upon so I
have to do something to try to mess up
what I see as a very harmonious uh
position for the white pieces so
something like check if you hit me with
Bishop D2 then I'm kind of happy because
this queen which was on B2 getting ready
to be hit by all kinds of Tempe is now
back here on E7 if I get you to re you
know Retreat then I've kind of messed
you up quickly Knight F6 exactly and
then I'm feeling much better but now the
question for me is if I play Knight D2
uh Knight F6 again uh these you know I I
love that line from uh grou and fine in
such
positions combinations are as natural as
a baby smile and when you're in position
when you're in a position where you're
better developed you get these
combinations you get these tactics moves
like Bishop C5 oops there goes your
queen right so these are the things that
Anna is looking at and
she's she's saying okay Anna you've got
yourself in a bit of a mess so what did
I go
Knight F6 Knight F6 castles right I
Castle as well I'm a little worried
about Bishop C5 but with good reason
it's still better without the queen on
V4 there true that okay so uh let's go
right should I just go Knight here and
just uh put immediate pressure on you uh
Bishop C5 is on my agenda right so I
will go something like Bishop G4 exactly
I want to defend VI H5 exactly Bishop to
G4 please note that once again you know
a desirable move like Knight E5 to
defend kind of just walks into a
terrible blow Bishop to G4 let's put
that one on the board as well and that
is a
Tempo where's your queen going F3 Rook
B1 you're going to go to E5 right that's
the thing I have a feeling if you
retreat with your queen or well actually
not Retreat go forward with your queen
to D6 I will retreat with my queen to E5
and offer a queen trade cuz if we qu
trade Queens I am a pawn up exactly and
that is why I do want to put as much
pressure on the F7 I'm very cognizant of
the fact I'm a PA down that I do want to
uh win your Pawn I trade of queens and
your your Rook would have to move and
that would expose the pawn on
F7 and why is this game of such crucial
importance well if you look at the
standings you see immediately both Arena
and Anna are on the outside yeah they
are tied for the third place uh together
with Nazi PID and TF abrahamian but if
one of them wins this game they can be
the leader going into round five exactly
again it's one of those games I see a
lot of compensation for arena uh but
Anna maybe with some very precise play
she's going to be fine wanted to go to
the game of uh Jennifer and Nasi just
for a moment because again you know
Nazis looking really really good uh and
uh coming into today's game uh what do
we have we have
a well a Catalan but what would we call
this line of the Catalan where this a
fianchetto on G G2 looking at the
position Jennifer has a huge space
Advantage almost like a four pawns
attack and a king's Indian defense and
she's readying the below F pardon me E4
5 Knight E4 on White's agenda um black
solid but I don't know like White's
position with this E5 uh kind of
breakthrough coming okay well let's try
it right I wondering if I have to play
immediately or if there is you know like
we saw darush like preparing always like
just waiting before playing that final
move exactly uh but okay let's go E5
right now right so E5 clearly uh in in
in a dream world somehow we get to Rook
H3 we' capture the rook and we'd plant a
knight on E5 and it's game over right so
we have to just ask the question you
know like if I close my eyes and play
Bishop back with the idea o excuse me
that somehow that didn't work the way I
wanted it to there you go uh Bishop C8
is there a knockout blow here though for
you Kate do you see
one it's not intuitively obvious to me
how to continue because Knight E4 isn't
Knight E4 Bishop F5 or Knight E4 takes
on E5 you still have to prove it right
right yeah I like Bishop C8 move that's
very strong one just to rear out the
bishop try to control those light
squares it it it's one of those position
that looks good but how big the
advantage is it's unclear Christians
what Christian what I got to stop myself
I know Larry Christenson so well that
you know when I go Chris I can't stop it
Christian what caught you ey well uh
speaking of important games for the
players these two players beim to janova
and Karis are coming as the leaders
going into the fifth round and take a
look at what's happening in their
respective games because they have great
positions spoilers alert once again
Bishop to D7 and we're discussing this
position we were saying that white has
to deal with this Knight on C5 this is
the key piece in Black's position
because not only that it controls the
queen side but it also helps with the
expansion via A4 and TV unfortunately
did not understand that her first step
was the correct one Knight to F2 but
then she had to follow it up with Knight
to D3 she hurried look for a good reason
it looks very nice to start with G4 go
for the attack try to open up the
position and get to your opponent's king
but unfortunately you're not in time
take take
A4 discussing we were discussing this
idea as well Bishop to G5 another step
in the wrong direction against she um
feels almost obsessive about this idea
of opening up the king side and
unfortunately you're taking too many
resources from the other side of the
board and from your own defense while
also not finishing up your development
with castle and King to B1 so Queen to
A5 immediately taking advantage of that
getting off the pin as well and Queen to
D2 was played this is not good not good
for tff because if black Kissa goes for
B5 goes for the attack and sacrifices a
pawn which he has to do Bishop takes F6
take on F6 and take on H5 sure I'm not
going to take back on H5 I don't want to
get checkmated after to H6 Rook to G1 I
understand that it's very easy to
understand that but after Bishop takes
H5 take on H5 What if I just simply go
King to G7 or continue my attack with B4
right B4 you're not going to take on G6
you have to drop back and then King to
G7 I'm saying okay where's your king
going how do you include this Rook into
the attack because I know maybe I'm even
going to start attacking you on the king
side you opened it up maybe you opened
it up for me maybe I'm going to go Rook
to h8 and then you're going to have some
problems with the pawn on H4 in the
absence of of the dark Square Bishop
that you just exchanged for my knight on
F6 so a lot of things a lot of
interchangeable um factors in the
position but she decided to go for Rook
fc8 sacrificing the pawn sure because
once again after take take G takes I'm
not going to take on H5 and I sort of
like it but I do feel like B5 B4 was
just a much more aggressive approach
because you can go Rook fc8 at any point
in the game you have to get uh quickly
on the attack on the queen side with B5
B4 still very good for Carissa you're
only getting a pawn and after that your
attack is more or less over so I'm
looking at the position I'm gauging the
level of experience that these players
have in the Kings Indian as well tev
Close To None Karissa has been playing
kings Indian her whole life she knows
how to attack I'm not sure TV knows how
to defend and Counterattack on the king
side and she's showing that lack of
experience
therefore I think caresa has a great
chance to potentially uh maybe get the
sole lead in this one but definitely an
important Victory if she manages to
successfully fulfill her attack one
thing what I like about the move for
Rook fc8 is that you really want to kind
of weaken the Knight on C3 after playing
A3 right that's a different plan than
playing B5 B4 but it's also a very
direct one Yes yes again look I'm
looking at the position I don't even
know if TV will take on F6 because sure
you do take a pawn but you also
understand that you no longer have for
the remainder of the game your dark
Square bishop and you're going to lack
uh that control over dark squares quite
severely you know that so I'm not sure
she's going to take on F6 but due to her
last moves I mean what's her alternative
she doesn't well I mean she's yeah
exactly the the horse she's riding yeah
is Bishop is G2 G4 G4 takes H5 and to
make that move G4 takes H5 count you got
to include Bishop F6 and you just play
Bishop G5 so exactly so you you've been
riding this the this Pony it's time to
go Bishop F6 and as you
know see where the chips fall but I like
what you were saying uh Kate with the r
with Carissa's move Rook C8 that
undermining move A4 A3 is quite annoying
because the Knight on C3 is a big white
I how am I going to be dealing with that
it's it's a really uh difficult
challenge in front of me and if you go
A3 yourself then I go B5 B4 and
completely blast open the Queens side
right uh this feels like uh Blitz Games
I had a lot of training games with h
Grandmaster John fedowitz he loved
playing the Kings Indian I like playing
the arach we got such systems uh such
games as this one going on if you don't
mind uh go ahead and play that boo of
Bishop F6 again just for a moment Bishop
F6 hg5 five because I think this is what
we're about to see and if you would be
so kind as to continue the line G takes
and just to let you know why why I'm
playing this move King to G7 you do have
some sort of a threat to take and then
que to H right I don't want to see that
Queen landing on H6 attacking my Pawn on
G6 so I want to stop and I just wanted
to ask after H5 takes G6 you're going to
take uh G I'm going to play H5 and now I
go look h m uhhuh and okay if you go H6
I hype yes no no no finally we close
things up I'm not going to what we
wanted right right you went Rook C8 and
then you went Rook h8 that's why Rook
fc8 was not the best that's why B5 was
much better okay but I'm not going to
play H6 because I agree with you your
king hides here I'll Castle I'll go
alongside and I'm hoping probably have
to yes yeah I'm hoping to use the move
Rook
G1 uh okay be very care King B1 King to
B1 has to be played okay I'll take oh
sorry I thought you were going to take
on B2 and then I was going to go Rook G1
and if you don't Checkmate me then maybe
I do do you Checkmate Me Maybe I do not
sure okay so I have this you give me a
check and I run that's it maybe I don't
yeah you don't have that Knight to F5
check or that is you don't have enough
resources this is a huge game for the
sanding guys well exactly you know
looking at the standings why criticism
first uh tatv not that far behind as
that time for third place still very
close to be going for the lead in the
tournament trying exactly tat could Leap
Frog her with the victory with the white
pieces today but it's a double-edged
sword I also wanted to uh bring up well
Alice Lee she comes into this
competition as a tournament favorite uh
when we left it and she's not uh doing
very well in fact she was very very
lucky yeah well day before yeah in
previous round yeah not to lose uh um
against Talia we had King on D5 in the
middle of the game Queens on the board
wow you know somewhere in the rules of
Chess it's like unfair that that
position wasn't winning for Talia takes
on E6 uh okay Knight to B5 and this was
actually a crucial moment uh I don't
know when atusa went into this line
whether her intention was to play night
E8 or not or whether she was looking
more at ideas uh you know focused ideas
of night takes let me just put a moves
on the board whether she was thinking
okay can I use my you know pass Pawn
sacrifice an exchange right because when
she played the move Knight B8 I really
didn't like that Knight E8 pardon really
didn't like the move and I thought okay
Bishop C4 Alice is beginning to take
over she won a pawn and we're yeah I
think we are now caught up with the
players Alice has won a PA but more than
that that majority on the king side
she's looking at F4 and E5 locking down
this bishop so unless atoui get
something very very quickly um Alice is
looking good here yeah I was thinking
about maybe pushing D3
three3 yeah to try to exchange these
pawns but okay we take I thought he
would play B3 but okay if we trade yeah
I was just I was simple I'm a simple guy
I was going to put the Knight on D6 but
if we trade too many pawns tell me how
How does it go I'm hitting the bishop
yes so let's go Bishop to uh D4 okay and
in we go and let's go King
G7 okay
fair and uh well you know me okay don't
ask me twice I'm a pawn grubber all
right Rook f8 Rook f8 okay uh pong
grubber I I've done good you take
everything I don't have Knight E6 here
yes yes uh by the way what's the clock
times because I think Alice is actually
doing good Alice is twice as much time
so Alice is 1 hour 59 minutes against at
33 minutes 59 minutes not 1 hour
almost like wow he has been playing
faster
than with each move uh but that extra
Pawn too uh accounts for something so
Alice looking at a opportunity try to
get back into the game sorry we didn't
see beam's game for some uh time and we
had a SL president here so we can take
look at the SL student how is she doing
Fred is like hey wait a minute guys you
know like how how how are we doing okay
very different approach uh for tella I
don't like what she did B3 is fine right
up to this moment this is fine I'm more
of the Knight
D7 A6 Knight E5 persuasion I don't like
this the two Bishop very surprising
because white usually wants to get rid
of the light Square Bishop the light
Square Bishop is kind of locked there if
we take a look it doesn't really have
future what to do next exactly the we
would much rather get the dark Square
Bishop so that's why we are transferring
the Knight maybe to C5 or E5 exactly and
uh for me uh this trade that tal has
initiated with the move Knight G4 is
actually uh not that great she we we're
up to date with the players here
actually we're still we're still
catching up I apologize and it's one of
those okay I've got a little bit of
space I've got a little bit of a bind
it's very very hard for black to get in
the move B5 I've got that square covered
but always actually can I capture it now
how how tell me I mean can I play it now
b55 I take takes Rook Knight
takes I have one two three four
Defenders you have one right okay
attackers uh no I mean and it's it's one
of those uh imbalances of a bishop
versus a knight but in this particular
case uh I just find that that white is
more flexible white is the one and on a
good day I get to play Knight D5 takes
and there's a backward Pawn so it feels
to me like beum is enjoying matters and
I know in their head tohe head it's even
it's like one win a piece and just one
draw they they match up very well
together sorry you were about to tell me
yeah if black cannot play B5 it's a very
difficult uh it's difficult situation to
find what else to play here because why
is very easy to double Rooks on eile
right Rook E3 and prepare that Knight D5
move Rook E1 and as you just said
prepare the Knight D5 move and that's
what it's all about what's caught your
eye um Chris well Wesley Wesley just
massively blundered what and then Mishra
did not spot it what take a look at this
we left it off here we said H6 followed
by Rook to E1 that was giving white a
decisive Advantage Wesley the first time
he's actually thinking in this game for
20 minutes in fact he plays the move
King to A2 Bishop takes A3 right away
why not was possible because of this not
Queen to A5 Queen to E7 and perhaps this
is something that Wesley was looking at
but Rook to E8 I'm going to control the
E7 Square first and you cannot get the
defense of the bishop Queen to f to
Queen anywhere I will go Queen to A5 you
don't have an option to protect that
Bishop PA a three and in fact you're
losing because you get checkmated you
have to sacrifice the queen but I mean
this is a dream compared to what we had
a couple of rounds a couple of moves AG
go right Queen to C8 Queen to d8 as well
Misha will be happy as he would be
elated to get out of elated of course he
played Bishop D6 okay but now this is
too slow once again I can get back to my
usual business maybe Rook to E1 maybe H6
as well maybe I can even take away this
queen A5 all together and the sacrifice
related to the pin on the a file with a
move Knight to B3 that's an option also
by the way I would be terrified of
having to face Queen A5 Queen A5 hits C3
hits A3 Bishop takes A3 so the move
Knight B3 natural right yeah well
natural but okay it does lose a lose a
Tempo
um I'm just very big sequence though
very big sequence that because King A2
didn't stop Bishop takes A3 right he
should have seen this bishop takes A3 he
probably just simply didn't expect
Wesley so to blunder like this in one
move he just believed um Wesley for his
word and by the way did Andrew make a
move after Queen to B6 he spent a lot of
time by the way he spent 25 minutes
another 25 minutes on D on it Tak D5 and
right now his facing the music because
after he takes D5 he has 15 minutes for
29 moves to go oh my a badano has more
than an hour with this position which is
losing by the way right Knight to
F5 finds it I mean this is so bad from
an objective point of view but also from
a practical perspective this is such a
difficult position to play with the
white pieces yeah and I don't see any
reasons why Fabby would not play the
move Knight F5 because the Knight on G7
literally is predestined for that square
knight uh just kill me uh after the move
Knight F3 I assume you want to take on
B2 Knight F3 yes yes I would take on B2
and you know like I Clos my eyes I go
Knight E4 Knight E4 I take this bishop
first so that you don't have any more
takes F6 a check IDE as Knight and then
you take on D I'll give you a check you
have to drop to F1 and then I just
simply take on D5 I have two Bishops
this horrendous material down I have an
extra Pawn right and you have your king
is on
F1 I'm castling next if I really want to
I mean this is a dream position this is
over right but what have the Romans ever
done for
us this is terrible this is awesome yeah
awesome for black yeah no uh Andrew is
not having the time of his life no right
now no that looks like and in a dozen
moves it all it's all gone wrong oh yeah
this is movie 11 and he's already lost
with white this is not not not a good
wow uh want to just turn our attention
uh to the game of lanir Dominguez um Sam
Shanklin because again our tournament
standings dictate that this is a big big
game uh between Olympic Rivals we're
caught up with the players takes on it4
Queen G2 okay give me one G7 absolutely
well Sam said I can cover up I Bishop f8
protects G7 what are you going to do the
pawn on e4 is hanging the bishop on C4
is hanging what are you GNA do Bishop to
G5 you know I was even thinking instead
of Bishop G5 may be something like
Knight
C5 wow doesn't that look nice like I
want to I want that exchange you my KN I
take yours well then you then you're
you're thrilled right The Rook maybe
well here you're kind of thrilled
because you you youve got that KN what
you want to
include uh Rook takes d8 Check Yes Rook
take just exchange just so you don't
capture that Rook a fair okay Rook takes
d8 Rook takes d8 and now I capture that
Knight no this I think you're lording
over the position you've got the two
Bishops everything you want Knight C5 uh
pardon me Bishop G5 was played in the
game Knight C5 5 looks like a fine Tempo
H Kate what did you have in mind just
after Queen C6 though so I'm kind of
Defending x-ray but I'm really looking
at your pieces too but now do I have
that Bishop H6 Bishop H6 pause okay
um I'm just seeing this position for the
first time and although I don't like
seizing the defensive you you kind of
put your pieces in a little Jeopardy
here Knight E8 just
protecting
um well my idea is if I can go let's
just please Knight E6 yes you capture
which probably you don't have to but
let's say you capture on E6 or C yes
I'll do it I capture with my Bishop
that's a check I move the King and I
have
F6 kind of really I I want to put so
much pressure on that G7 Pawn you study
the games of Michael Tall or something
you're taking me into a forest where
only one of us uh can get out of uh here
okay F6 well I learned from left poly
GFI a long long time ago uh Grandmaster
preparation an absolutely amazing book
transformed me uh Rook A7 what do you
think is it I mean how many times are
you attacking G7 how many times am I
defending right yeah four times for me
and four times for you yes and I don't
another how else are you you threw
everything but the kitchen sink at me
here uh there with all of those
attacking mov I don't think this Knight
C5 works but sometimes you do want to
calculate these kind of creating ways of
bringing those pieces because the Knight
on B3 or actually A4 here it's not doing
much but if you can get it to E6 or
somewhere closer um yeah yeah you go for
it Bishop to G5 Knight takes C4 Bishop
takes f8 G takes pardon me uh takes
takes on G6 and we've got a monstrously
complicated position your knee-jerk uh
thought you like white you like black I
like white you like white I still think
I have some uh pressure on the G file
okay wow okay uh this one for me is
incredibly double-edged quick look at
Andrew Tang's clock here because um it's
going it's 15 minutes 15 minutes Fabby
just played the move Knight to F5 just
played it like 30 seconds go great move
best move in the position it's not even
about the clock right now I mean the
position is just I I don't want to say
hopeless but against a player like
Fabiano with such a sense for dynamic
play I don't see this one going well
going into Andrew's favor I don't say
it's hopeless either I just say that uh
it's overwhelming overwhelming yes yes
but not hopeless uh but the clock is
just another uh I'm not convinced if B
takes C6 B takes C6 help white in any
way shape or form because I do have the
B file open right now and I can go Rook
to B8 and reinforce my attack offensive
so not looking good not looking good at
all for Andrew but for Fabby dream come
true started with two draws but uh
back-to-back victories before the rest
day and now he's looking as we were
looking at him but you you killed me
with that Queen B to action uh Christian
and I suspect Fabby is looking at that
beef Pond very gleefully as we go on
break uh our social media director
Sabina Grand Sabina foer caught up with
uh Wesley so for an interview hope you
enjoy Wesley thank you so much for
joining me today I wanted to ask you can
you tell me a little bit about about
your chess upbringing oh yeah yeah for
sure so I was born in the
Philippines and I learned Chess at
around 6 or 7 years old my father taught
me and my sister the movs because he
just bought an extra board at the market
and uh you know it was my goal to beat
him and I might should do so and I
started playing my neighbors and in
chess Phil sorry in the Philippines
chess is a popular Pastime sport uh many
people know how to play uh not
professionally but uh I just truly enjoy
the game my favorite subject in school
was Matt and and the chess is my
favorite sport I started reading books
and I started joining weekend
tournaments and then I won the under 10
age group in the Philippines in 2003 and
started
representing uh my country International
in International competitions and my
rating went pretty quickly after that in
2004 I reached
2160 in 2005 2200 and 2006 I reached
almost 2500 so my progress has been
pretty pretty fast and then uh in 2012
when I was uh
17 I decided to accept a chess
scholarship here in St Louis
Missouri uh was number in the world and
I uh practice as a bonus I practiced the
university with a lot of different Grand
Masters uh from different countries and
that tremendously helped my uh and the
rest is history basically yeah for sure
and then I became professional 2014
thanks for the help of my family it's
fascinating to hear that you are
passionate about math and uh you started
learning chess at a young age in the
Philippines which you you know was tough
for you I think as a kid what influenced
which book would you say influenced you
the most yeah my favorite books growing
up was books by pandini by Bruce
pandolfini he's got a lot I think one my
very first book was straps and
saps and uh it was basically E4 E5 and
Tred to mate black and the other one is
M was it
like uh Bobby Fisher's most outrageous
chess
moves
and yeah I mean it's interesting growing
up in the Philippines because the
players there rely more on intuition
than than book I mean American Kids rely
on encyclopedic knowledge but the
Philippines is more
intuition and uh yeah I believe CH in
the Philippines was better 10 15 years
ago than what it is now they don't
really have any support for athlet it's
right now or for a long time so it was
good that I switched but also
interesting growing up there when you
were around 15 was that around the time
when you decided to become a
professional player I don't know when I
became a grandmas at 14 I thought I want
to try to reach
2600 and when I did so I wanted to reach
2700 although that took
forever uh it's it's hard to say it's
just when you're a kid you can be ultra
focused on one thing like Mishra for
example you're Ultra focus on getting a
goal
2600 and
and uh feels like there's nothing else
you want to do at the moment than
achieve your goal and then I I was I was
also homeschooled for two or three years
during high
school but I never really thought I
would become a CH professional until
maybe when I reach top 10 the world
world as many years later and you are
mentioning that in the Philippines you
feel that people are focusing a lot on
intuition while here more on openings um
how were you able to get interested in
um you know memorizing openings well I
had a friend who was providing me with
the latest books and databases and he
always told me you need to learn you
need to learn more openings because back
then my openings was very limited and he
said it's very hard to he kept saying
it's very hard to win you keep playing
the s c only with black and you need to
learn more openings you need to be able
to play everything and uh mean openings
is not everything but it's true that if
you only pay one line then it's going to
be very difficult to win especially in
this day and age what is your your way
of memorizing the openings do you spend
a lot of time on the computer do you
practice over the board as well yeah I
mean it's Chang change now because the
engines have become a lot stronger but
back then I was buying a lot of uh
physical opening books and reading them
from page from first page to the last
page or playing them with a board was
time consuming trying to memorize them
but they always said you should
understand the lines and not memorize it
so you know totally agree if you don't
understand it it's hard to to get to
memorize them yeah for sure but now it's
now chess has really changed a lot
stockfish has become a lot stronger and
also there's live Book Live databases
which weren't which didn't exist 15
years ago so I don't know how effective
opening books can be now like physical
opening books maybe they still are for
for starting players but I think for my
level I don't really read opening books
anymore and for a short period of time
you were a coach you were coaching the
US teams at one of the olympiads do you
see in the future becoming um a coach or
do you think you'll always continue your
career as a professional player yeah
it's interesting it's hard to predict
the future
but I mean been professional for a long
time we'll see how it goes I mean I need
to improve my results clearly but
they're two very different things and
yeah you know I don't want to be a good
player and a bad coach but
we'll see for the future we see where it
goes yeah yeah I mean I'm turning I'm
turning 30 in one week
so it's in interesting
there um we'll see how we'll see how it
goes there always times in your life for
the return a new chapter but uh but now
you have the US Championship to focus
about so let's focus on the chess I'm
very grateful to St Louis for hosting
tournaments like this thank you very
much wesy I wish you good luck and
looking forward to seeing you the thank
you yeah
[Music]
thanks yeah um it's amazing what the
club has done for chess in general
because I mean it's already been 15
years and they've done countless uh
national championships tournaments for
juniors helping around schools and
they've just grown the game so much
across the United States I think if I
look at my own career and I look at
American chest in general we're in a
much better place than we were 15 years
ago and so the contributions have been
immense and of course it's all thanks to
Dr juny singfield and Rex
singfield I would say that s CH Club is
like a rock in the ocean of Chess and we
know that it's it's there it is there it
will be there I think it send a hope
that the game of chess will always stay
float by the mere fact of its existence
I think it it it sends positive waves
across the
globe the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States we bring the educational benefits
of Chess to thousands of students across
the St Louis area we also promote Chess
at the highest levels hosting all levels
of the US championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit St lewiis chess club.org to
claim your membership
today the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Louis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess has intrigued people around
the world for nearly 1,500 years stop by
and learn about the impact of Chess from
our three floors showcasing the art
culture and history of the game the
World Chess Hall of Fame has something
for everyone to enjoy for more
information on current exhibits please
visit World Chess h.org
[Music]
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85,000 students in both in
school and after school programs we
created the select chess training
program and the junior select chess
training program in order to elevate the
skill level in students across the St
Louis area these students receive
professional training from grandm verua
niobian other programs include chess
cops a partnership with the St Louis
Police Department looking to improve
relationships between atrisk kids and
police officers in the St Louis area
with over 600 students playing chess
over the board since
2019 the St Louis chess club has also
created a chess merit badge for the
scouts BSA quickly becoming one of the
most popular badges with more than
250,000 Scouts earning the badge since
2011 students of chess can also pick up
a copy of read and write chess thanks to
Club co-founder Dr jeie Ken sinkfield
anyone can learn how to understand chess
notation in no time we view chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting St Louis chess club.org
[Music]
education hello everyone and welcome
back to our live coverage of round five
of the national championships we've been
treated to Fighting Chess in round five
is no difference we're going to pick up
the action in the middle of the game um
with beum uh one of our tournament code
leaders uh when we had left it we had
left it in this um I want to say
um moroy bind but it's really what I've
always called The Accelerated dragons
position and you know it's funny how my
approach to a particular position can be
completely different from somebody
else's and and their idea isn't bad
either uh in this position as white I
really expected beum as we were
discussing um Kate to play you know Rook
E3 and slowly slowly prep the move
Knight
D5 V's not one of those people who
likes IDE prepar no no no she's an
aggressive attacker look at this she's
on a rampage over here with the move F2
F4 her idea is very simple this bishop
on D5 pardon me this bishop on E6
defends the D5 Square I'm GNA kick that
Bishop away I'm G to play the move F4 F5
I'm G to play Knight to D5 and I am
going to destroy uh Black's position so
the move F4 F5 check King F1 F6 I like
this Pawn structure from Talia because
you know I'm kind of happy whenever
you're going to push for F5 as
because then my queen can get to that E5
Square be really nicely positioned in
the center um and I think that's
something that you want as black okay
can I put you to the test yes
F5 oh she played Rook E3 I have I I was
trying trying to channel my inner vum
there and is this going to go for it F5
I assumed you were going to move your
bishop or take my Pawn I was planning to
play Bishop F7 okay perfect and I wanted
to go Knight to D5 see I was always
about Knight to D5 and I want to
recapture with the E Pawn in case you
take right but now I can play B5 myself
Rook is hanging oops
I take first and then so then I take so
okay hold on hold on I got to warn you
I'm a pawn grubber yeah I'm GNA play B5
you are anyway right you got to play
King G you want to play B5 anyway if I
capture on
C4 what what what oh no I don't think so
because he takes on H7 and then after
the exchange of the Rooks on the B file
I have Rook B8 also I take and then Rook
B8 is coming ah you saw my dirty crafty
I mean I know very
well we' been doing this too often you
guys know you know tricks all to but
didn't do that she she prepped uh she
played the move Rook
E3 and I mean she's keeping an eye on
the b files she's holding this U Pawn in
you know this this break I want to say
uh I AG Rook makes perfect sense I feel
it's maybe for you a little bit slow but
on the other hand The Rook is getting
ready to the G
file ideas I don't know uh very flexible
defensive approach by tella I was all
about trying to play Knight to D5 a
different approach Al together by veum I
want to quickly check in on tatev and
Karissa because we know oh my goodness
wow she recaptured on H5 that's a
shocking decision okay so she took she
did that whole thing Bishop takes it
that operation we more or less expected
A3 Rook to B1 take on B2 Rook takes B2
and that is a move I really don't like
at all a G6 takes H5 opening it up now
fortunately Queen H6 is not winning on
the spot
right is it that Knight is hanging on C3
that's a check but it's only a check but
that's why she took on H5 right because
of Queen H6 because I have Bishop G4
like I will give that piece later Bishop
G4 is a blocking just to blow that file
okay so if I go like king
take or oh I see Bishop G7 first and
then anytime I play Rook G1 you have the
very crucial Bishop G4 okay that clears
some cobwebs thank you for that one so
takes takes so it means I have to play
some silly move trashy move because
Queen H6 I can't play but what about
Knight D1 Knight to D1 that Knight or
the other one I didn't no I thought R
the correct one Knight F2 no I like
your the correct one KN on F2 to D1 I
like The Rook from B2 maybe moving to
the king side potentially potentially
and that's when I put on my running
shoes that's that's what I didn't want
to see I thought the king would actually
be safe uh on sad for tatev that the
king is actually and I think that's why
she took on H5 right that's why
she first of all like Rook is no longer
on A1 and also that Knight on C3 is very
feeble right now I think this is a big
difference to the lines that we were
looking at previously right without
inclusion of A3 right so she played A3
she weakened The Outpost of the Knight
on C3 I find this very uh smartly done
actually by Karissa and right now take
on H5 and run the king over to the
center where due to lack of dark Square
Bishop for white you're not going to
have to worry about anything in the
position I think the king is going to be
perfectly safe on E7 so I really like
what C I did wow
um my my good goodness it it it
just it's one of those positions where
calculation decides everything I have
missed the whole defensive idea you know
with Rook G1 and you know here here's
one of those situations where you think
you're chasing your opponent uh but
really you're doing them the biggest
favor the king is actually safer on and
now I have music uh to face on the queen
side Queen takes C3 that was why you
light to start with the move Knight on
F2 to D1 defending the Knight on C3 so
readying the move Queen H but then I
didn't see a good followup Kate for I
agree with tatv that if she gets her
King to E7 centralizes it she's got this
Pawn structure surrounding her King the
two Bishops are doing good stuff did she
just play Queen
H6 oh no played Queen H6
so she went for the sacrifice I mean
look at the time by the way she
has thank you very much Jack I she
didn't even take a minute to think she
just captured that night immediately I
think that that that tatf has missed the
same thing that I missed I I freely
confess I missed the move Bishop G4 if
you don't see Bishop G4 you see Queen H6
and Rook G1 you think I just win maybe
she's thinking she's gonna capture that
Bishop with the Knight
what um let's say I move my king because
I'm not too sure what else but this was
your move that messed me up maybe okay
Rook G1 Bishop G4 I resign that's clear
right well let's make one few more moves
so please Rook Rook G1 I didn't see
another move after Bishop G4 what's my
next move my queen is hanging oh I
cannot capture the bishop with the
Knight because you do capture the the
que I guess you can go Queen G5 right
and after you grab another Rook that's
the problem yeah now I have to take on
G4 with the Knight I I just like the way
you said that you grab another Rook
Knight takes G4 I think T of a
realization is just kind of blossome
that her intended whatever it was that
she intended has a drawback um I can
just take on G4 and once again with my
running shoes well not much choice in
this case by the way uh uh this is over
guys no more checks after Queen takes C3
the position is completely busted for T
well for Carissa Yep this is like a
gift uh and again for those who joining
is just a little late first of all shame
on you but it looks like Karissa Yip has
just about to score another Victory and
catapult herself into clear first once
again Bishop
G7 why don't we take on H5 and just kind
of close our eyes is it the same thing
you're just going to move your king
queen take I think I'm going to take
your Rook first and then just move your
king I mean I can also give a check on
C1 if I want to yeah I thought I would I
would make some defensive move but in
fact I'm I'm busted it getting M it it's
it's hopeless Rook takes A2 hits my
Bishop on E2 so uh I think
we think uh T is just blundered and a
big blunder that I must say queen H6
looks
so seductive like that just it looks
like it was winning well to be honest
look you're in this position you're
facing the music on the Queen's side if
you don't play Queen H6 you know your
attack is over on the king side well it
wasn't that obvious I liked I like what
Kate was doing Knight F2 to D1 I mean
okay you go King f8 I I understand later
in life I might play F4 or Bishop B5 the
king is safe on the on on the king side
I agree and by the way on the center
we're seeing those last few moves that
we were discussing King to F1 Bishop to
G7 very well played very well calculated
by Karissa right now and perhaps this
was the move that she missed that have
missed but again to get back to my point
yes you first of all you don't have
again we get back to the experience
situation you don't have the experience
in these type of structures you haven't
seen this uh type of attacks
materialized right if you are Ted you've
been playing for your whole life then
you start seeing these ideas of Queen to
H6 otherwise it gets very uncomfortable
on the queen side also look at the clock
she's close to uh down to 10 minutes
with 20 moves to go t with 20 moves to
go that's a lot of moves to go right and
Karissa is piling on the pressure on the
clock as well she has 50 minutes
remaining 5 so she's been blitzing out
her moves she's showing confidently that
she knows exactly what she's doing yes
yes it's tough and then you see this
queen H6 you hope that you get some sort
of a Checkmate you play and that's why T
unfortunately right now will be
realizing that her attack is not going
anywhere and she will face the music uh
on the queen side also down a rook so
yeah this is over our current position
we're expecting Tod off to play uh Queen
takes G H5 or queen G5 and we were
looking at we were trying to make some
variations of this nature work but very
very unsuccessfully Rook takes A2 a
massive threat in the position for
Carissa and Carissa is looking very good
but yeah we have um maybe let's take a
look at Ina Crush against Anna zatonski
because here we have in attacking and
now if you look at uh the clock of Anna
she has only 17 minutes we left it in
these parts and I wasn't sure uh I'm not
a big fan of Anna's position Queen check
uh just to try to mess up the attacking
pieces Knight E7 Knight G5 we kind of
looked at this well actually I was
castling but Arena went very immediately
this is m one let me just remind people
that's the in in chess but also putting
pressure on F7 exactly I me is there
even a defense to this move uh I'm going
to play H6 I think I'm gonna play Oh
pardon me I I do have Bishop
F5 right but then I have Knight ex F7
okay fortunately that's not
Checkmate it's bad but it's not
Checkmate like okay I'll give you a
check just to ask you what oh then
you're going to go Bishop
d22 I apologize that is a silly but we
do have Bishop F5 on the board Anna
played Bishop F5 and I'm expecting
Knight takes F7 unless Bishop maybe I'm
missing something well I'm I'm just
saying like Okay you go Knight takes and
I go B5 an incredibly bad move what's
the worst thing you can do uh against
this you have a discovered check you
have a double check but do you have a a
knockout blow gate I don't see it that's
that's my
problem you're right I don't see it
either I mean I can play Bishop B3 yes
and but I'm just throwing out a rather
ridiculous move Bishop to B3 I
conversely you could play more forcing I
don't know if uh You've Won your Pawn
back you you still have the attack and
it's not actually very clear what Anna
should be doing herself right I mean um
Bishop C5 is on your agenda
rookie one uh I definitely like Arena's
position I just and lastly do I have to
take the pawn I guess I do Bishop G6
might be the you know if I Castle right
right then Bishop G6 and black has
defended and also then I can maybe move
forward with some B5 exactly exactly
exactly we'll keep an eye on this one
Christian uh over to you and what's
happening in the Hans Neiman
leavon good things for Hans are
happening good things for H very good
things for Hans I think we left it
somewhere around here after the move G4
Leon decided not to go to H4 which we
thought would be the main line but in
fact go to D4 okay makes some sense as
well Bishop was Kate's move actually yes
you have to take with the pawn otherwise
you're just uh simply going to be a pawn
down if you take with the Knight I can
always take back the B7 Pawn is going to
hang at the end you don't want to see
that you don't want to defend those type
of positions no C takes D4 Rook to B1 G5
G6 do not allow white to go G6 that's
going to weaken the light squares even
more so it makes a lot of sense that
black wants to stop things with G6 the
problem is Bishop to B4 Knight to H2 I
like this move not only that you're
hinting at the idea of Knight to G4
Knight to F6 you're also taking
advantage of the fact that this Knight
on C6 has a job right now to defend the
bishop on B4 you don't have enough time
to take on E5 take on E5 take take Rook
takes B before game over right oops
you're losing a piece next move I'm
going to go Knight to G4 or perhaps
after Castle because right now Knight to
G4 doesn't work Rook takes H4 and you no
longer have the idea of uh discovery
check with Knight to F6 but what you can
do is uh recalibrate your attack towards
the queen side I can go there as well
Rook to B3 very good move very precise
move by Hans in this position was played
Bishop to D2 and Rook F to B1 H I'm
looking at the position sorry but what
do you do next you give a go is massive
the best move according to the engine is
to give the piece with
B6 I mean this is this looks close to
over okay I understand you take on H4
but I go KN to F3 maybe a second maybe
you'll get on G5 as well but that's
about it okay take on G5 five first of
all I can go Rook to A3 and what do you
do on that side I don't know I'm not a
I'm not a this pce down guys it's a full
piece down okay a couple of uh pawns
right now but still I have great
coordination and let's not forget I can
also start looking at opening up the
position of your king with
C5 not looking good this looks close to
over from a practical perspective
objectively as well after the move King
to F1 and for hun huge huge a victory
today over leavon aronian leavon aronian
hello uh one of the pre- tournament
favorites would catapult him 2 and 1
half to three and A2 and only if hobby
wins which we think BBY is by the way
winning uh will uh prevent Hans from uh
having first place wow um I must say
that is a stunner uh to think that you
have to play B7 B6 because you well I
mean you've castled into a hornet's n
knight5 Rook takes takes B7 let advocate
for black I want to play Queen takes E5
okay okay Queen takes E5 probably going
to get checkm but how Rook takes B7 yes
okay you're threatening to take on check
right yes what do you do next 95 95 95
yes now is it a m you are getting M it
yes it is a mate oh very yeah very CL
only look Rook B yes oh you're going
Rook C5 check I was only looking at Rook
B8 checks if you go Knight D7 I just
simply take that's it no that's terrible
no I mean guys I think wow the position
is just terrible the attack speaks for
itself it's over it's over after King to
F1 which he probably will play because
who plays King to H1 down the H5 like
that no you're not going to do that
you're going to go King to F1 right and
again there's no defense against Rook
takes B7 you have to give up the piece
but I mean if you have to give up the
piece you accept the fact that you're
losing in a technical end game not
looking good for aronian and he must be
beating himself look he played you are
mentioning that the beginning E4 his
whole life he has been responding with
one E5 incredible one5 player right
right Marshall incredible knowledge in
the Marshall as well he wanted to win
this game he wanted to create imbalances
unfortunately right now that strategy is
coming back to bite him right um much
like yourself I uh was trying to
advocate for Leon's position it's
terrible leavon coming in happy birthday
he during the US championships he
celebrated his birthday he is his CV is
amazing I mean let's just start with the
fact that in a candidate's match he beat
leavon uh pardon me leavon defeated um
Magnus
Carlson one of magnus's earlier
candidates uh he lost the match he was a
number two rated play in the World by
far and he's coming into this
competition um wow just uh very
ambitiously and it has not been going
well four draws at at the start he took
it slowly at first and probably today he
was ready to fight but it's just not a
day it it certainly is not um another
game I wanted to see uh because that was
an incredible game when we left it it
was the Sam Shanklin versus the lineer
Dominguez game and sorry we just we left
it at these parts and I wanted to ask
you this question because laner did
capture The Rook so here you are Kate
you got the situation where this bishop
on F6 I mean look at that Bishop I mean
come on come on come on isn't that the
most magnificent Bishop you've ever seen
in your life it does dual purposes it
hits the Rook but it also hits the h8
square we all understand the pattern of
Queen and queen mates
um do you take the Rook how do you qu
you know your Bishop's great right but
how do you qualify that against an
exchange do you like uh I was thinking
that you were going to play a move like
Queen F2 for example
uh the idea is that you're in many ways
you're hitting this Square D4 you you're
getting out of the way so that you can
play moves like Queen F5 and Rook takes
G6 Rook G6 is on your agenda Queen H4 is
on your agenda it looks good in the game
lanir took the Rook you know I was
actually think that decision yeah
instead of taking and instead of Queen
F2 I thought about Rook D3 Rook to D3
there's another move where you start to
look uh over I mean I think you're
forced to play moves like Bishop G7 at
some point you've just got to get this
bishop is just too good right but then
when I trade the Bishops and go H4 I
have to face the music exactly you
didn't win the exchange which happened
in the game but you're playing the
position what you think is a nice
position for yourself uh in the game we
did see by laner captures takes takes
Queen G5 Rook e that's a strange move
Rook no I didn't The Rook is attacked
yeah but I thought he was going to go
Rook C Rook here the my my main line was
Rook to C8 Queen D5 and I was going to
give you a
check right drive you away you're going
to take take I had this really uh
elaborate sequence worked out where I
thought black was doing pretty okay
after Knight takes E4 and takes H2 you
know just everything gets cleansed you
know Rook D6 Rook A6 uh that did not
happen in fact Sam Shanklin played the
move after Queen
D no sorry I'm just I I I messed up I
I'm just going to refresh my board
apologies he played Rook E8 Queen D5
takes takes so lard is trying to trade
pieces quickly because he does have that
exchange uh advantage AG but look at
this my first impression is black is
actually doing pretty darn good that
night is kind of is really the board
almost for for for yeah almost off the
board uh for me it's terrible I'm I'm
seeing 93 I'm seeing Rook takes and by
way guys we have a
result to you Carissa win her game yes
wow
wow ouch yeah that one hurt for tatev
because the point is she came into
today's game she said I'm not going to
play my traditional E4 stuff I'm going
to play D4 I'm going to play against
your kings Indie and I prepare to line
and Karissa said look I have a lot of
experience in these lines and my king
isn't safety yours isn't I'll play in
the line you know if I'm playing white
with Karissa now I wouldn't
allow let's just go E4 let's go cilian
just get her off her game because she's
having a very good run with this opening
a lot of players felt the same way when
they were playing Bobby fiser I'm not
going to play a Kings Indian anymore
rookie two take us through this game uh
well first of all show us the finish uh
if you don't mind so I think we left it
actually at this point we were looking
at this idea Bishop G7 Bishop uh G4 and
just take the Rook on B2 Knight takes G4
H takes Rook takes Rook to C7 guess what
I have that Rook to defend as well H5
okay you're trying to get H6 and a
beautiful finish by Karissa very nice
move Knight to D3 you cannot touch that
Knight because you get checkm in one
move you're opening up the second Rank
and if you do go H6 the problem is I can
give you a check I can give you a check
like this as well follow it up with
Knight to F4 once again The Rook is
nicely protecting G7 you ran out of
pieces right you gave me all of your
pieces this bishop is definitely not
getting anywhere close to the attack you
have a pawn but my Rook is making this
construction absolutely Le on the king
side beautiful beautiful decisive game
by Carissa and right now she's in the
sole lead but what's happening with the
beging versus Talia Cervantes game in
this one objectively a decisive
Advantage for white after move KN to D5
will she find by the way Knight to D5
now that I look at the position makes a
lot of sense first of all you just came
from C7 right guess what I'm setting up
for when I'm putting my Rooks on the E
file the opening of the E file right so
Knight to D5 makes a lot of sense I have
to play Rook E8 you cannot take because
you're losing a pawn that's it you have
to go E5 you're allowing my Pawn to go
to E6 this is over can I go King f8 you
can go king f8 of course but
E5 she's setting up for this she's
setting up with her last few moves for
this opening of the center with E5 with
Knight D5 these are the options what if
I play B5 now o if you play F6 time
play6 I will probably take this one as
well I have a feeling I can do this all
right let's try it out B takes C4 and
queen to H3 some oh there's
no Queen to H3 and oops I'm trying to
get to H six I cannot get you know what
would have been funny is if our software
would have allowed allow Queen H3 that
would have been good I remember uh the
Yad yes with Fiddler
was actually possible in that situation
for no reason um very nice so Knight D5
let's get back to this B5 you're going
super aggressive E6 but the thing is I
can just simply go knight7 right capture
on C4 I'm trying to get some play on The
Queen
side and yeah Rook C7 you get something
but now actually this is my plan right
Queen to G3 first of all there's also
Queen takes D6 once you touch the pawn
on C four ah yeah this is not looking
good for Talia and once again 30 minutes
for beim still big advantage on the
clock 18 minutes for Talia for with only
15 moves to go but still a very
complicated position a lot of things to
uh be calculating right now and I have
to say t not t excuse me beim is in po
position to win this one and maybe catch
up with the current leader
kite with one result in the
in the women section yeah we haveing
Karis who won an important game and she
is the sole leader right now she can be
caught up uh by begim to here Genova but
she still needs to win her game Catch Me
If You Can I want to look at the game of
Nasi for just a moment if you told me at
the when you got the pairing sheet that
hey in round five Jennifer U is going to
play against Nasi I would say oh that's
a game that might be deciding first
place Jennifer uh who's having a very
very bad tournament needs to turn her
event around we got this crazy position
last move was E4 E5 it's clear what
Jennifer wants she wants to staish a
protected past p on E6 don't get a
chance to say that every day um on the
other hand certainly is okay can I throw
some spanner in the works here if I take
take and I do something crazy like an F4
so you allow my knight to go to E4 okay
right it's not like you know I feel
that's the end of the world it might be
but is it the end of the world like I'm
just just seeing what I can do to mess
things up I'm kind of hoping I don't
know if that's a right way of putting it
you know that I could do something
crazy I I'm fishing I'm fishing I feel
anytime I get oh I wanted to play Knight
D7 but you just capture that
okay right I mean yeah but you can prep
it with
E5 uh and Knight D7
uh visually it looks great for Jennifer
question is it by way she played G5
immediately immediately so she tries to
break in there we go she's she she's
trying to uh put up some uh resistances
here
G5 it's an honory move is it but wait a
minute hold whoa no that's a terrible
move wait a minute you're you're opening
up the G file but you're doing it for me
so my my trick is if you take with a
knight and if for example you don't want
to walk into Knight F3 right if you go
Queen
here right and that's a pin that's a
nasty pin so just a second if I go E6 I
me that just looks winning that looks
like a beautiful Pawn chain that is
really stopping the bishop C8 from
getting into the game and then I'm happy
that the king side is going to be open
as white precisely that's that was my
feeling as well is this over guys I mean
yes you cannot take with the pawn
because of Bishop H3 b h yeah and my
queen on C3 is playing an active role
that's game over yikes we think that
Na's G5 is badly timed I have an idea
please she want to maybe Knight takes F4
yes yes Rook G3 Queen H4 but I don't
have to go Rook G3 guys I can also just
simply go rook day4 and Bishop F3 that's
the caveman approach I'm still going R
G1 next you ah just to be much more
aggressive yeah not give you anything to
Hope in the position
yeah wow and our tournament leader uh
Carissa Yip in studio uh do the honor
Christian uh for our tournament leader
Karissa another Kings Indian another
Victory with the black pie is a very
important game because tatev was also in
great shape were you surprised when she
played D4 we know she's predominantly a
one E4
player yeah so I think she's only played
like D4 couple times in her life that's
right um so I was definitely surprised
when it was on the board I prepared
mostly for E4 and I had like this brief
leading thought I was like what if she
plays D4 cuz she knows that like you
know I'm always a Kings indan player and
then I was like nah she wouldn't do that
to
me
um but yeah I was surprised and then I
think I was also surprised by this
bishop E2 Bishop E3 line on the board
yep uh I know it's like one of the more
challenging tries but I think like
generally I score well against it um I
don't know if that's true in like my
online database so I was pretty happy
with this I know recently my most recent
game in this land was like KN C6 at the
US junior girls mhm um against soe tang
and then the line kind of goes like D5
Knight
E5 but I kind of wanted to maybe throw
off her track if she was only prepping
night C6 so we went into this uh into
like the usual E5 setup yep and and
H4 yes and I think I misplayed this here
because usually White's supposed to go
G4 first um but she plays like this
setup with Knight C5 Queen C2 and then
yeah I felt maybe H5 was just best and I
was definitely a bit nervous out here in
the open after like the opening because
they're always these ideas of like G4
Bishop G5 which ended up happening in
the game M and so I was just hoping that
um before she could kind of have time
for all of
that out on the queen side yeah and it
did it did and I do believe that at this
point instead of uh G4 which was a
mistake Knight to D3 was the better
alternative just to deal with the Knight
on C5 first I have to deal with the
Knight on C5 first and then I can start
thinking about my own attack on the king
side she did not do that there was a
clear difference in experience between
you and her in this type of positions
did you felt the same way during the
game as well did you feel like you're
seeing more you understand more patterns
in these structures in this
opening yeah definitely which was also
kind of part of why I wasn't really
worried about D4 um because I just felt
if she has less experience in the Kings
Indian then all I have to do is get her
sort of out of theory or out of like her
prep and I should just have a better
understanding of sort of how to play
this and I felt that she didn't really
see like this A4 Queen A5 idea um it
wasn't really something that she was
anticipating yeah so that was just like
one example of how that came to play and
you got to this point and she played
this move Queen to H6 you immediately
blissed out Queen takes C3 your reaction
to uh this queen to H6 and going all
in um I definitely spent a fair bit of
time I think on G takes H sh because
Queen H6 if it works for white I'm just
a dead lost but at that point she was
already a bit low on time I felt so like
my practical chances were good I think
also like I've sort of Consolidated on
the king side because it's really hard
for white to infiltrate with my dark
Square bishop and the queen side's super
weak for what so Queen H6 it kind of
felt was a bit of desperation and I was
pretty sure it wasn't going to work out
because after Rook G1 I have this big
Bishop G4 idea right MH yeah no Champion
the game very nicely uh calculated after
that you uh finished the job in style
with the last move Knight to D3
beautiful game Kissa now you're in the
sole lead at least until the game
between beim and Talia is finished how
are you feeling after round five how are
you feeling about your chances and your
shape as well in this
event um I feel I feel pretty good I
feel that I'm like really informed this
tournament and I'm playing good chess
and hopefully I can sort of keep that up
well congratulations uh keep it up and
we'll see you tomorrow Karissa indeed
our our congratulations uh as well as
well what can I say that was just a very
nice and smooth game I mean imagine
winning so many games with black pieces
I'm just wondering if she prefers now
playing with black or or white
I I think I think she does uh just
checking in on that game between uh beum
and Talia where beum if she were to win
with the white pieces would join Carissa
uh Megan again uh took a completely
different approach I was all about
putting the Knight on D5 and pressing
against the E7 Pawn uh bigam played E5
right away and maybe this gives Talia a
chance to try to keep the E file closed
with the move F5 if you do play E6 the
bishop could reroute itself quickly I'm
not going to say painlessly but uh if I
can get the Bishop T to uh C6 I might be
the one with a tickle what if I am very
fast with like Rook E5 here uh after
Bishop E6 uh Rook E5 okay so un I'm
going to close my eyes and just pretend
that you're not going to Checkmate me so
I'll bury my queen um on the queen side
and by the way we do have a asria I'm so
happy that she stopped this terrible run
very important draw for her absolutely
absolutely get back to the tournament
stop that bleeding right as uh she draws
with the black pieces uh but uh this
position Queen B3 I'm going to say that
for me um I see three result game I mean
yeah you might just kill me with Rook F5
but if you don't I do have Bishop C6 I
do have Rook I have my counter PL mhm
unless you want to play G4 do you know
G4 that's G4 runs to the bishop C6 move
check yeah right that that might just
actually be helpful so this looks very
ugly to be honest for black disos but I
understand it may be uh talia's best
chance to try for something exactly uh
quickly just checking in this is by far
the best position she's had in a long
while right yes this game Al together I
have to say but guys we need to go to
the Hans game because I'm not really
sure whether he made a move or not he's
still thinking after Bishop to E3 no no
no Hans after Bishop E3 check we thought
King F1 just comes naturally but he
hasn't made a move he's down to his last
12 minutes on the
clock yes he is yes he is he's
stuck he's been thinking for um close to
20 minutes you know this actually more
than 20 minutes that that this almost
like an absurd skit a humor skit where
you know you're you're you're listening
to the thoughts of Hans oh dear Bishop
E3 check I I'm busted if I go King H1
I'm walking on the H file King F1
there's some terrible result of Queen E5
then you're thinking about leavon in
Leon's mind what is this guy thinking
about King F1 I want to resign I want to
go home he's going to capture on B7 and
what's he thinking about why is
I truly have no idea well he's probably
thinking about the fact that King H1
actually also works it does and he's
trying to understand whether it's better
or not but King F1 just it's the most
practical decision in the position King
to H1 also works um and I guess we're
going into some sort of a similar
situation Queen takes but now I can take
on H4 right and if you don't Checkmate
Me Maybe I get to your knight first on H
maybe I have some IDE yeah yeah yeah
yeah the king is stuck right right on H1
no you're going to play King F1 come on
20 minutes ago you should have done it
Hans come on Bishop to E3 King to F1
we're at move 25 you still have some
questions to answer along the way in
that end game despite the fact that
you're a piece up they're still two
pawns for it right so you have to be
precise don't allow yourself to go down
to your last five minutes before you
play the move King F1 the because then
you're encouraging leavon who will play
the move B7 B6 who will give up the
bishop and play Rook takes H4 and then
try to you know Cheapo his chances uh
once again uh because Hans is taking so
much go take us down that line again B7
B6 by the way maybe we can do it on your
so that we continue seeing uh the
situation and this moment because so
we're expecting King F1 but maybe what
Hans is calculating is after King F1
black to play
F5 is that an option
F5 so I want you to capture with G pawn
and now Queen takes E5 and it's slightly
different compared to the lines we had
because maybe the file uh I see what
you're saying let's go let's go you can
take here but I'm taking here that's a m
and that actually it is it's just made
in one check Queen C7 and that's it yeah
Knight
F3 E5 still there's Bishop H3 uh mate ah
yikes made that way yeah yikes yikes
it's the ghosts that he's seeing right
now right this F5 ghosts things of that
nature right that don't actually exist
in reality
exactly I I wasn't really too sure Kate
but if I aasan the other way you do take
my night right your queen is very
dangerous and then yeah I'm going to
check my you now this is this is what
you saw just want to point out to every
every body that that was why we had to
take with the G pawn and not with the E
Pawn maybe it's ghosts like this down to
his last minutes is uh making
Hans stop for me it's very surprising
because in the game with Mishra remember
he said he saw the bishop E5 Bishop G3
move so quickly like the fraction of a
and that was a very difficult maneuver
right right right now it's just like
don't go with the queen under under Rook
I'm really trying to understand why what
he's missing maybe it's Rook
H5 I I'm I'm trying to follow you as
well you know this idea that we're going
to allow Rook takes
B7 no and that's it but I take I can't
even take the Rook with the queen right
or Bishop F3 I mean Bishop F3 is over
Bishop F3 no I'm I'm this cannot be I'm
looking for a Desperado actually is what
I'm looking for King F1 F5 I don't see
it GF and no Rook takes
H4 come on this can't be Queen takes E5
and Rook
h8 I'm puzzled no no I'm I'm truly
puzzled by this moment that's very slow
because I can even take the Knight on C6
and You' got to check on B8 in case you
have to bail out you could also throw in
a knight F3 before Rook B8 I agree uh
I'm just I'm playing with with the
pieces in my head but I'm not succeeding
in in finding anything this looks
terrible um let me just check in on the
west say so game for a moment uh before
we go there there's been some
developments in this game that we
actually haven't seen in a long long
time Ray Robson versus Jeffrey it all
started with the sacrifice after Rook to
E8 Rook takes F7 a very typical
sacrifice in this structures take a look
at this queen takes G6 Bishop to E6 a
big blunder oh no by Jeffrey King to D7
had to be played in the position but
it's not easy because after Rook F7 Rook
E7 Knight F5 you have to accept this
situation right now Bishop to C5 setting
up the pin que f8 and now King to E8 you
have to see everything from afar wow
this is not easy stuff right King to E8
allow Knight takes C7 and understand the
fact that you have enough counterplay
with the queen against the King on G1
perhaps a Perpetual yes wow it's I mean
look you see Knight C8 you see you're
getting checkm in one move you probably
stop at some point along the way right
so that's exactly what he did he played
the move Bishop to E6 but now after
Queen G7 Bishop to E5 this is the
position we see a repetition once but
now if he finds this move Bishop to C7
which makes a lot of s Queen C3 Queen C3
is a problem yes that's a Checkmate in a
couple of moves so for example if you go
Queen E7 check check you take or go to
A6 I go Queen to A5 and that's the
Checkmate in one move so if he finds
this bishop to F6 is the only way to get
out of it right out of Queen to C3 I
take Rook to
E7 and this is the key right
here Knight to E4 get lost that's I'm
sacrificing every single piece except
what I need to Checkmate you the queen
and the bishop on C7 Rook F5 check
Queen to C3 and this is the key right
now Queen to B3 King to C5 and I just
simply take your Rook also I follow it
up with Queen to A3 and take the other
Rook SK the rook and that's a win but
good luck finding this wow good luck
finding this at this point look Jeffrey
hasn't seen it at least not before he
played the move Bishop to E6 maybe he
saw it right now or at least maybe he's
calculating trying to figure things out
11 minutes for to make this a big
decision play the move Bishop to C7 he's
going for it he played it he found it oh
he found it because you see that you
would love to play the move Queen C3
check in this position the bishop on E5
is in the way you do spot
bishop7 cation right you're sacrificing
every single piece with with 11 minutes
on the clock Ray L he he he he Revels in
this chaos but uh we do have a special
guest a shria
who we've been wanting ishri as our
guest we haven't had a chance to
interview her because she started so
poorly Welcome to our show ashri a
difficult uh games difficult tournament
up to this point but you're finally on
the scoreboard uh your reaction to that
how did you adjust to these last few
difficult
days yeah I've had a rough start I don't
think I've started with four losses
before um but it happens and at least
the good thing out of those games was
that I was getting good positions out of
the openings and I was just misplaying
and choosing the wrong plans at the
critical moments so you know I'm just
put all that behind me and just taking
it a game by game so just focusing on
the games
ahead do you train with somebody for
this tournament did your coach tell you
any encouraging words uh after this
losses how did you readjust to uh this
new
reality mhm
I I've just been getting advice to like
just take it game by game just to like
forget everything that has happened so
far and just to think of it as like a
fourr round tournament um in this middle
part of the event but just really taking
a game by game just not thinking about
what has happened in the past um and
just looking forward to the future while
still a lot of games left ashita thank
you very much for uh joining us and
we'll see you in the next few rounds
absolutely thank you uh ashri because uh
that's the way you've got to do it it
just forget it it never happened uh next
game it's important to really like you
have a bad start you can acknowledge
that but then you know it's good to take
something out of that like she was
saying she had good positions she had
good openings so it wasn't like she did
everything wrong it just something was
missing so when you take like you know
game at a time you're like I can still
maybe I can still do it and now she got
it draw exactly uh I want to just jump
in uh to our defending Champion Jennifer
you
uh she's playing against uh Nasi our
commentator we saw this move by G5 and
it was just like ah terribly timed break
a G5
E6 and the whole point there is what
Nasi intended was to capture the pawn
and she's threatening mate and Christian
just pointed out well you could take
take Play Bishop H3 Rook G1 and whoops
thanks to the fact that your king can't
go into the corner it's just game over
so
unfortunately uh Nasi had to reset after
the move E6 she played H6 but it's all
uh play on one goal at this point as uh
got a pawn but also her pieces are just
it's not just the pawn it's the file
it's the bishop that is very strong with
the Queen Bishop G6 coming even right
and uh these pieces The Rook on E8 the
bishop on C8 passive uh a great line
from Roman gingi harvil uh White has uh
the attack and the
compensation up up material and uh on
the attack is Jennifer she looks like
she's in cruise control CHR and that's a
very important win for her right because
she did not start very well she's one
point out of four but now if she can win
again the former two times us wins
Champion I think that's a very good
boost of confidence well not only that
but she's a streaky player to begin with
if she does get on a a win streak she
can be very very dangerous for uh the
remaining competitors Christian uh
what's caught your eye well Wesley is
looking Prime to get his first victory
in the tournament look look where he got
on this side what's been happening on
this side not much right he's completely
safe this night had to with draw back to
D6 you haven't activated any of your
attackers as black and on the other side
I'm just killing you so this one is
looking good I can take on B7 and
refocus my attention on the pawn on D5
with the move Queen to F3 you have to go
Knight to E4 but after Bishop to B2
follow it up with Rook to D1 and at some
point something's going to give also
unfortunately you cannot go Rook to d8
to defend the pawn on D5 because the
queen takes E4 take and that's a
Checkmate so F6 this is the position
nothing is looking good for Mishra right
now I have to say this is Wesley's game
to Win It Fabiano doing quite well uh
after this transition into the end game
Bishop takes A2 Rook to C1 Bishop to a
H6 I have the pawn the extra pawn and
the compensation in the position C4
we're expecting long Castle Rook to d8
putting more pressure on the dile is an
option as well but with long Castle you
don't necessarily want to hide your king
uh but rather you want to go Rook to E8
and Central neiz your Rooks in the end
game put a lot of pressure on white
pieces this one is completely lost so
Fabiano is looking Prime to win as well
and Hans has played Hans in fact has
played the best moves in the position
take a look at this so he did go King to
F1 B6 immediately responded and we got
into this end game with the Rook to E1
Rook to h8 he's looking at some sort of
checks Rook H1 Rook G2 trying to get
something in the position unfortunately
after Rook takes E3 very nicely played
and we expect King to e to pick up the
pawn on E3 and to be honest I'm looking
at the position with the two minor
pieces with the two minor pieces they're
so dominant right and I'm thinking you
know what I I think leevon might resign
very soon actually
because I don't think he wants to uh
defend these type of positions D4 C5 is
coming C4 C5 maybe even like that to
sacrifice that that's an option as well
it's not looking good is it that easy to
win Christian so if I go I go Rook H3
okay C5 C5 very important move C5 okay
you want play C5 all right yeah that's
that's a that's a good way to do it and
then I drop down Rook to
B7 give a check B7 maybe I can I'm not
sure if I want let's not give anything
black any chances in the position no
let's play it a bit more safe why not
Bishop to E4 first she wants to go check
Capt G5 that's no problem at least
something
I first of all I have this idea of King
to F2 and that's going to block all of
your pieces Rook F5 no longer possible
Rook G4 that's fine but how do you
invade after that now I go
C5 now I go C5 I go Rook to C3 I pick
that up I go to the A7 Pawn via A5 what
are you doing okay Christian I will go
Rook H5 I want to run with my Pawn on G
right now no no before no Rook G4 Rook
G5 to H5 Rook H5 right right and then
she wants to go G5 G4 and that's the
whole I'm with you some future there
yeah see some future okay I see what if
I go
here okay let's go G5 G5 oo okay but
what do you do with that pawn on G4 you
you you get to G4 that's fine even to G3
Ah that's fine King G2 nothing to do
next once you go here I pick it up also
what's really annoying is when you look
at the move King H King F2 to G1 as well
that Bishop on e4 is really covering
your your your your entry yeah into the
position and maybe Knight C6 is setting
up some NES you know no it's looking
good uh we're at move 31 H down to his
last five minutes sure he got himself
down to his last few minutes but he's
given himself a a winning position and
the opportunity to take down leevon I
mean one of the favorites going into
this event this would be a huge victory
for uh Hans he hasn't won against a
2700 uh player Plus in a long long time
so this one is going to be a boost of
confidence one of the very solid players
right he doesn't lose very often Bishop
E4 on the board great move that's kind
of just cement cementy Type move tie
maybe he was just calculating this whole
uh line this whole end game from that
move King to F1 well if he was
calculating the exchange sacrifice on E3
really kudos to him by the way guys can
we please turn our attention to game
arena crush and Anna zatonski I wanted
to say I don't know there was BL or or a
sacrifice well no she when we left it we
just left it this part she did play the
move Bishop takes H7 castles so AR
she's not Material down she's got the
two Bishops and her pieces are just
primed to pounce moves like Bishop C5
Rook E1 on White's agenda black is
really uh struggling she her Advantage
became two Bishops versus two knights in
open position not good not good Queen
dropped back now I'm not saying that
Anna set herself up Knight Knight F5
yeah she she walked right into this but
I feel like it may be a sacrifice
because the knights on the king side can
do something otherwise what do you want
to do as black I mean the two Bishops
are just too strong Rook C7 coming Rook
C7 Bishop A7 Bishop C5 Bishop G5 again
Bishop G5 in almost every case but this
exchange sacrifice is not going to do is
is is not enough it it must be winning
on the spot I I mean H4 is hanging if
you want to play some G3 I have Knight
D4
fair but can I I mean there's something
about these Knights can I skew one of
them or not am I do I have Knight
G3 Knight G3 first of all that's
shocking that and oh you're not going to
take my knight on G3 I am going to take
but only after I've taken the Knight on
E5 as well so my next intention was to
to to take or play Rook to C7 uh but
okay let me start with uh Queen D4 in
that case Queen D that was a mouse slip
that was kind of you to put your queen
on pre
[Music]
Rook I guess you're going to find a
square maybe F4 okay fair by the way
after Queen F4 is Knight G3 I don't
know did I do good by encouraging your
queen to go to
F4 because I'm thinking if I get I don't
know the H4 PA the two knights there
Knight G4 exactly I'm looking at that
Checkmate on H2 exactly uh because
suddenly without a dark Square Bishop
your attack is I it it was funny because
when I played the move Rook C5 my
intention was of course that I was
winning material by the knights being uh
mispositioned maybe I just should just
okay it looks a little goofy but if I
attack the
Knight
let's go again Queen
D4 Queen D4 again yeah I'm
so that's a good pawn it it is defending
my king uh G3 if you go Knight takes G3
again my intention is to go Queen takes
E5 unless I'm blundering and if I go
Knight take H4 probably that's too
much Knight takes H4 I Knight F3 but I
think you can take it and escape the
king have some fun just take a look go
away I don't know you can take Queen no
Queen
F4
nice Queen comes in good point um well
the knights are there I miss playing it
for arena but the knights are and Knight
H4 Queen D4 Knight G3 ideas right it
starts to feel a little bit especially
in Bug House you'll be very careful with
uh give me a pawn and uh so on uh well
time trouble as usual isn't Anna zonk's
best friend she's left herself with five
minutes against Arena's 20 or 19 I think
it's time to move to the Jennifer just
to Jennifer you versus Nazi P because I
think we're going to catch a resignation
very soon it's that bad so let's try to
uh when we left it we just kind of left
it here we saw Bishop takes F5 actually
and
Bishop that Bishop on G6 is I think
it's I think it's simply time and the
bishop Bishop F7 check Rook H3 yeah and
last but not least Rook H3 might just
win the queen Hardy hand clasp in store
for this one yeah that uh the problem is
you're not even going to be just a piece
down I Bish C8 is completely dead as
well right but you're also getting
checkmated after Bishop F7 you try to
move away with the Knight I might not
even touch your Rook on E8 I love that
Bishop F7 check move by the way this
this is uh because again we've got this
queen and if we if you forced to move
the king then that whole Rook H3 SE I
think once Jennifer comes back from
wherever she is right now to the board
Nazi is probably going to resign
yeah Knight to G4 okay okay okay Knight
G4 what else to do Bishop F7 and we
think
Jennifer will win the game on the spot
with that move Bishop F7 the king moves
at least you threaten check maybe she'll
take your Rook on E8 oh she took the r
yeah that's a little surprising is very
much so but okay jennif has something in
mind because she can capture again and
then play E7 Queen G7 and there is a
Checkmate or maybe Queen F3 as well she
has played Queen F3 by the way yeah
that's a Checkmate actually also yeah
that's check mhm King G7 Queen F7 Queen
H7 that's actually a nice way to finish
things off
true just reminding everybody there are
no friends on the
board as Queen F3 check and uh
congratulations to our defending
champion that's her first win her first
win in five games and uh again she was
suffering uh two defeats as
well I I just want to check in on beam's
game because uh it looked to me like
beum was going to win uh a queen for a
rook and a minor piece and she has done
that uh last move was Queen H4 Rook d8
by tell you Queen
H4 and jump in on this one Kate your
thoughts I think it's very problematic
because now the pawn on E7 is hanging as
well you have only one move Rook E8
right to defend the pawn but it is uh a
very good Bishop your chances of
fortresses are pretty decent or don't
you feel that way why
not I mean it's true I don't have G4 or
anything that I would like to break in
on that King side right uh and by the
way I did play the move when Talia
played the move Rook d8 could she be
thinking go ahead and take my E7 Pawn
like go ahead take my E7 uh I believe
just to interrupt you sorry for that uh
Fabby has won his game if I'm not
mistaken our congratulations to Fabby as
he puts his signature on this event
winning three in a row yeah is is is Big
especially two of them came with the
black pieces that's huge yes
yes but uh again he started with two
draws against two of his Rivals laner
and uh leavon and then won three in a
row and uh we think arena is about to
win as well yes so let me just jump to
that oops there's a lot of games they
dropping fast one of them ah so I was
trying to take advantage of the two
knights the situation where the knights
on are on E5 and F5 if I was bringing my
Rook uh Reena spotted a much better
approach she just played the move Bishop
E6 and I think she's about to capture
this Knight and uh on a an exchange down
she knows it's terrible and she captured
with a pawn she did so that's even Pawn
structure kind of damaged ride as well
uh but it's just one of those things
where everything is just terrible the T
Adventures because they have a lot of
like forks and stuff the single night
there white is very safe exactly I agree
completely and Arena know pardon me Anna
knows that uh she's she's blown it once
again I want to go back to the B game
for just a moment because she did that
is strange H she so Talia in this moment
she knows well what can white do right
but but so she could have played Rook E8
herself and said okay go ahead do your
worst or whatever and you know I'm going
to play Rook takes C5 strangely enough
when she played Rook E8 I think her
intention was this what would have
happened okay so Queen takes E7 right
and if I check just wanted to see this
King
G1 okay excuse me King to G1 and I'll go
back so kind of do your worst you
probably
will and E7 right right and this Rook G2
checks is no you're just queening no
sorry it's all wrong she did play Rook
E8 in the game and we are up to date I
was trying to suggest that there were
possibilities of fortresses you were
saying I don't believe in fortresses uh
taking a page Wonder something like
Queen C4 can happen but actually beging
played Queen F2 defending the pawn not
allowing Rook D2 okay I
will like has a very simple plan right
now that you told me what I should be
playing I'm all for it Rook D2 is on my
agenda what's what you going to do about
that Rook D2 and then you know my bishop
and Rook will be coordinating so can I
go Rook E2 yes Rook E I will give up the
first rank because for you to double up
the Rooks there that's going to take
some time and I'm not 100% sure what
they would be doing in such a case
anyway um you know for me I'm really
afraid of the move Queen H4 which would
more or less force me on the defensive
so maybe I would just kind of play with
my Rooks again uh I like the queen what
can I say why not why wouldn't I like
the queen but I do I don't think it's
cut and dry I don't think you know you
can say that beam is going to be
claiming this game anytime soon play
Queen G3 here let's say I will force The
Rook to go
back do you you force The Rook to go
back back that's gosh darn it I want it
I keep doing I keep doing the same thing
I keep trying to play for for for for
mates and I'll bet you you mate me
first you know what I mean I'm queen of
s and queen of Faith yep got
me uh let's just refresh our standings
with the ladies because we do have some
results right Karissa have scored a very
important win to keep our leader ship of
the women's section she has four points
out of five really amazing performance
truly um and we have Jennifer who
scoring her first point uh of the
tournament and she has two points now
she's almost getting to that 50% soon
and Jennifer our defending Champion is
with us take it away Christian Jennifer
first of all congratulations your first
uh Victory as the defending champion and
it wasn't easy you've had a difficult
event up to this point some l es but
finally today you managed to break
through your reaction to
that um well I mean this was I'm
obviously really happy with the result
actually this isn't just like my first
win this tournament this is literally my
first win since like January cuz I've
only played a couple of games no I've
only played like one tournament and then
I played like two games in World Cup and
that so like it's been a while but um I
don't know I it always takes me a bit to
warm up in tournaments usually cuz like
if you look at my past us Champs results
from like before I won it was always
like this like I would get like one and
a half out of five and then like do fine
in the rest so um it feels good to kind
of get back in the get back with things
but and you're a player that relies very
heavily on confidence whenever you get
confident you're a very streaky player
and a very dangerous opponent uh how do
you feel about your confidence after
this important Victory the first one
since January as you
mentioned uh well if I I definitely feel
a lot better um it also like I was kind
of expecting something like this to
happen in the beginning just because um
it's been really tough with school and
all that to like kind of study chest so
I'm incredibly out of form like
incredibly incredibly out of form so I'm
honestly glad I just didn't lose all my
games because the way I was thinking I I
was just like missing everything but now
I'm feeling a lot better especially
after rest day somehow that's always a
fear whenever you play this closed
events you feel what if I score actually
all losses zero out of nine or zero out
of 11 but finally you got that important
Victory and it came after you started
your attack with this moment F4 very
aggressive take us through the remainder
of the
game uh well okay I honestly don't know
what the what was happening after Queen
H4 a little bit because it was pretty
complicated um I don't know if I should
have let this queen H4 but because my
Rooks got a little awkward having to
defend the F4 Pawn but the second after
like E5 I just have these E6 ideas which
I think is really nice but um I think
she missed this E6 move after G5 but
yeah here I I I felt before um before
all this happened just like after F4 I
was feeling pretty confident um just
because I felt like a nice position
where I could just kind of you know
extend and do whatever I want as long as
they don't like hang of Pawn or
something in Center absolutely guys any
questions because after that it was
smooth sa for her attack Kate yeah uh
Jennifer congratulations very nice game
and kind of straightforward attacking I
wanted to ask you about your game
against Talia Cervantes because that was
you were worse after the opening
probably close to losing but you managed
to like keep saving that position for
five six hours until you actually
accomplished to make a draw what was
your strategy in this game and in
general how do you kind of keep on
defending a bad
position well I honestly think think
that's just kind of me my entire career
if you look at most of my games I'm just
always losing sometimes out the opening
so if I don't want to lose every game
you just kind of kind of mess around um
create some chances so I mean I I just
if I have a bad position I'm not like
you know I'm just like let's make it a
little tricky for my opponent you know
it's not really something I like doing
but um I'm pretty used to this situation
yeah you made it more than little tricky
it was very difficult to to win for
Talia so congratulation on that game as
well
yeah your defense there was just
remarkable super human uh but good luck
Jennifer uh for your campaign uh
defending champion and uh take us to
that game of beum uh well before we go
to that one before we go back to that
one because that's going to last for a
while but Ray this is the position we
currently have in the Ray Robson game
after Rook to G8 Knight to E4 he spotted
it you cannot take because of Rook to F5
and then my queen finally gets back to
play that's a mate check you can hide
here but now without the Rook on E8 I
even have this idea check check and
beautiful mate on A5 this is the
position we have Knight to E4 King to B5
I'm following your king I really need to
get to that King by the way this is a
beautiful mate you're trying to escape
nope Knight to C5 the pawn the Knight
and the bishop are working in
collaboration just beautifully in this
instance A4 King to B4 you got the king
to the dark Square it's finally to get
my queen back via the dark squares with
this move Queen to
H4 I'm looking at the position I think
this is uh this might be over guys I
take the Knight I take the Knight if you
take the Knight I just simply take the
quick I have that I'm sorry I I was
defending you didn't know how many
problems black has in right I was trying
to save the king more than enough right
I mean this is more than enough this is
over and unfortunately a rook is not on
f8 to give me a Checkmate first on D1 um
overwhelming material advantage at this
point so I think the only way to
continue is to take on C7 the problem is
that after Queen to D2 check now I can
even go Knight to C3 Knight to C3 you
have to put the King on either B4 or A5
and that's going to mean that I'm going
to take on B5 Discovery in the worst
case if I don't find the Checkmate I
just pick up the queen And1 once again
this is decisive uh material advantage
following uh that will also be the mate
very by the way this is over Ray Robson
to win which he has done Arena Crush has
also won her game and let's just take a
look at the men's
standings uh to refresh our uh where we
stand because our next guest likes where
the men standing sorry here we go enjoy
seeing that um yeah so Fabiano Caron
with a very important win leading the
tournament with four uh points out of
six and we have Ray Robson who also won
his first game as Jennifer u in the
tournament um and he has two points and
our leader indeed is with us with four
out of five bana another Victory with
the black pieces after the one against
Jeffrey this is an important one coming
into this game uh a pack of hungry
wolves behind you only half a point how
important was for you to get this
Victory with the black
pieces yeah I thought this was a game
that I really should be fighting for the
win potentially uh I didn't want to go
crazy but I I thought uh especially if
Andrew plays this line then we're going
to get a big fight and he has shown the
intention to play this line and I had a
rare idea in the opening Knight
H5 uh deviating from his game against
Levon where which repeated with Bishop
G7 Knight B5 so this was a rare and
interesting idea rather risky of course
but also if white doesn't know what to
do it's it's very interesting and he he
clearly was caught off guard a bit he
didn't really react in the best way I
think Bishop D3 is a very dubious move
and then Bishop H4 is uh is a even more
dubious move yeah he was
shuffling these last few moves with his
Bishop he actually made five moves with
the bishop in a row and allowed it to
break in the center and get that Queen
to B6 a lot of tension in the position
how did you assess it after this move
Queen to
B6 I thought this was much better maybe
border line winning for black it is yes
I could also take on D4 and play Knight
E6 which is better for black like my
first intention was okay Knight D6 and
queen goes back and D4 and Knight goes
back and of course I'm much better but
then I saw Queen B6 is perhaps even more
devastating for him yeah and then I
think I didn't play well I mean okay
Knight F5 is definitely correct like for
for a few moves I probably played
correctly but then I think I lost some
of the advantage like maybe here
somewhere uh yeah maybe F5 yeah I spent
some time on it and um I thought that
like if I play F5 and then Rook B1 Queen
D4 I get a better version of the end
game but of course I should Chase his
King to to F1 my first intention and the
thing is after King F1 Queen D4 take
take I saw like Rook B1 and then Knight
F3 and I I didn't want to start wasting
time with my pieces Bishop B7 Knight F3
C5 but but of course it's very important
that he can't castle Yeah but I was a
little bit unsure if this was a better
version or what we had in the game and
finally I went for what we had in the
game I regretted it somewhat but it was
still overwhelmed at this
point I wasn't so sure like if he plays
uh Rook A1 instead of Rook
C1 uh also also after U Bishop B6 yeah
Rook A1 Bishop D5 Castle Bishop G7 C3 of
course I'm up a pawn it's much better
but the draw drawing margin in chess is
rather high and he can start to both
trade Bishops with Bishop F3 and also
play Rook A5 Rook A1 so I I felt like I
didn't um play this too ideally and then
he played Rook C1 and and I think after
that Bishop H6 is a very devastating
move yeah uh maybe among other moves but
I I didn't really
see um I thought okay instead of H4
probably King F1 is the most tenacious
uh on move what was it 25 I guess King
F1 but I thought Bishop D2 Knight D2
Knight C3 this is what convinced me to
play Bishop H6 when I when I played it
because okay my Bishop's trapped but
with this I save it and his King on F1
is of course also in big trouble
so yeah at this moment I was pretty
confident absolutely an important
victory for you Fabiano congratulations
definitely you're setting up um a good
trend for this tournament try to defend
the title we'll see you
tomorrow our congratulations as well
Fabby well we're getting a lot of
results this round five I mean that rest
day really charged the players as in the
open section two games two wins and in
the lady section too we've uh we've been
seeing from the four games three
victories and in the game of Arena just
at the very end I mean you got to go
down with a cheapo Anna had one last
gasp Checkmate on G2 she didn't want to
trade uh Queens okay are you gonna let
me play Queen takes G2 no okay we can
get call it the day as Arena
Crush wins a very important game of a
very key rival and I think begim right
now is winning her game also and it
wasn't easy all throughout it in fact
the whole assessment changed in the last
couple of moves after this move Rook to
C5 if she would have played uh Talia
that is Rook to D1 theine is saying that
I'm actually getting very close to
equality achieving equality after this
moves a G5 F4 I need to be able to cover
up up the entry of your queen and
unfortunately after for for tative after
Rook takes C5 Queen to B4 perhaps this
is what she missed you cannot move the
Rook you have to defend it with the
other Rook because you lose the pawn on
E7 the problem is that once you move the
Rook from the eighth rank you no longer
have Rook to E8 so now I can harass you
with the move Queen to H4 how do you
defend the pawn on uh E7 King f8 is met
by Queen takes H6 game over so you have
to go G5 right right but now I go to F7
you come in Via F7 that's it you cannot
defend against that I believe those
moves are not yet on the board but this
is over take a look at the woman
standing and if beIN wins her game she
will equalize the score of Karissa at
for and we do have Arena Crush in studio
uh to tell us about her game today
Welcome to our show arena take it away
Chris Christian Arena uh a great game
for for you uh this was not easy against
a player that you know oh so well one of
your Rivals for many many years take us
uh through today's
game yeah well um of course I was kind
of uh baffled by what was going on in
the opening um because she actually she
played the same line against me that she
played at the Karen's cup and I took on
C5 but that can't really have been a big
surprise to her because I did that uh
like less than a month ago against har
in the Tata steel rapid um and then but
but she seemed like kind of not so sure
about what to do so that that was the
surprising part she really spent a lot
of time um but really I hadn't done
anything surprising um so she took the
pawn on B2 of course it's risky I didn't
know exactly why it was um like bad I
mean I just know white has a lot of play
for this kind of Pawn and really the
very tough moment for me came like on
this move I spent like what like half an
hour over here um on Knight G5 right
because first of all I completely did
not accept Castle expect castles right
when I played Knight G5 I thought she'd
play Knight
E5 um at least that was the move that
worried me right and yeah and the thing
is that um like if I go Bishop B3 here
which was sort of my first instinct um I
had some issues with Bishop G4 right and
like rook d8 and because I'm not castled
uh Knight D3 is a problem so why did I
ultimately go for Knight G5 because I I
kind of figured out that on Knight E5 I
can just castle and I can afford to give
up my light squared bishop and this took
me a while to really come to because you
know giving up that Bishop is not an
easy decision so you really have to
evaluate this position with the Bishops
of opposite color and I thought on
castles there's Bishop C5 and then once
I kind of saw those ideas um I was
feeling pretty confident that I would
have um like what I wanted in this
position but this was like for sure you
know the most difficult moment of the
game for me because I thought if I
castled instead of Knight G5 and she
castles I mean I wasn't so sure you know
what was going on with my initiative
there yeah and it does seem like it
dissipates after uh this couple of
castles but Knight to G5 very forceful
very precise move I have to say and uh
after that where did you feel like
you're finally in full control of your
advantage because you did get the
advantage but it still wasn't that
easy oh yeah I mean when I got the two
Bishops against the two knights
obviously I thought I I was very happy
sort of in the beginning but then I
realized okay there's actually a lot of
work here I think the move H4 obviously
won me the game um it turned out to be a
lot trickier than I expected I mean the
whole point of H4 is actually to have
Bishop G5 ideas um but I guess I don't
know I guess she just I don't know
missed that or something because
otherwise like why would I weaken the
pawn that much why would I put it to H4
right right right but um you know yeah
so she kind of stepped right into the
whole point of age four and and then you
know once you win the exchange it's easy
but I mean other than that I mean it was
still it was still going to be a game
but it's certainly kind of like
unpleasant for black even before she she
blunders The
Exchange well Arena congratulations an
important victory for you uh very good
victory for you because there are two
ladies that are also scoring a lot of
points that is uh begim who still has to
win her game but it seems like she's
winning that one and Karissa take us
about these Dynamics right now in the
tournament with you three not
necessarily running away with the event
but definitely showing that you are the
top favorites to win
it yeah I mean I'm just kind of playing
my tournaments especially because I
cross path with Carissa in round one so
that like big matchup came so early and
then you know we're just playing our own
tournaments um you know I still have
beum left to play but there's still
there's just so many games still left
that you know I feel like yeah
everything is going fine absolutely guys
any questions for no just our
congratulations Arena as we're in the
this round after the rest day and the
players came with so much VI vim and
vigor we've seen a large number of
decisive games already and we're
thinking beum is about to accept a
resignation from Talia as well in order
to join Carissa she did play that move
Kate Queen H4 and what a nasty move that
is uh there is no way to defend the E7
Pawn you can't defend it with the King
it's pointed out by Christian the pawn
on H6 is hanging the all the Queen's got
to do is break into Black's Camp Queen
takes E7 you block the threat of Queen
E7 Queen uh posts up uh to quote Maurice
Ashley post up to H5 so you can go Queen
F7 that's all she wrote the queen just
breaks it breaks through uh the line of
defense and uh it's over you're getting
M it and so we do think that Bon's about
to join yeah black would love to have
the bishop on E8 when play G fire I just
not allowing the queen to get in but
that would make all the difference in
the world and then that would leave only
one remaining game and that's the game
of Alice uh lee Alice actually enjoying
uh this position very much she has an
extra Pawn but it's also like her Pawn
is super dangerous this Pawn this passer
on H5 this passer on the E Pawn versus
this lone passer which is actually
firmly blockaded so it just really feels
like Alice has a two- Pawn Advantage at
the moment with her A and E Pawn I
wouldn't be surprised in this ending if
Alice were to win it and fact I think
this is very uncomfortable for black to
defend because you have to keep
defending that pawn on C5 you have to be
worried about that a pawn Runner just St
forward yeah you put your Bishop on D4
you congratulate yourself your Bishop
looks really good until you say to
yourself okay how exactly does this rook
and this bishop stop that a pawn so uh
it might be a very bloody round in the
lady section with five of the six games
already three of the F three of the four
games finished uh decisively are we
going to see such
a Bloodshed in the open in the open as
well so right now we have three decisive
results take a look at this one
Dominguez versus
Shanklin Rook takes a look this is still
a three result game right because you do
take my Pawn on A5 you will take my Pawn
on B4 as well following it up but I do
have these two running down the board
right so F5 G4 look look look I mean
this is going to become some sort of a
race right and if you have to make moves
such as A4 uh that's not an easy move to
make no it's not not an easy position to
calculate anything can still happen in
this one no no seriously I want to
emphasize that I mean to our audience
you we can sit there and say we're in
studio we've got a three we've got an
engine2 but when you're sitting at the
board and you're white you've got three
connected Pawn you got three pass pawns
our opponent has two pass pawns uh
you're not
sure no no no you're not sure at all and
you're nervous uh in fact yes forget and
how important is this for the man's
standings because we know Sam is only
going into this round half a point
behind the leaders ler really needs a
victory as you mentioned at the
beginning of the show as well because is
only on 50% and Fabiano is running away
with it so he needs a victory in this
one Shanklin also if he wins stays close
to Fabiano important game
absolutely and uh we do have Ray Ray in
studio uh to explain to us his victory
today Christian Ray uh very uh difficult
tournament for you it didn't start off
well with that game against uh Sam you
were winning in that one unfortunately
you weren't able to convert but finally
you're breaking the ice this Rook takes
F7 tell us the story of that
move uh yeah I guess Rook F7 was the
plan when I went for F5 F5 was very
committal I think obviously I could have
played something like Rook A1 and I
thought I'm just better but F5 is super
direct so it could be very good or could
actually even like give away everything
I could be worse immediately probably it
was just a force draw but um yeah so
like F5 Rook E5 FG HG Bishop D4 and then
in this position he has like uh five or
six options so for example Rook E6 uh
was an option so that I don't have Rook
F7 ideas because now he guards G6 and
then I had been planning Knight
F5 uh after Rook
E6 and then the point is if he takes
take um he can even play Rook F6
immediately okay if I play Bishop F6 he
has Queen B6 but yeah have Queen H5 and
what's really yeah what's really funny
is Queen H5 I'm not actually threatening
the
bishop but he actually also can't move
so my threat is something like Rook F4
because his Rook is pinned to the mate
threat on h8 and he actually just can't
stop it he can include C5 Bishop E5 but
I don't think it changes anything and
this is a very funny um kind of trap but
yeah after uh Rook E6 Knight F5 there
was Bishop G5 um which wasn't clear so I
mean probably F5 wasn't the the best
objectively but it was just so tempting
so Rook E8 was another option and then
this Rook sacrifice seemed kind of
forced and it was hard for me to
evaluate from AAR excuse me sorry about
that um but I thought I should always
have at least a draw so it was still
kind of safe and here yeah I mean
there's King E6 or King E7 it's funny
like there there actually differences is
but he went King E7 which allowed Bishop
C5 and I took on G6 which could have
just transposed and I thought he had to
go King D7 and I couldn't find a I
couldn't find anything better than a
draw I was looking for some way to like
maybe pick up the bishop on H4 and just
have uh a strong position but I didn't
actually see a clear way so there were
like tons of checks so many different
options but um yeah I thought that was a
draw with Bishop E6 I had seen uh
basically everything that happened in
the game up to Knight E4 from afar um
and knight4 is obviously I don't know if
it's the only move but it's really
really nice yes um with the point that
if he takes I have Rook F5 check giving
up my Rook as well and then Bishop takes
F5 Queen C3 uh I'll give mate a few
moves yeah Queen E5 B3 and queen A5 mate
yeah very nice a lot of uh beautiful
geometry in uh this game Ray uh
congratulations an important vict
victory for you you how do you assess
your game so far sure the result hasn't
been the best but you did get some good
positions how do you assess how do you
feel about your chess so
far yeah I mean I wasn't I haven't been
playing very well but I did have some
good positions like you said I mean the
first game I was completely winning
against I mean completely is a little
bit of an overstatement in terms of
there wasn't like a direct win but just
the position was pretty overwhelming uh
against Avon and there was literally no
way I could lose that one and uh after I
made a mistake and he got back in the
game I ended up just like making a crazy
decision not to force a draw instead
playing a position where I can only be
worse so I somehow ended up losing that
one and uh yeah then I uh lost another
one uh so I don't know my play has been
I mean I lost him Misha he played a
great game I have to say I did have a
chance to get an advantage at one for
one move but it was extremely
complicated um so I don't know I'm
feeling a little bit better than the
first few days trying to play a a little
bit better as well um I probably could
have scored some more points with the
positions I had but just have to accept
uh what's happened still a lot of rounds
to go we'll let you go get ready for the
next one and we'll see you
tomorrow thanks uh thank you Ray indeed
uh nice Victory and the geometry the
attack
really played uh very well but Jeffrey
seeing Knight E4 and Rook F5 that is
impressive sacrificing everything uh
turning our attention to uh the game of
Hans I take no friends Neiman uh uh
versus leavon Ron and uh that was the
game where we really saw the two minor
pieces working super well against uh The
Rook uh the one thing that uh Leon has
going for him re what you wanted to do
too Rook takes G5 and get the G Pawn
going well Leon's doing the best he can
but he's facing a killer threat Knight
C6 check uh by white so leavon said well
I've done the best I could I've chased
the king as far away over to the queen
side away from the G Pawn as I could uh
sacrific The Exchange and now suddenly a
totally different set of problems is BU
white because the Knight C6 is no longer
the killer move the Rook on A6 is maybe
a little misplaced absolutely and you
start to feel a little nervous you start
to say to yourself who wait whoa whoa
time out just a second here who's taking
care of this peski this guy wants to run
up the board and uh Hans readjusts
himself to the change circumstances and
he made the move King uh D3 so he starts
to float with his King back over to the
I like that idea just to bring the king
closer to the pawn uh to have that King
stopping the pawn so the Knight and Rook
can still be active and you know try to
maybe go for for the black BS maybe F7
to Target exactly funnily enough I was
taking again uh whenever I look at the
games of leavon I don't know what the
heck is going on half the time uh I
thought the Rook is now kind of stuck
and misplaced I was thinking another
approach was to go Rook A3 and in case
of G3 not saying that you should play G
D3 but just in case this idea of you
know sneaking The Rook
behind uh the pawn would it's an ideal
The Rook on A6 is doing nothing uh Hans
took another approach as I said he he's
moving towards the pawn I assume his
idea is that he wants to just stay with
his King he's got Knight F3 and he's got
King F2 in his pocket uh to to deal with
the pawn and once again because we're
seeing so many results and decisive ones
let's take a look at these standings uh
Kate so we have Fabiano Carana winning a
very important game today and still
being the sole leader with four points
and then we have um who do we have tight
so Wesley so winning a game with three
points and he's second he's clear second
for the moment right because Sam
Shanklin and uh lanir are still in there
as well and we do have Sam savan with
two and a half points right coming up so
uh big results and over to the ladies
what's happening there with I believe
one game remaining right so oh no pardon
me because beum is still right beim is
still playing but we are assuming or
expecting her to win her game but so far
Kar s winning an important game to today
against T faam and being the sole leader
in the women's section very impressive
Kings IND the in defense that's third
time yeah is wonderful uh winning with
the black pieces and back over to you uh
CHR J is your student uh we might be
seeing a result in that one so perhaps
maybe we can uh see their reaction
there's not much more chest to be played
in this right you probably have to go
back first of all this Pawn has been
dropped um you got to go back and then I
can repeat the position and play E7 and
I don't really the problem is Rook E5
doesn't work because I just simply take
Queen to F6 and you lose uh The Rook so
she went King to G6 may maybe makes more
sense Queen to F7 King to G5 but now I'm
starting to see some sort of checkmating
ideas right I can also go E7 that's
maybe the easy way out but but G3 is
very uh G3 probably have to take right
H4 is a checkmating threat in one right
so you have to take back you give a
check I go to
H5 where's the
mate where's I know why not to just go
E7 and promote ah and first of all Rook
E5 doesn't work anymore exactly um yeah
E7 was played that's a winner well the
thing is if you do go Rook to E5 I still
have that check exactly H4 and King to
F4 or king queen to G7 and G3 now and
then I pick up the Rook on E5 maybe even
with a queen just to not give you any
checks on the first rank actually that's
a way to mess to draw the game that's a
way to mess it up yes you take the Rook
but unfortunately right now there's only
a Perpetual don't do that of course uh
and she went for this E7 so let's uh
let's look at the Players right now
because I don't see
any big options for Talia with with the
clocks also not being a factor in this
one just uh E7 yeah E7 seems to finish
the game Talia is going to be Talia is
gonna be m i I mean she's really been
unlucky if you look the positions that
she's had over the last three rounds
including her game with Alice where she
was at first much worse probably losing
then she was winning and then she lost
that game ouch there was a trend with
Talia right I mean she was getting great
positions but unfortunately you or game
with Jennifer exactly to make the right
decisions at the right moment and that's
exactly what points to the fact that
maybe she's not in the greatest shape in
this event last year she scored bronze
medal
the chionship but this year just there's
a little bit of missing in in every game
and that's what makes a huge difference
in in the point it's always those small
details of course exactly and as we uh
look at these crucial games that are
remaining we're going to jump to the
game of lanir a moment because we saw
where Rook takes A5 Rook takes B4 the
queen side was being eviscerated it's
all about Sam shanklin's pawns and
whether or not he'll be able to generate
enough um counterplay we know from the
chess engine perspective that uh White
is winning and it's pretty clear
uh but you know you sit there again
practical perspective the Knight can be
blocking you know the Rooks from uh from
giving checks and the pawns are running
they're pretty close yes I mean and
they're together connected and but on
the other hand we are in this kind of
awkward situation that if we try to make
a move like F4 we are encouraging uh D6
and then bad things could happen in oh
sorry guys let's go back to to to that
one to uh tal Talia for because I think
we missed a Checkmate in one move okay
that's game over um so Queen to G7 was
the move but if you go King A4 I can
just simply take on H6 that's a
mate ah oh that's nice so perhaps that's
why we've seen resignation early on Oh
you mean at the very end there you know
I was recently doing doing a broadcast
um with with Bon where we did the same
thing we missed a Checkmate and I said
well I and I I wanted to cover for beum
and I said well b i I'm really sorry to
say that you gave a great piece of
analysis but there was a check maid in
one she goes oh yes sir what a shame for
you so we miss a check made one in her
game she's GNA say h what a shame but we
do have in studio Wesley so Christian
over to you and in fact we missed the
end of that one because it finished so
quickly Wesley congratulations an
important Victory and you surprised us
all with your opening choice and how
fast you were playing tell us the story
of this piece of opening
preparation oh yeah hi Christian thank
you well first of all uh what my
birthday yesterday happy birthday
every yes
you're now yeah I'm I'm 30 I'm I'm
catching up to you
Christian but uh yeah it it feels good
being 30 you know you can make as you
get older you can make decisions of your
own and then you know become more of an
adult and uh you know it's more it's
more fun they said my teacher said
before high school was the best times of
your life but you know everyone gets
older and then I know I appreciate all
the experiences I had I'm glad to be
30 but uh very
yes Wesley well welcome to 30 I feel
exactly like you Wesley just you know
that I'm looking forward to you know
maturing and becoming a full adult and
making your own decisions making my own
decisions what happened today you you
you you chose the line that Bobby fiser
played Bishop
C4 oh yeah yeah yeah for sure uh well I
was actually inspired also by Fisher but
also by Magnus he played this uh a few
days ago against Vincent kimer in the
European Club cup but Misha always plays
the nidorf I think he's been
experimenting with the winow as well but
I thought I'd play this risky line
because tourament not going my way also
the last few months has not been going
my way so I thought why not try to play
this risky line then IED it very deeply
but it's it's very double edged and uh
white is not better but I figured it it
doesn't hurt to try and it's a new
change to my usual um my usual games
which always includes trading the Queens
so Wesley how deep was your preparation
in this line where did how do I what
where did your preparation
end well after e takes D5 e takes D so
this so right up until this moment
before the move D5 you you you you knew
about this position you thought it was
even yeah I had very deep analyis here
it's basically just the starting
position of my analysis wow but why is
not better no yeah I mean how fast times
have changed yeah like maybe 40 years
ago you play 1 C4 and then you're out of
book but it about six years ago by the
way
40 you play you play one E4 C6 and then
you're out the book right uh but we
unfor we thought the move D5 was
actually premature did you did you
prepare against Queen A5 then is that
what I understand yes yes it's the main
line but uh yeah it's just a it's just a
I actually had quite a lengthly
discussion with my great opponent with
Mishra okay after um wait isn't his last
name abhimanu or is it Mishra okay I'm
getting confused
Mishra okay I I got it backwards but
anyway I had a lenty discussion Queen A5
uh so he didn't like the move Knight B3
for black but he actually missed a
crucial part he just missed that he
could just take on A3 King A2 Queen A4
Bishop A3
D5 Rook A1 yeah he miss he could just go
like take and queen D6 I guess something
that's what you missed as well yeser
yeah yeah very similar blind spot very
yeah that the queen just actually has a
square if the pawns on
E5 it's good I don't know why Wesley is
laughing at you but yeah no I mean yeah
I mean Misha missed it y missed it like
look hey man you know you're on the same
rating right now yeah right right right
maybe you should play there you go um
after D5 me Queen A5 we also yeah after
Queen A5 G5 is just a dter bishop takes
G5 but Queen A5 like Queen yeah like
Queen A5 I had to play G5 otherwise I'm
worse okay G5 and here black if black
once he can force a door with Bishop
takes Pawn on G5 I see yeah W takes
Knight E3 but I'm very impressed by my
opponent because he found all the best
moves so like take and kn C4 and black
just has forces to draw so I mean I was
ready to draw at this point you know
because me find all the best moves in
the opening and he's got like an
encyclopedic knowledge but I was very
surprised why he played D5 and here is
just an exchange down I didn't like his
move Bishop E5 but maybe there wasn't
anything better I don't know like I
don't know if black could oh there's
also an interesting line so Bishop D6
which we also discuss he could play
Bishop
A3 he could play bishop and then Rook E8
Bishop A3 which I
underestimated and takes takes takes on
E8 yeah there's no other way to defend
the bishop fortunately Rook
D1 Rook B Rook Queen d8 Rook E1 D E1
yeah Queen d8 H6 and I wasn't sure what
was happen happening here I thought
white is better but I could be
wrong where did but King A2 look so
natural to me so I just played
it where did you feel that you had the
game more or less in your favor Wesley
more or less we thought once you got
your kingside going it was it was
winning like here yeah for sure well
when he played D5 I knew it was a big
mistake that was I got very excited all
right yeah I mean he's got an isolated
pawn and then his Bishop on B7 is
blockaded very I mean the bishop on B7
is very passive uh so I was very
happy but uh yeah in the game I I don't
think there was a way to save it for
black right although I'm not an engine
so your first win of the tournament
you're witnessing Fabby uh win three
games in a row your thoughts uh with the
tournament
ahead um well Fabby has obviously been
very impressive he's
gained uh almost uh 50 points in the
last 10 months I believe so he's doing
really well I was very impressed by his
game against Darius the other day uh he
wasn't better but you know Fabby is just
type of player who just knows how to
play chess he's a complete allaround
player you know it's very good in the
openings and you know he can just he can
just play chess unfortunately
so yeah I mean like some players for
example are very good at one thing let's
say tactics or the openings or
calculating but uh Fabi is just a very
good chess player
overall and uh yeah as for me I just
take it uh a game at a time you know try
as I mentioned earlier the last few
months haven't been going my way but you
know I'll just take it easy try to be
happy and relax and uh if it doesn't go
my way that's fine that's what I that's
that's happened before thank you Wesley
for joining us we're happy to let you
relax and take it easy we see you yeah I
will see you again uh where's the action
uh Christian as Hans would probably say
he's pretty decent for a
podcaster well let's see what's
happening in uh Alice Lee versus pussian
Alice seems to be on top in this one
it's all about this Hans versus leevon
is he managing to break through because
this was not an easy one right but he
managed to calculate very well G3 by the
way was levon's I would say big chance
in the position yes because after Knight
to E2 you continue pushing G2 now you
can have to stop me from going R to H1
so you need to bring the king closer but
now I can start picking up some pawns
and this is not that easy because the
material gets limited you go KN G3 I
exchange another uh Pawn take take you
take on G2 but F4 maybe Rook to C5 as
well I might be getting close to
exchanging that last PA right but the
way he played it the way leevon played
it seems to have allowed Hans to build
up his advantage of even more because
the pawn on E5 is Untouchable Knight C6
check you take Knight to C6 that's
that's the key of this position right
you cannot take that pawn on E5 and if
you don't take that I will be able to
arrange my pieces in a very harmonious
way we have Rook to E1 KN to
E2 I closed the action of The Rook I
stopped the pawn at least momentarily
for example if you go G3 now I can go
King to D2 and I have The Rook ready to
uh get into play as well what I wanted
you cannot go Rook to A1 because of
Knight C1 oh now I'm um picking up the
for fre Pawn for free and you have to
save your Rook as well which is not an
easy task you have to go uh King to B1
uh Rook to B1 I can go King to C2
everything is working my way right I
will pick this guy up on G2 I will go
after the F7 Pawn this is just simply
over so after Knight to E2 I'm looking
at the position Hans is looking good
guys wow in this one and and he might be
keeping Pace not fully with Fabiano but
definitely only half a point behind if
he wins this one that's going to be a
tremendous result PE keeping Pace with
Carissa yep is beum and she is in studio
Christian your student beim first of all
congratulations welcome back to the
studio this was not an easy game did she
surprise you in the opening when she
allowed this uh morazzi Buy
hi guys it's good to be back yes
absolutely she surprised me she never
plays C5 so I didn't even look at uh
that line for some reason and I was like
okay let's just play and obviously I
didn't get anything out of the opening
well the marozi Bine is always uh
supposedly better for white right you
have more space and if she doesn't do
something tremendous dynamically then
you're just simply going to have an
advantage in the middle game a long-term
advantage in the middle game where do
you feel like you're taking over the
initiative when did you feel like you're
making and finding that
breakthrough uh I thought the Knight G4
idea like giving exchanging the Knight
to U Bishop wasn't that great for her
and then after Bishop D4 I felt like at
least I have long-term you know slight
Advantage because my knight is way
better than the bishop and I play this
lines since uh I was a kid and I love it
for white so I felt very comfortable and
when she played C5 I was like okay it's
going to be a good day absolutely no
matter what because I really like you
like this type of position for wine
right yeah I do like it and then things
changed a little bit in uh the late
middle game uh phase and at this point
she gave you the queen but it wasn't
easy because maybe she could find some
sort of a blade right how did you feel
about this how did you feel about the
assessment of this
position uh before I played E5 I saw
this position and I felt like it should
it should be easier than than it was
actually when I was like evaluating I I
felt like this position should be better
for me but when I got the position I
started to think I'm like I don't have
much I felt like maybe I rushed into
this like C5 and it wasn't the most
precise way to play uh was white but
then uh I was happy with my position and
queen E1 trick I just got very likey
Queen uh B4 Queen H4 it's coming if she
doesn't take on C5 then my idea is to
play B4 and she cannot take on A4
because of Queen A1 check that was my
idea yeah and then is if I'm pushing uh
B5 then I should be already winning so
it was kind of yeah at some point I
wanted to play Rook D1 and exchange the
uh Rooks and and then last minute I
decided not I feel like I should keep
the rops so it was a little bit
confusing for me but somehow it worked
out because she had time trouble and she
couldn't figure out how to uh defend the
position better I guess beim uh well the
pressure that he put on your opponent
paid off today congratulations another
important Victory will let you go rest
uh because you're still neck and neck
with Carissa this is a very tight
race yeah it looks fun so far
nice uh congratulations beum once again
standings before we take a a break just
I mean because we're seeing a lot of
results today it was that free day the
players uh electrified got electrified
with the ladies um so we have two
leaders here Kar s and beim to janova
both won a game today and they are
Leaders with four points out of six and
in the open section and in the open
section we have a soul leader
let's see him yes Fabiano Carana winning
an important game today and also having
four points but we think Hans nean might
be uh catching him a little bit with a
victory over leavon potentially three
and a half points for Hans as we go on
break uh Sabina caught up with Alice Lee
had a nice little interview hope you
enjoy
[Music]
it
Alice thank you so much for joining me
today I want to ask you a little bit
about your chess up bringing there's
been a lot talked about you in the media
but I want to hear it again from you I
started playing chess when I was six
years old um so my brother was going to
the school chess club and uh I went to
lawn also because my parents just wanted
to drop us up at the same time um so
after I started playing in the chess
club I was actually like one of the very
worst and uh for me it was just I lost a
lot I was kind of upset but um as I kept
uh actually not losing every single game
I became more motivated and eventually I
played in my first rated tournament uh
that summer and from there I think it
was just I really loved the game which
allowed me to continue to uh enjoy chess
while playing it very nice and how did
you get into playing a lot online and
how do you combine that with um studying
over the board yeah um so I think
especially in the recent years there's
been a lot of uh new chess resources
both online and also books published um
so for me I did go over some uh books
for example the 100 end games you must
know um and Mauricio flor's uh Pawn
structures book um I also used like uh
some online tools for example chess
Tempo and chessable um I think they have
a lot of great resources and for me uh I
think especially in this new generation
uh where everything is just so much
stronger it's really great to have all
these new resources and you're spending
a lot of time online could you give me
an approximate uh amount of time that
you spend per day working on chess um so
actually this year I'm doing online
school so it makes it flexible for my
schedule um so I guess before high
school started I was spending like a
couple hours a day on chess sometimes
more especially during the summer when I
was playing in a lot of tournaments now
the high school started uh it's more
work um so I have to I guess find a new
B since for me it's my first year and I
haven't really had to do something like
this in the past um but I hope that at
least I'll be able to find some sort of
balance between schoolwork and chess and
I'll be able to at least play well in
this tournament you've had some amazing
results lately congratulations for
winning gold medal uh at the women's
world team championship how was that how
did you feel that moment yeah so that
was actually like the first tournament
that I played in uh like internationally
on that stage so I think it was really
great for me to be able to do so well
there and of course it was like a really
great experience to be playing on the
first board against such strong players
um I I definitely wasn't expecting to uh
win the gold medal there I was just
hoping you know I could at least do okay
um but uh for me it was great that uh I
was able to have like really good
results and it was my first like really
really strong it was a really great
experience for me do you feel nervous at
all or did you feel at that time nervous
because you you know representing the
United States and there was your first
competition of of this kind yeah I mean
uh so beforehand I actually thought I
was playing on the second board so I was
like okay not as much pressure and then
when I went there like oh I'm playing
number one okay um so it is a team event
and there's something nice which is that
um even if you don't have your desired
result uh you can still hope that your
teammates also do well um of course
there's a little bit more pressure as
well because you want to win for your
team um but for me I was just like
trying to focus game at the game and I
was able to like find I guess a good
start and then after that I think I
think I just got a some good results
very very awesome congratulations again
for that I want to ask you one more
thing regarding this tournament um so
last year as you mentioned maybe your
result wasn't as great but you've had a
great uh year where you've improved a
lot um I think you supposed to get your
International Master title very soon and
this year you're one of the favorites do
you feel any pressure at all or have you
been able by now to deal with all your
emotions and are you just going to take
it a day a game at yeah uh so last year
I was I think a lot more inexperience
and this year I've played in like a lot
more strong tournaments so I have
slightly more experience I mean uh for
me I guess I am one of the top Seas but
I don't think I'm like the very favorite
so that's something that's kind of nice
because I don't have so much like
pressure that everybody expects me to
win um and I guess for this tournament
well I think winning would be nice I
it's also extremely hard because the
field is so strong um and for me I'll
just take it one game at a time and try
to play my best very nice thank you so
much Alice I wish you good luck and
looking forward to your
[Music]
games yeah um it's amazing what the club
has done for chess in general because I
mean it's already been 15 years and
they've done countless uh national
championships tournaments for juniors
helping Ground Schools and and they've
just grown the game so much across the
United States I think if I look at my
own career and I look at American chest
in general we're in a much better place
than we were 15 years ago and so the
contributions have been immense and of
course it's all thanks to Dr Jun
singfield and Rex
singfield I would say that St Lucia's
Club is like a rock in the ocean of
Chess and we know that it's it's there
it is there it will be there I think it
sense a hope that the game of chess
will always stay afloat by the mere fact
of its existence I think it it it sends
positive waves across the
globe the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States we bring the educational benefits
of Chess to thousands of students across
the St Louis area we also promote Chess
at the highest levels hosting all levels
of the US championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit St Louis chess club.org to
claim your membership
today the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Louis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess has intrigued people around
the world for nearly 1500 years stop by
and learn about the impact of Chess from
our three floor showcase the art culture
and history of the game the World Chess
Hall of Fame has something for everyone
to enjoy for more information on current
exibits please visit World Chess h.org
[Music]
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85,000 students in both in
school and after school programs we
created the select chess training
program and the junior select chess
training program in order to elevate the
skill level in students across the St
Louis area these students receive
professional training from Grandmaster
verua niobian other programs include
chess cops a partnership with the St
Louis Police Department looking to
improve relationships between atrisk
kids and police officers in the St Louis
area with over 600 students playing
chess over the board since
2019 the St Louis chess club has also
created a chess merit badge for the
scouts BSA quickly becoming one of the
most popular badges with more than
250,000 Scouts earning the badge since
2011 students of chess can also pick up
a copy of readand write chess thanks to
Club co-founder Dr jeie Karen sinkfield
anyone can learn how to understand chess
notation in notes time we view chess as
a valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting St Louis chess club.org
education St Louis the chess capital of
the United States boasts the worldclass
St Louis chess club and the World Chess
Hall of Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise all occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chess
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q Boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to
enjoy the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States and is among the best in the
world thanks to co-founders Dr jeie
Karen sinkfield and Rex singfield the St
Louis chess Club is a nonprofit
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess locally and
internationally we bring the educational
benefits of Chess to thousands of
students across the St Louis area
promoting cognitive development critical
thinking concentration and analytical
skills the St Louis chess club welcomes
chess lovers of any age and skill level
to come and enjoy the game of chess we
also promote Chess at the highest levels
hosting all levels of the US champ
championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sinkfield cup
Ken's cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also include over
2,000 chess lectures for anyone to enjoy
become a member and enjoy perks such as
free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit St Louis chess club.org
to claim your membership
today the S CH Club is celebrating its
hello everyone and Welcome to our live
coverage of round five of the 2023
national championships with three games
remaining in this round we've seen a
very result driven uh round with lots of
decisive games with more to come it
would appear as Hans is uh winning very
crucial game against leavon aronian over
to you Christian absolutely and uh
perhaps we can see the situation right
now because I don't think this game is
going to last for uh very much longer
Rook to F4 was the last move we see a
check by leevon on A3 but once I move my
king anywhere probably to D4 seems like
the most available Square I will take on
F7 and the problem is you're also losing
the pawn on E6 and that's the key you
lose the pawn on E6 that's over so Hans
reaching for the king king D4 as you've
prescribed Rook takes A4 I don't see any
resignations coming it's coming it's
Rook takes F7 check I'm going to move my
king and uh well this is not an easy
choice of course but let's say King to
C8 yes and I'm dreaming of the move B6
B5 that's fine you can have it I'll give
have that yes yes I will so you're going
to go Rook E7 give me B5 I might not
even try to stop you from going B5 and
uh you're just going with the
combination of King Rook Knight and pawn
Knight C5 there Knight C5 first of all
Rook C6 Rook C6 is completely winning so
for example if you go A4 right now okay
then I can just go Rook C6 wow you take
take you go A3 I go Knight B4 then I
pick up the pawn on B5 and that's
it okay fair enough yep that
uh you got me yeah no question about it
that looks that looks uh simple to be
sure and uh just I mean for leavon Kate
you help me here this
is this is a real setback I mean he
hasn't he drew all of his games four
games he comes in he tried to be
creative with different boang uh against
him wow but it wasn't that bad I mean he
he sacrificed the peace and he he almost
fought his way back I'm not going to say
to equality but he was close uh
knight4 Knight F4 something similar he's
very similar you want to just recapture
with Knight on E6 and then the king can
still go forward to D exactly so Knight
F4 more or less I'm going to say a
tactical way of completing the Affairs
right Knight takes E6 Rook takes C4 King
D5 we get the same type of position of
Knight rook and pawn versus I mean I
just was thinking Rook Knight King life
is very very very good and as we watch
Hans nean putting the finishing touches
on this game another huge game going on
between l and Sam Shanklin that also uh
is so important for our standings and we
do have B5 on the board we should we
should stay with with that one cuz that
one the Shanklin game is going to go on
for a for a long time to come for a
little while it it's nowhere close to
being over this one I have a feeling
it's not going to last long so B5 on the
board as expected Knight takes wait do I
have just Rook f8 check and Knight C5
that's his idea as well yes I'm sorry
you have what
hard so Knight takes E6 Knight takes E6
Rook takes C4
check King and now A4 now you want to
give me Rook check and Knight C5 KN I
thought it's different but I think still
Knight C5 here yes good well Knight C5
is King D5 and we do have King D5 on the
board this is the current
position as the players update their
score sheets they just I guess pass the
60 move rule we always had those score
sheets that had 60 moves you
know I had I want once I had a score
sheet that looked like a score book
Because I had so many of these 60 move
score sheets um
how made in 19 no no you're not coming
back from this how recoverable is this
no it's not no no that's not happening
check made a 19 no he he can do a lot of
things things he can go Knight C5 he can
go Rook f8 he can even go for the B5
Pawn with either the Knight or The Rook
I think the easiest way and the most
practical choice is to just go Rook a
7even followed by Rook a five which uh
from your lips to H's ear Rook A7 yes
just get behind the pawn
freezes freezes the pawn never mind the
fact that I'm hanging a rook but freezes
the pawn gets The Rook behind setting up
for Knight C5 or Knight D4 for example
if you go something like Rook C3 yeah
and I just go Knight D4 tag that pawn on
B5 you go B4 I pick up the on A4
exactly that looks very good no that
looks extremely clean actually this is a
huge it is E5 is also running yes
especially I was thinking Knight C5 and
King C6 but you're absolutely right the
E Pawn you know Knight C5 E6 and a check
an
E7 uh also very very simple way of
winning and what is Sur a devastating
loss for sure because he's been
struggling in the last year in the last
couple of years in fact right now he
lost a lot of rating as Wesley was
pointing out as well MH they haven't
been having the best of years and uh
this tournament is Big this tournament
is of great importance for both of these
players he tried I mean look he showed I
want to win today I really want to win
to
to create some imbalance is just not
going his way Hans played a great game
he did he did um just thinking about the
two players in particular who played out
of their field if you will leavon he's
been defending E4 E5 his entire career
he played a sicilian today Tata has been
playing E4 her entire career wanted to
prepare for a line of the Kings Indian
she got her preparation Carissa said
look you're in my playground and we see
resignation the resignation has been
completed and another decisive
game
wow uh for the open section we started
with one win in round one and then it
was just but suddenly yeah but suddenly
the floodgates today what happened today
Christian was it the free day it's the
it's the day after the rest day
everybody
with energy Renewed Energy and they're
trying to bring their best food forward
and that's exactly what we're seeing
right now and everybody's ready to
battle as usual right they know that if
they want to win the tournament they
need to win games because at least one
of the players always tries to run away
with it in this case it's fa who's
obviously showing uh great skill and
great Poise up to this point but take a
look at this I mean Hans is only half a
point behind remarkable big big win for
hson this one and turning our attention
to the game of lanir and Sam Shanklin so
lanir has been nursing an
exchange uh having an exchange ahead I
mean to say for quite some time but on
the other hand Sam earlier had what
looked like some very nice coordination
of the Knight and the rook and it looked
like the pawns were actually going to
get further than they did lanir has done
a great job at
freezing uh blacks pawns and now he
looks like he's ready to go King B4 a
pardon me King a A3 B4 and push his
pawns uh he looks much closer to winning
now does laner than he did about 20
moves ago I don't know if Sam slipped or
whatever but uh right because the white
now can just go and support the pawns
exactly for for Le for lanir much like
Wesley winning uh his first game and for
Sam Shanklin this would be a setback he
he was he was feeling pretty good after
the rest day two and a half out of four
always thinking that maybe he left a
half a point on the table I guess I'm
going to break your bubble oh no finally
it's looking like this is uh a draw no
yes what yes yes after is that right
after Knight to E5 uh it seems like
shankland managed to fight his way back
into this game why so what if I go King
A3 and just start supporting the I think
I'm just pushing I push as well that's
fine Rook
D5 let's go Rook D5 just in case so I'm
going to sacrifice at some point you
have to take right right and these pawns
take take F3 yes and I go back to the
first you have to go back now I get
close and it's a race right you know
it's it's in fact it's not a race
because I go back towards your pawns and
that's the mechanism I go back and then
I use my Rook to connect with the F Pawn
from behind Rook F5 F2 to freeze The
Rook that's going to freeze The Rook on
F1 and I'm just simply going to stay
stick around the pawns a blockade so if
you think about it Knight E5 was played
it's not even that difficult from a
conceptual point of view so Shanklin
might be feeling quite good right now
about his chances to potentially get a
half a point a crucial half a point by
the way because he was pretty much lost
that's remark able and the crazy part is
as we were at the opening ceremony Sam
was very
happy his his new book right on Rook
endings had just been uh published and
he's played Rook endings almost nonstop
had like four Rook endings T I mean the
irony of that and now again another Rook
ending that is crazy I guess his sails
are going to go through the roof
right provided he maximizes uh The Rook
endings that he gets Knight E 5 Kate you
could knock me over with a feather right
now I I was really really stunned Rook
H5 okay when uh Christian is saying that
uh Sam's closing in on a draw just when
we were thinking White's closing in on a
win King A3 B4 but Knight E5 with the
idea of f4 maybe this is what he missed
from afar take a look at this uh move F4
right now and his intention I think was
maybe Rook takes correct but now I have
Knight
D3 uh oh and there's a discover check
Against The Rook that's right and King
C3 Rook takes H5 right King D3 and
that's good enough for a draw This is
the End Game you're proposing with a
rook F5 yes King to E5 first oh King E5
first I need to stop you from going King
E4 and by the way as we interrupt our
analysis of this crucial game we have
another guest interview over to you
Christian Hans is in the house Hans
welcome uh back to the show
congratulations this game uh it started
off as early as move to there was no
opening preparation he surprised you
because he usually doesn't play the
Sicilian in fact at move one tell us
about your reaction and how did you
approach that
game yeah well he's been playing C5 in
Blitz like at the levitov tournament he
played a lot of uh C5 um online um I
don't know the last time he played C5 in
a classical game it must be years maybe
you guys can check I I I don't
uh in colasso was quite a surprise but
um I briefly I checked like a couple of
his games in C5 E6 but I didn't prepare
anything um but I guess I had a nice uh
counter
surprise what was your uh counter
surprise well the C3 E5 idea and the
funny thing about this is that um I was
playing in Mexico the world juniors and
next to me there was a game like Yan
subel against rudic marcaron and I saw
that um this idea was played and I was
so impressed by the idea um and honestly
I've never checked this line once in my
life um but it looked nice I thought it
would be a nice surprise and like from
what I remember the game that seemed
like enough uh preparation um so I guess
uh the fact that I don't pay enough
attention to my own games helped me out
here because I remember seeing this game
next to me and being so uh so impressed
um by what was happening um so that's
why I decided to go for for this line
and um it worked out well because
obviously he's not uh going to be aware
of this type of sideline if it's his
first time playing uh this this type of
idea absolutely still it was a very
imbalanced very complex uh game but it
felt like you just understood the
position better at this point after
Bishop takes C4 Queen takes C4 how did
you assess it obviously he was trying to
start an attack on the king side but
finally you got the light squore Bishop
you have the two Bishops Advantage it
felt good from a practical perspective
coming from your side did you feel the
same way yeah know I felt uh very very
good here um I think once I saw H5 I
thought the this is this is the biggest
Bluff in the world
I'm not going to uh uh okay maybe it's a
fine move but I don't really uh H5 with
the IDE H4 is definitely not working um
so I was not worried about opening up my
own f file um so that's this was good
yeah I guess G4 yeah so this was good
yeah G4 G4 was good yeah he mentioned
after the game that he should have
played Knight H4 after Knight D4 it felt
very very bad um yeah I take take Rook
F3 was my idea yeah and then um
oh no Bishop H4 Rook
F3 and I wasn't sure I didn't see RI C8
but yeah I have like Rook H3 I saw this
RF Rook H3 maneuver but I wasn't sure
how to evaluate but I thought there's no
way I can there's no way I'm not better
here is that what you guys were
discussing after the game no he just
told me that he missed after Knight F D4
that I could play Bishop takes D4 that's
that's all all we discussed yeah Bishop
takes D4 and when did you feel like
you're by the way I this moment G5 yeah
G4 G5 was a very good idea but after
Bishop to E3 you had 33 minutes on the
clock and you ended up spending a lot of
close to 30 minutes on so King F yeah so
King F1 Queen E5 um that's what I was B6
I obviously understood that I was fine
so Queen takes E5 right uh Rook takes B7
Queen takes E4 mhm Bishop takes E4 Rook
takes H4 uh Bishop takes C6 and uh here
I yeah obviously Rook A7 is winning but
I was trying to make C5 work um C5 C5
uhuh I spent my time C5 but he has yeah
Rook Rook h8 Rook D h8 Bishop G2 and
then I thought Bishop F4 and I couldn't
figure it out okay yeah oh yeah I saw
Rook B3 I wasn't sure how to evaluate
this but this is not that clear right I
spent I spent all my time calculating
this when it just Rook takes A7 it just
game over it was very stupid I think
maybe the nerves uh were affecting me
because obviously I should just play uh
Rook t7 it's just game
over of this Rook H7 if he goes King
Rook to h8 Brook B7 and then there's no
mate on H1 because your Bish so he he
has to play um he has to play Rook D6
but after Bishop G2 it's just game
over I don't know why eventually it took
me 30 minutes to realize this apparently
so but uh yeah B6 obviously like I saw
um
and I thought I played okay after this
maybe I wasn't that precise I I was
pretty happy with this it was this
moment when you didn't necessarily let
him back into the game but you gave him
some opportunities oh wow how is he wait
wait so what was the moment can you G oh
so this is actually right now yeah so 92
G2 what were yeah 92 G2 King E3 mhm yeah
King E3 Rook
H5
we weren't really sure how to assess
this one whether you have enough King F2
Rook E5 for a win or if he man yeah you
probably have you probably have like you
know 10 only moves in a row and then
maybe you hold right right yeah
that's yeah no it was very difficult
with with the time situation he was uh
putting a lot of pressure so I couldn't
really find the clear way um still H I
mean I guess I think after that you uh
took over the game and you made the best
moves in the position was very this was
and then 81 yeah and okay just he
blunder 191 yeah this is just a loss
yeah well Hans congratulations big
victory for you how do you feel uh to be
beating a
2700 plus level
player well leavon is such such a legend
so uh it's obviously an honor to play
against him and to win the game uh the
last three games we've played actually
the first game uh I had almost basically
winning position the second game I had
great positions so uh uh I feel like
I've showed my good chess in our in our
three games um uh the last year's
championship game even with black I was
doing well so of course it's it's an
honor for me to beat him he's like uh
one of the greatest uh players of of
modern times um you know he was like
number two in the world for a very long
time or one of the top 10 players so
it's um it means a lot to to to beat him
and um especially after he sort of
slipped away the last two times uh it's
nice to to to win it's you and Fabby at
the top right now closely following each
other how do you see this uh race
playing out in the next few
rounds well um he did just beat Andrew
who's who's been struggling so I guess
it'll be pretty it'll be sort of crucial
to to beat beat him since he sort the on
paper at least uh very very uh he's the
target um so I think this will mainly
come down to um beating sort of the
lower seats um because the top players
uh are quite difficult to beat so this
is a very big win but
um uh you know I'm playing well um in in
all five games that I've played uh I've
had a winning position um I was winning
against Sam um winning against dorius so
I think that I'm I'm definitely creating
chances in the games um I'm outplaying
my opponents um I think this game I I
showed a good level of technique and
consistency um and I just need to keep
up my level but uh I feel like uh I can
outplay uh anyone uh so um I'll try to
keep playing my best chess Katherina you
have a question for Hans yeah Hans I
have to ask because during your um
previous interview you said that you
really enjoy inspiring young minds and
you like in engaging in community
service so how was your community
service during the rest
day it was great um uh what we did is we
had um basically we played on the
the this like the board that people
what's the demo board the analysis board
the big board that people and we had a
demon board and it was yeah
demonstration board yeah sorry and it
was um we basically played hand and
brain and all of the kids uh got in a
line and each one would come up and say
peace uh so it made things quite
interesting because there was varying
levels of skill um I actually remember I
can uh I was thinking I've been thinking
about this game so basically it uh maybe
you can bring up a board I'd just like
to show the game if if you can bring up
a board it's very interesting since you
asked and you're so curious you got it
so uh it was uh it was E4 E5 F4 um EF uh
D4 and they played
D5 um um Bishop takes F4 Bishop E6
Bishop B5
check and then I was really hoping
because so here they said Bishop so I'm
trying to think okay let's go Bishop B5
check they'll see that C6 attacks the
the bishop and then they'll say bishop
and I can go Bishop D3 but after
C6 they said uh they said
Knight so so after C6 I went Knight C
Knight C3 C takes B5 Knight takes B5
um Knight
A6 and then now they say
Pawn so I said uh I said
E5 and um then they said Bishop Bishop
before check
C3 Bishop A5 Knight
D6 uh King f8 uh Knight F3 Knight
E7 uh
castles and then they went um what did
they
play
H let me think what did they play trying
to think what did
they by the way as you're thinking who
was the brain who was the
hand I I was the hand that's that's what
so each kid would would be contemplating
what move they're going to play and they
would sit there so nervously and and and
uh it was uh but basically what happened
was is
uh let me
think basically we got like
95 and uh I sacked a rook and everything
worked out quite beautifully there was
some very painful moments lots of
compens something like this happened
something yeah something like this
happened um perhaps I yeah so basically
something like this happened and uh we
won after sacrificing this pie and at
some point my team just started saying
every single perfect piece they were
reading my mind we had great C
um so I was very very uh happy with how
that game went of course even such a
casual game among school kids I take
extremely seriously um this is this was
I'm not messing around you know Victory
must be attained at all costs any
emerging out of St Louis any potential
applicants to your scholarship
H um I I think that um you know uh uh I
from the club has told me that uh
there's like you know a lot lot of Chess
programs it said you almost 100 um chess
programs so I'm sure that if you give it
some time there will be some emerging
chess talents from St Louis um you know
the main chess talents from America come
out of California and New York um mostly
because of the the school programs and
then the access to tournaments
um uh so I I think that um maybe a
couple more years and we'll start to see
some some emerging St Louis you know
talents from the you know Capital uh the
chess capital of America well
congratulations uh Hans big victory for
you we'll see you
tomorrow thank you our congratulations
as well indeed Hans uh hand and brain
that can be very very fun and it can be
very very frustrating as well as I just
want to jump into our remaining game in
the open section lanir versus Sam
Shanklin now this is a completely
different kettle of fish uh this wasn't
The Rook F5 uh um sorry
remember we you you you gave us a
position a moment ago uh Christian where
there was a black Rook there was a white
Rook uh passively placed here in this
particular oh he did go back I was about
to say can't we put our Rook
aggressively behind the pawn but am I
quck maybe with like Rook H4 Rook F4
that's right that's the problem is that
the problem so checking Rook back Rook
down sorry and you're quick like this
and you have to go to a D3 if you want
to do
something this is this is that this is
the position or something like that
position you were telling me where the
pawn and then the king gets back right
and as fast as possible for a blockade
gotcha so I'm just going to refresh the
board get the current position and the
assessment of this this well isn't this
the same thing then F3 and Rook F3 right
let's try it out so you go F2 King Rook
F1 Rook F3 and then it's but maybe
you're not in time right A5 now
A5 A6 A6 A7 A7 Rook takes F2 after Rook
f8 I don't know this is not that easy
right so maybe F2 is not the correct
we why don't we get closer that pawn
let's go something like King E5 or King
E6 okay whichever you want
so I just like the the fact that your
Rook is kind of messed up and it's not
you know6 yeah it's not supporting right
the pawn how did you continue if you go
before before now I put my Rook behind I
go H4 and Rook F4 right yeah it's true
and if I go King B5 now I go F2 now you
play F2 and you're just in time yes to
get your setup
right wow hold on just humor me a few
more moves King B6 all right let's see
King D7 King David 7 okay yeah I'm
trying to get behind you basically at
all times um you want to go King C8 B8
King C8
yeah wow so can I go King B7 here King
B7 maybe I can go Rook F4 but then you
go B5 right right and that should be
winning yeah this is this is the dream
position for me uh to trade the a pawn
put my king in front of the pawn and
then build a bridge uh as we very well
know so so it's still not that easy not
at all it's still not that easy by the
way guys maybe we can switch to the
women's section because Ally she traded
Rooks and I think that's good for her
because that Bishop end game I think
looks very good for her well definitely
we were always talking about the a pond
as well as the E Pond being uh the more
dangerous
because this Pawn on C5 has been
blockaded and hasn't played a role like
a pass Pawn should this looks winning
just when we look at the king side you
see the G6 and H5 they're both pawns
light light squares so they can be
picked up yeah bishop4 now I go E5
correct just go E5 E6 A6 by the way you
can even get a a third more potent pass
Pawn the H Pawn as well you have a pawn
yeah you you have a Pawn on E6 you'll
have a Pawn on A6 and you'll have a H
Pawn and the king is fabulous is this
Alice's second won
be from well she was winning then she
was losing then she was winning and
finally did win so she's back to 50%
with a victory if she wins this game and
that's huge for her for her chances as
well because once again just like in the
open somebody's running away with this
event right well you've got two uh
ladies uh in the case of the Women's
Championship Carissa and be but I really
don't see how you are stopping it
because
E6 you have to bring the bishop back
because you can move with your king then
the pawn on A5 is running exactly now
this looks I I mean no suggestions if I
go King you go E6 and just as you said I
can't move my king back uh to stop this
one because uh bridesmaids right
threatening
A7 and with the the promotion Square
protected so yeah we
think it
wins yeah A5 A5 looks good wow there's
no way to stop it right so we've got in
the women's section two co-leaders but
we've got Arena
Crush uh just defeating a huge rival of
hers and point behind half a point
behind behind and we've got Alice Lee
who very very quietly is moving up the
ranks Kate but I have to say the two
leaders Kar sa and bag to janova with
four points out of five right but look
at the difference between after the
third after the podium right already two
and a half points that's one and half
points gap between the first and the
fourth that's a big G it's true and
atusa not winning this one that's going
to remain that one and a half point
right exactly exactly so commanding I I
want to say commanding lead for those
three ladies right now definitely a
three horse race up at least up to this
point but Alice Lee she's going to be
facing uh those players also in the
first place uh not uh no she's she lost
she lost against Karissa she Drew
begging in the first round oh my
goodness that's absolutely right and
with Arena
that gameena still has begim and still
has Alis Lee right so those are big
matchups that are coming up so when I
look at that leadership group I say
Carissa is the one who's done
extraordinarily well because she played
a lot of her direct competitors that's
what I mean yes and then extremely well
yes and you know she was saying before
the tournament she played the Juniors
she won a um silver medal there I
believe right but she said it was a good
training to kind of get ready for the US
Championship oh definitely and it's a
confidence Factor too you go to an event
by the way the world juniors is just so
much fun you're meeting all of these top
players from all over the world and
you're competing and if you compete
successfully you feel so much better
about but it's also very difficult
tournament I remember playing it and
it's just so long right right well in my
day it was 13 Rounds so it was very very
long yes as uh by the way I we gonna see
Alice making a move I feel like she we
haven't we haven't seen E5 yet no not
yet I think one one of the things she's
really calculating is instead of the
move E5 she's also calculating uh King
B5 because she's thinking okay I go King
B5 you go Bishop
here I go
A6 no E5 it is here I'm threatening the
big move A7 and if I if you go back back
I go here and if you try to take ah
gotcha so that was what she was she
might have been thinking as opposed to
the move she eventually played which was
E5 King B5 uh also very attractive
looking move but I love E5 E5 E6 bring
force that Bishop to step back follow it
up with F5 take that pawn on H5 give
yourself yet another pass Pawn that
looks like uh Bishops of opposite color
nothing doing and once again back over
to you Christian and the Sam shanin game
no this uh end game is not easy at all
um this is the position we have right
now A5 was played after King to E7 was
shanklin's decision we were discussing
about bringing this King towards the
pawns that's the key mechanism in the
position okay King to B5 sorry after
King to E7 A5 was the move and Rook to H
four now I'm looking through the lines
this is not easy at all if you go King
to B5 now F2 and Rook to F4 both lose F2
and Rook to F4 both lose yes because I
go Rook toec needed there Rook to F4 and
now A6 and you're not in time wow so the
way to make a draw right now is to go
Rook to H5 I would assume this is the
mechanism that he's looking for Rook to
H5 King to B6 and now King King to d8 oh
my goodness that's
inredible King to d8 is the only move in
this position maybe that's why he went
to E7 he understands what he sorry to
interrupt you Christian because you're
on a great train of thought here but
just the move Rook H5 check I find
counterintuitive because it seems like
you're helping me you're putting my king
in a better
Square precis it's not the only move but
I'm looking at all the other ones
they're not intuitive at all to
h8 wow is a draw as well King to D7 King
to d8 maybe that's more natural but if
you don't mind continue your thought
Rook H5 check King B6 King d8 only move
why is that mechanism drawing so what do
you do right now is the question I I
need to wait you and by the way uh it
seems like perhaps Alice and atusa are
going to shake hands
soon you think so we are being told that
this is going to happen anytime soon
I'm not sure about that I think there's
still things going on uh we'll keep an
eye on that but please once again just
clear the cob cobwebs why was well
perhaps they will shake hands actually
now sense yes yes yes because uh E5
Bishop to E3 came A6 King B6 but now you
cannot catch the pawn I go E6 after E6
yes E6 and that's it so maybe that's a
good point you're right maybe our
producers are uh what do they know come
on not as bad as we thought are you know
maybe they actually know
so Peruan niobian St Louis University
coach uh as Dr Fred said you know like
they're very proud in St Louis yeah this
one seems to be over and atusa has last
seconds yeah but she's Shing hands good
call and our congratulations to Alice
with a row backto back
victories he brings her into the
discussion because she was really out of
this tournament and now back to you
and right now Rook H5 by the way was the
move played by he played it I mean who's
better to find this move than a person
who just published a book on theoretical
he's going to sell some copies after
this one for sure I got to tell you
that's impressive he's proving his
skills King B6 King d8 only move why is
now so you you had to include the check
why do you this is the key moment guys
we have to watch this moment right now
let's let's just wait and see once he it
will explain it no oh my goodness what
he's he's he's picking up the Rook oh
he's he reached for The Rook he's he's
trying to pick up the Rook guys so he
wants to give another Rook check if he
does that he's
lost if he G if he gives Rook H6 after
King to C7 he's lost because then your
body check attacking the king have IDE
Rook W yes keeping the king at Bay oh my
goodness oh yeah he's going to play with
the Rook his oh this is this is
it this will be the decision that's
going to haunt him tonight and he still
has a lot of time almost nine minutes he
doesn't look like he's reaching for his
King does look like he's reaching for
either F2 or even Rook H6
check very
stoic linear right now H6 just King B7
or King C7 is King C7 only move King C7
followed by Rook e one chance maybe
that's what he's missing right now in
this moment and he's done it Rook
H4 okay so he wants to give obviously a
rook Rook B4 check but your point was
that after King C7 a couple of moves win
right now actually more than a couple A6
is a winning move Rook to A1 to get
behind is a winning move as well and
King to C7 I love that move King to C7
right now because the idea behind King
C7 is I really want to drive away the
king with the move Rook E1 check and
pick up the Rook with A6 so I love this
move King C7 I mean I would find that
move right away that that that just I
find that move to be so appealing please
tell me King C7 is a winning move yes
King C7 is one of them one of the three
that one of the three but A6 also is a
win A6 the same and the idea is check of
course now I can go A5 or C5 both of
them uh win okay so hold on you're
telling me this is another win that's
right so that after Rook B4 check you
don't play King C7 anymore you play King
A5 King A5 or King C5 and after
A1 whoa
fancy so you're just threatening to play
A7 yes and if the Rook goes passive then
your king is not in time to win my Rook
I go A7 you move your Rook I go King B6
my next move is Rook here and I clip the
pawn that's right wow okay please help
clear the cobweb so it was a check we do
know uh everybody we do know that Sam
did play the move Rook H4 and that's a
but why was King d8 the money move so
the question is what is my purpose is to
get with the king in front of those
pawns right so that I can start giving
you checks and set up that defensive
mechanism that we were just discussing
right so if I play a B4 B4 makes the
most sense right and you play King C8 I
go King now I go F2 so the timing needs
to be so precise this is such a
difficult end game F2 now I go F2 Rook
F1 Rook F1 Rook f55 no sorry Rook F1
Rook H6
check dud what what is I go King B7 King
B7 that's right and now Rook H7 I need
to drive the king all the way to the
eighth rank you're doing me a solid
favor by driving me there I'm not
understanding anything of this thank you
I exactly and now Rook to H5 is the only
one and now Rook to H5 is again and with
the kings in opposition whenever you
take on to I go Rook to B5 I drive the
King on the a file and that's going to
be a
draw by the way Sam gave check on B I
feel like I'm going to have to go to a
very special training camp this looks
like that's this is the the line that
you said Rook takes B3 and now Rook A1
is the money
move immediately immediately played by
lineer oh my goodness and Sam was was
taken back I don't think he expected
Rook
A1 no he did not by the way that was the
only winning no did not and look yes
that was the only move could he be
trying for F2 here F2
A7 Rook check I
promote yes makes sense mhm I take I
give check and
I'm here I give check again
okay no I if I go into the corner you're
you're you're you're close
enough
right so wait a minute I I apologize uh
sorry so you play F2 right right which
makes sense he's done it now I can't
believe I don't have a v i mean i i a A7
is my only turn move oh maybe you have
King
A4 he's played A7 A7 on the board your
queen is the only move because we're
assuming you there's no Perpetual check
if I go Rook A3 check you take my Rook
you make a queen the Assumption here is
that oh this is absolutely sick what
this oh my God the win is absolutely Sam
is promoting to a queen so we are as
expected a queen is on the board oh my
goodness uh so this is going to be the
coldest of showers that Sam has ever
experienced in his life King
B6 Rook B3 check R B3 check
King King
C6 Rook a or check or Rook A3 I check
okay check King B5 so I walk so I can't
give a check anymore because you walk so
I'm going to to play here and you're
going to play H1 Rook H1 and then it's
the skure this is a this is a well-known
mechanism this is uh the skure and your
your your king actually needs to be on
G8 to avoid that's right the the oh this
is so sad oh Rook H1 right now if go
King D7 I go Rook h8 threatening to to
Pro look at that so wow by two ALS star
moves Rook A1 and Rook H1 as if it was a
Blitz game he knows this he's got we saw
that reaction oh
look oh that's painful you've just spent
three years shower right there three
years of your life writing what you
think is the greatest Rook End Game book
ever printed published ever and then you
lose a rook ending he's so devastated he
just missed this Rook H1
move that's painful
wow that is painful if you tell me lania
takes a sip of
water chasing you off Don't Be Cruel
like that don't be cruel like that wow
what a move Christian that's by we have
five decisive games section that is
incredible wow and and resignation
immediately yes well he recognizes
there's nothing you can do that's it
he's going to play Rook check defend the
pawn and then his King is Waltzing up
the board to win The Rook but guys that
that drowish sequence that we saw is not
easy no no no no
that's once again Sam's reaction to this
move Rook H1 was just oh damn
it chess is cruel it is it's brutal you
miss one move he's he was probably
thinking it's really a draw that he
manag until the last moment until that
move Rook one you think the the king is
going to go to A8 and your king is close
enough to make the
draw and uh as we uh pause our broadcast
we have in studio a very young very
happy Alice Lee over to you Christian
Alice back to back victories for you
you're definitely back into this
tournament as well your reaction and how
happy are you right
now uh yeah I'm pretty happy because
like um I mean just the way that I
started it was uh great for me to just
not continue the losing streak
especially for the round four game and I
think this game um it was kind of nice
for me because it was like I don't have
too much risk of losing um but yeah I'm
very happy that I was able to win it was
indeed a very clean game from uh the
beginning to the end but when did you
feel like you're finally putting the
final finishing touches on this
one yeah I mean to be honest I wasn't so
uh I mean I knew like throughout the
game that I had like a really
comfortable position um especially since
like she went into the end game um I
thought like only I could win I probably
like a two years old um and I think yeah
I mean once she played D2 I was like
really happy because I knew like um I
got into the opposite color Bishops and
I up two pawns but then I somehow missed
like this bishop A3 move and I knew like
I still had to be winning I was still
like it's still much easier to play for
me but um yeah like after Bishop A3 and
then um because it was kind of annoying
uh I played like I probably could have
just played Rook C1 immediately instead
of keny too and that would have just
been like a super easy win um I mean
yeah I mean I was worried that she could
like take with a bishop on F4 but even
so that should just still be a um very
easy win right uh and then because now
your a actually runs down the board yeah
yeah I mean uh actually the seon though
I was kind of glad in the end game that
it was there because you know it kind of
blocked The Bishop's uh diagonal um and
when exchanged the Rooks at this point
you made a right decision to exchange
the Rooks you had to be uh very precise
in your calculation because opposite
color Bishops we know they have a
tendency to be a draw but he calculated
everything and at this point after A5
King d8 and this last moves came not E5
not F5 excuse me but E5 Bishop to E3 and
A6 that's how you finish the game this
must have felt good those last couple of
moves just seeing the pawns running on a
bash and her being unable to stop
them yeah yeah I was actually hoping for
Bishop E3 because if she did Bishop F2
then A6 probably wouldn't be very good
she'd have like Bishop H4 but then when
the bishop got D3 was a very nice like
promotion yeah I mean okay here I'm
still winning I take the pawn but um
it's nice when I you still have some
work to
do yeah yes Alice congratulations
important victory for you what did you
do during the rest day to get back into
this
competition um I mean I didn't do that
much I uh in the morning I did some
School workor uh and then the afternoon
I was like spent a few hours um like uh
teaching at uh the high school for a
community day um and that was really fun
uh after that then I started doing
preparation so it's like not too much
different than like a normal day because
uh the teaching kind of it's like a few
hours kind of similar to the lens of a
chess game um but it's definitely good
because I was able to get more rested um
and get more sleep Alice good job we'll
see you
tomorrow thank you our congratulations
indeed Alice say this round five is just
incredible I mean five victories in each
of our tournaments uh take a take it
away Kate the standings let's see the
standings after round five so we have
two leaders still as was after round
four we have Kar sa and beim toir janova
who both won her games today they have
four points and then we we have a so
sole third place uh for Ina crash with
three and a half points yeah separation
of our three leaders there and in the
open section what's the separation look
like in that one here we have a so
leader Fabiano Carana four points and a
soul second place Hans nean with very
important win today three and a half
points and there a two-way tie for the
third place Wesley saw and lenir
Dominguez both winning their games today
important victories for Wesley and lenir
and for leavon aronian that loss against
Hans nean has pushed him all the way
down in a tie for eight Ray Robson says
Hey tying for eight is great I mean I
don't know about you guys but uh that
Ray uh Ray's Victory today over Jeffrey
was incredibly nice very nice and we
have uh lanir the man of the moment uh
wow with you Christian lenir a final
game that kept us on the edge of our
seats until that last move Rook to H1
and in fact it was a very close game as
well tell us your story and your
reaction to those last couple of uh
final final moves that decided the
game yeah well um I it was a it was a
draw of course at the end I I mean uh I
knew it but uh uh there was this last
trick uh um I was very happy when I saw
it that I have this Rook H1 at the end
and he yeah he went for it so but I
think he defended quite well I mean I I
I think I should be winning at some
point with the two Rooks yes uh but I
think once we get to this Rook end game
then then it should be a draw because
his Pawn is to to I think it was this
moment after the move Knight to E5 when
objectively it's finally we entering dsh
territory oh yeah I thought I was still
winning but yeah maybe maybe not the
case anymore but before that it should
be winning right yes yes before that it
was definitely winning but even this
position we were trying to understand
the ins and outs of uh this end game it
wasn't easy at all and in fact it was
this critical moment at this point after
the move Rook to H4 A6 was already
winning Rook to H4 was the big blunder
King to d8 yeah was the only move that
was yeah no I I didn't I didn't see that
I thought that his intention was to play
Rook H6 and then I saw King C7 and I was
very happy exactly yes because this is
winning and then I realized ah it's Rook
H4 what he wants but then I quickly saw
this line with Rook H1 at the end and
yeah again I was extremely happy I
thought uh now he needs some some kind
of uh study to to escape and but yeah it
turns out he he just didn't realize that
this final position was losing we were
discussing at the beginning of the show
that you know the bunch of 2800s in the
tournament they really need to get some
victories to start catching up with
Fabiano who is right now on plus three
did you feel like this is a must-win
game for you in order to uh still stay
in the
race uh well yeah definitely it helps a
lot uh but uh yeah fa of course uh just
like last year he's trying to to run
away with it yeah it's it's not so easy
when
when he scores almost every day but uh
but okay yeah it's it's nice at least
for me to to keep my chances after after
winning this game great game linear
congratulations guys any questions for
linear not for me just uh wow just great
watching you play lanir this
endgame it's fascinating that he had a
draw with King d8 uh mystifying I want
to say uh but congratulations very
important victory
um keep it
up thank you
absolutely I isn't that incredible that
Rook H5 check was the right move Rook
H6 I have to admit I did not understand
what was happening there I would also
think I'm winning as white but if
someone drew that that would be a
shocker for me me three me three
absolutely uh Christian wrap up the most
eventful round of these US championships
well uh I know who's uh doing an update
to his book tonight and that is Sam
Shanklin because I mean that game just
an incredible defense was necessary with
that move King to d8 that's not easy
stuff and uh I don't blame him for
missing that move Rook to H1 that was
not easy but I have to say everybody is
bringing their aame in this tournament
and you can see so many decisive results
people want to fight that's exactly what
we're seeing they understand that they
need to win they need to score victories
in order to be able to uh be in the race
stay in the race and potentially Vive
for that National Championship just an
incredible tournament so far and I
cannot wait to call all the action with
you guys tomorrow 2023 national
championships are bringing out the best
of everybody in this field Kate it was
marvelous love talking the action with
you and and Christian thank you
everybody for sharing part of your day
with us we certainly appreciate it tell
your friends and family where you're
hanging out and we will see you all
tomorrow good
[Music]
night
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is
prohibited